Testing 123. . . . .
>> Hi, testing.
.  Good morning.  Good morning.
I'm Jane McAuliffe, and I'm the
director of national and
international outreach at the
Library of Library of Congress.
It's a pleasure to welcome all
of you here today for a new
event here in the library,
national Digital Initiative and
I welcome you to the Jefferson
building in the Library of
Congress and I hope you have a
chance to walk around this
building and enjoy its shear
beauty.  Thomas Jefferson
believed that the unhampered
pursuit of truth was the key to
a successful democracy.
Jefferson's own library forms
the core of this great
collection and you will find it
beautifully exhibited on the
mezzanine floor of this
building.  Today the Library of
Library of Congress is the
largest repository of knowledge
in the world.  We are surrounded
here by more than 36 million
catalog books and other print
materials
in 460 languages.  More than 69
million manuscripts and the
largest book collection in
America and the largest
collection of material material,
sheet music and sound
recordings and a statesman,
Herbert Sandral once said a
library is caught in closed
doors.  The people must have
access to the library's
collection to put those in
action.  It's not enough anymore
to open up the doors of the
building and invite people in.
We have to open the knowledge
itself for people to explore and
use, that's where NAYO,
national and international
outreach comes in.  A year ago,
the library created this new
division to make this collection
to better serve the American
people and the world.  NAIO was
created with high aspirations,
aspirations, toaspirations, to
promote scholarships, foster
creativity, develop
collaboration and communities,
and enable everyone to discover
and to learn.  Of course in the
21st century we can do a lot
more than open books.
Researchers can now analyze more
information in an hour than we
can read in a lifetime.  We can
collaborate and share complex
ideas in an instance and we can
empower everyone to participate.
Like all of you, the Library of
Congress is to enable that
vision.  With that in mind, we
have created a new office in
NAIO and that office is national
office of Digital Initiatives
and we have given them a big
responsibility to lead
innovation and maximize the
impact of digital collection.
Not just here in the library but
across the many communities.
To lead this team we have chosen
a dynamic charismatic innovator
Kate Zwaard.  She knows the
library and led the development
of the library repository.  She
is a good communicator and has
been on several committees.  She
expect great things from Kate
and her team.  Today is a
perfect example of what we want
you to do.  Leveraging the the
the library
to bring all of you together,
discussing the best practices
and lessons learned from your
work, taking the next steps and
what we can do even better as we
move forward.  So again, thank
you all for joining us today.  I
am excited about what we can
accomplish working  together.
together.  And now
I would like to hand you over
to the chief of national Digital
Initiatives
Kate Zwaard who will be
here today and for years to
come.
Thank you.  [Applause].
>> Thank you so much for the
warm welcome, Jane.  We are
thrilled that you all can come.
Welcome to the people watching
via live stream from  home.
home.
Please
remember to tweet your
questions with the #asdata.
It's possible to see what we can
discover, we can enhance our
ability to search, visualize and
organize information.  As the
capacity grows, so do the
questions.  How can researchers
participate in data scholarship
and how can the collection work
with research?  We put together
the symposium and among those of
you who expressed interest in
the event, we had interest in
NASA, the episcopal school, and
even the DC public library and
this topic has struck a cord
with many of you.  I would like
to start by thanking those of
you who made this  possible.
Initiative teamInitiative team
that I will introduce you to
later.  This is the first of
many to come.  I would like to
thank Jaime Neer who did a lot
of the heavy lifting to get us
off.  Thank you to those who
donated their time and effort
and thank you to the office
of equal opportunity for
funding the live captioning and
thank you to the volunteers who
helped put this event on.
This event has opening and
closing and keynotes and four
sessions.  If you are watching
via live stream you can tweet
questions using #asdata.  The
video of this event will be will
be made will be made on our
website
and archived at the Library of
Congress.  Don't ask questions
that you don't want mixed
in.  No pressure.
Our keynote speaker just got
back from
Africa to document the live eco
system.  This project is making
all of the data open for us to
explore.
Participating in this expedition
and almost getting eaten by a
lion, is one of many way
Jer Thorp is using data to help
our lives.  In the 911
memorial, placing those deceased
closest to the ones they knew,
using social media and a theater
performance with 120 projects
and collection.  This shows how
Jer is changing from cold and
sterile to interesting and
vibrant.  Even though many of us
have not been able to trek
through Africa, we have the same
mission as Jer in many ways, to
make information through all of
its forms relative to the
public in the hope that it will
improve the earth, cells and
future.
Please introduce the co-founder,
author of creative research,
2013 national
geographic, and director of the
international telecommunications
program, Jer Thorp.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  Good morning.  I think
it goes without saying that I
am tremendously honored to be
here today.  I am a Canadian and
nonetheless, I really -- I am
really honored to be here.
[Laughter].  With this entire
talk this morning, I wanted to
talk about the office For
Creative Research and I put
together a talk specifically
about collections as was just
mentioned, we do a lot of very
different things.  And I was
almost in with the talk when I
read the program for the event,
when I found out that the talk I
was going to give was called
Data and Humans, A Love Story
and it's a title that I did not
make up.  And I said okay, I
will do this talk instead.
Obviously this talk is going to
be about data and humans.  And
start to talk about data and
humans, we must begin I think I
think with I think with data.
There is an
artifact of our understanding of
data as you have seen before,
the pyramid which describes the
progression from wisdom.  I
think the shape of that pyramid
defines a lot of data data over
data over the
last five to ten
years and it is to collect as
much of it as possible and get
wisdom at scale.  I will mention
that we are missing something
at the bottom of the pyramid and
I am not going to give it away
yet.
I'm going to start with a little
bit of wisdom from one of my
favorite people Lisa Franklin
who just passed away.  She is a
thinker and writer and in her
lectures, she talks about the
idea that most of the world of
technology that we live in was
not made with our idea in mind.
This has never been more true.
true.
Sotrue.
So the
central question that I want to
bring to us today, what is it
like to live in data.  One time
we might have been satisfied
with collecting data and at some
point we might have been
satisfied with visualizing it
and more and more and more we we
are we are actually creating
systems and
worlds that we must provide in.
This is a diagram by a
sociologist named Jacob Murano
and it's called a sociogram and
you can think of it as a social
network.  This diagram is of a
7th grade classroom.  Girls on
the right and boys on the left.
Two brave ductors crossing that.
I like this diagram, and I think
about how it would have been
made.  The scientist or the
researcher would have had to sit
in the classroom and watch the
students and the students would
have had to watch them.  They
would have had to would have had
to smell that
teenage smell and learn
people's names and understand
that while these objects are
being drawn as circles circles
and
triangles, they are in fact
humans, how would we do
something like this today?  We
might do it like a research
group in Canebridge,
Massachusetts did, they used a
Twitter API and pulled 600,000
tweetstweets andtweets and ran
them
through sentiment analysis and
attempts to decide which tweets
are sad
orangeorangery and so on.  They
found out the saddest place in
New York City was a high school
called hunter college high
school, which was which was
above which was above the
resiviour and
it shows up as a purple dot.  I
think of what it must have been
like to be those students.
This is a September day and the
day of, you were at
a school in Manhattan and I
think about what it's like to be
in high school and I can only
imagine how weird the students
must have been to arrive in
class.  I don't think the
students were thinking about
that.  I don't think they
understood the data point as
humans buthumans but return
for API.  I tell this story,
they made a big mistake.  The
system they used to locate the
tweets was wrong.
It wasn't actually this high
school, but it was somewhere
else nearby that they had
determined to be the saddest
point in Manhattan.  And I went
and visited the vice president
of the high school and I asked
her, what was the mood
of the students for the first
day and she said nobody cared.
Why did nobody care?  Well we
knew it was wrong because high
school students don't use
Twitter.  And we know that when
we are not allowed to use social
media, we know they are using
it but Twitter isTwitter is for
Twitter is for old people and
nobody in the high school uses
it.  It's kind of amazing.
Right, these guys have gone in
public based on a premise which
was false from the beginning.  I
think thisbeginning.  I think
this examplebeginning.  I think
this example highlights a
lot of our problems.  This
amazing ability we have to
harvest and collect more data
has to be balanced with the idea
that the mechanisms we need to
do so are further away from the
people that we were engaged with
in the beginning.  What is it
like to live in data?  It sucks.
And I don't mean that only in
the majority, I mean it's like a
gigantic vacuum cleaner.  The
word collection is in the title
of today's event, and
collection and gathering is a
neat way, and I think it's a
little more violent where
strengthening and abstracting
and mining data from
individuals, a few years ago --
actually in 2009 I became a
little bit obsessed with these
tweets that people would write
when they landed at the airport.
You were not allowed to do it at
the time.  People would tweet
as soon as they landed.  I
pulled a few from the few from
the feed few from the feed this
morning.
These are statements, there is
nothing really exciting here
they go into someone's life but
there are also data points.  I
know where they just landed and
I know from their profile
profile where profile where they
live, we can reinstruct a
system from just those tweets
which is a simulation of air
travel and this actually came
out of a discussion with a
friend of mine who is an
epidemiologist who is always
looking for a way to model human
travel and we thought we can
model it based on the tweets
that people were making when
they landed on the tarnack.  A A
A week
later, I made this called good
morning.  This is everybody on
Twitter in 2009 saying good
morning.  And you can see the
way they traveled around the
world.  Green dots are people
who get up early.  Red dots are
people who get up late.  I'll
let you see the east coast and
the west coast to make your
decision on which one is lazier.
There is nothing steady
happening here.  But there is
something activating for me to
construct something from
nothing.  And I wasn't the only
one.  Advertisers Advertisers
were very excited about the
potential that we can scrape up
data from people and put it
together in stories.  In 2011, a
couple of researchers
discovered that apple was
storing all of your location
data and it was storing it
unsecurely on your device.
What that meant is that anybody
who knew where to look, can find
a file that says exactly where
you had been since you owned
your phone.  I don't have to
think about that very long to
understand the proxy concerns
here.  But a group of people
that I was working with at the
New York times lab at the time,
Jay, Brian House and I said look
at all of this data, let's get
it while we can.  We found data
at open path, you can find
openpath.CC and the app collects
data from your phone and it's
secure and only you have access
to it.  You can share the data
with researchers for whom this
type of data is gould.  It's
really really exciting for
epidemiologists and urban
planners.  It's almost always
held by private entities and can
we make a collective tool so
people can visualize the data
and understand what is going on
in the world and understand the
researcher.  You can go and look
at the data and see where you
have been and the patterns of
your travel and so on and so on.
It's pretty simple.  But for us
it was experimenting something.
It was an experiment in data
ownership, what happened when we
give people ownership of their
data?  And in this case they
really do have ownership.  If I
wanted to look up your your
your data, I did
for a while, I couldn't, it's
encrypted on the server.
Only you can find it.  The idea
was maybe the data ownership was
a personal relationship with
data and I think we are pretty
far away from right now.  I
think when I say the phrase to
people, they are like what are
you talking about?  There is a
lot of personal information in
the data.  This is a graphic by
by Brian by Brian House
and shows what he calls
meaningful location.  This is
derived from the data and the
the data
knows where he lived, where his
girlfriend lived at the time,
where he practiced with this
band.  The pieces of meaning are
encoded by the data.
I did something a little little
bit different with my data.
These are little arrows in there
and the direction that I was
traveling in and this reads like
a clock on its side so over on
the left here is the beginning
of the day, that is me is me
going is me going to work.
At the time I went northwest to
work and then at lunch up at
the top and down down at the
bottom, I had just moved to New
York, I had just went home.
That is is me is me all over New
York
and there might be some bits
there in the very late evening.
evening.  Butevening.  But the
idea of this was could we make
an artifact that someone can put
up on their wall?  I had this
dream that someone would put
this up on their wall at night
before bed and look up at it and
say, good night data.
It's weird because this is what
data looks like.  This is one
data point.  Another data point.
Another data point.  I moved to
New York City from after living
in Vancouver, Canada my whole
life, and this is the moment I
stepped off the plane at
LaGuardia airport for the new
chapter in my life.  The data
point was that night when I had
a crisp glass of reesling in a
restaurant in Amsterdam Avenue
and I would have for gotten
about it if it wasn't for this
data point.  Five years ago I
opened the door at the end of my
apartment building and bet my
partner, Nora, who is here and
instantly fell in love, and this
point to me, I had this idea
that I will sit my grandchild
down in my lap and show them
this data point and say this is
how this started.  We made some
progress there.  This is my
favorite data point.  Actually
when I wrote this out, I
remember something interesting
that we were all born with data.
This is what we share with our
family and friends.  We share
these numbers and statistics to
prove something and prove that
the child was born.  They are
evidence ofevidence of our
evidence of our existence
and time on the planet.  Any
way, what is it like to live in
data?
I think there is the sensation
for most people that we are
being used and we are being used
and again, primarily by
advertisers so most of the
machinery around data goes
towards placing ads in your web
browser.  Maybe behind the
surveillance is slightly
sophisticated but maybe not.
Most of the effort is being done
to place ads in your web
browser.  I teach a class at New
York University and one of my
students had a project called
cookie job and she took
collections from people's
advertisements and sent them to
strangers and had them write
stories based only on their ads.
Advertisers are trying to find
out about you and give you ads.
Can we turn that around and take
ads and find something out
about ourselves?  At the time I
was working on a project that
allowed me to collect all of my
ads.  This is a month worth of
web ads that I saw.  I sent it
to ten strangers and paid them
ten dollars andten dollars and
askedten dollars and asked them
to write about me.  It was
interesting.
[Laughter].  I learned some
things about myself -- I learned
nothing about myself but I
learned some things about what
advertisers believe about me.  I
am in my 30s and I live alone
and play video games.
I love this one.  This is my
favorite one.  I want to get it
framed.  [Laughter].  So there
is something interesting
happening here.  Advertisers are
collecting data about us us and
us and they
are building these profiles and
making decisions based on the
data and those decisions more
and more are affecting our
lives.  Affecting the level to
which we can be ensured that is
the type of health insurance we
are being presented and might
affect the type of credit card
that we are being offered.  This
tool we built in my studio
called flood watch allows you to
keep track of the type of ads
and allows you to donate the
data to researchers.
Researchers in particular who
are interested in discriminatory
advertising practices.  Places
in which advertisers are
discriminating against on
things that you are not allowed
to discriminate on, age, gender,
race and we are investigating
now and building this tool and
hoping to get tens and thousands
of users so they can collect
the largest database of
advertising data, and just don't
give it to advertisers, so you
can find more about
floodwatch.OCR.NYC.
If you are interested in this, I
will say hold off.  Our next
version is going to be really
amazing.  What we have done I
think in the creation of our
data systems is not dissimilar
to what we started to do or
continue to do with our cities
and Jay
Jacobs, the urbanism critic,
talked about one of the problems
at the time and I think one of
the continued problems in cities
was the lack of feedback for
people who live in cities and
tools like open path and flood
watch are about giving people
who live in data, mechanism for
feedback.  What we want to do,
is be able to give them agency
because one of the other things
that it's like to
be living in data.  What does it
mean to give people agency?  In
man chester we have been
studying with Will Dixon and he
studies pain and a
rheumatologist.  What we found
over the years is that pain
symptoms can seem to be
correlated with the weather.
Right.  And this is confusing.
confusing.
Weconfusing.
We don't really
know why.  We don't know if it
exists.  There had been no
scientific research about this.
We started this project called
cloudy with a chance to pain.
We recruited now almost 10
thousand chronic US
US pain sufferers.  We asked
them to do a couple of things.
See how their pain system
differs from others in the data
set and you can explore your own
experiences compared to
everybody else.  We set up a
system where we we mailed we
mailed people
three e-mails, weekly
visualizations of what the
project was doing so they were
part of the project and not just
storing the data data into data
into a black hole
where it might
never come out again.  The
biggest thing that we did in the
project which I am proud of, we
made a tool to allow the
contributors to the project,
suppose their own hypothesis.
This is called citizens science
projects and  I'm sure I'm sure
you have heard about
it.  They fall into two
categories.  They are either
citizen data collection or
citizen labor that they couldn't
find a grad student to do.  Not
too many of them are actually
citizen scientists.  What we are
doing here is meant to do
exactly that,that, lookthat,
look at their data
and make a hypothesis, and what
we end up with is not only ten
thousand people participating in
the study but end up with
thousands of hypothesis and
tells us what people are
thinking about the conditions
and actually really good to look
at the hypothesis.  Maybe
people are finding something
that we are not able to find.
The idea of putting people in
the drivers seat and giving them
agencies, is super super
important to us.
What is it like to live in data?
I believe one of the primary
conditions of living in data is
to be overwhelmed and feel like
you are living under water.  We
can't really look at our data
systems, because they are so big
and so complicated.  And there
is this idea -- I do a lot of
data visualization and there is
this idea that visualization is
a remedy to this and
visualization can help us with
the complexity.  I can argue
that visualization does not
usually help with complexity.
What it does it getting riddive
complexity but getting rid of
complexity is like sweeping
something scary under the rug.
We don't want to get rid of it.
We want to engage in it,it, in
a way of understanding.  This
is what we have always had to do
as humans.  We have had to
engage in complexing
things.  They might be right or
wrong and at the same time,
they might be one over the
other.  Humans have developed
millions of years of evolution
to do this, and I believe that
the mechanism we have developed
is ours.  And we do a lot of
projects and trials to encounter
this very appealing approach to
use visualization.
For example, this is a map.
Yeah, it's a map, this is all of
the hotels in the world.  There
is 500 thousand hotels and each
one of them shows as a data.
If I wanted to explain to people
what hotels look like in space,
this is useful.  If I want to
explain to people what hotels
are actually like, this is not
useful at all.  So we were asked
by the
Vancouver Art Gallery to try to
develop the complex system of
500 thousand hotels.
Instead of turning to
visualization, we turned to
narrative.  This is an image
that jack Purlack drew to help
understand the journey that the
characters are going to take on
the road.  We thought, this is
interesting, what if we did
this, took hundreds of
characters from fictional novels
and put them in today's world
and tell them they can travel
the same places from the
fictional novels and stay in
hotels.  We dropped people in
the imaginary world, in real
time, continually at the art
gallery for over three months
and during the three month
period, the imaginary fictional
characters lived within the
database of the hotel.  Here
we're going to see -- woops, I
skipped the video here.  These
are the characters of Lolita
driving alongdriving along the
eastern seaboard and they are
about to stop at the hotel for
the night.
They don't have a lot of money
and going to search for what is
is available
in the budget.  On this
particular day, you can see from
some of the returns, they don't
have a lot of luck in finding a
beautiful hotel.  We show the
viewer in the projection, kind
of a combination of photo
documentation from the hotel
itself and also from the users.
We show them the names of the
hotels, we look up the price and
one of the interesting things
about this is that is that it's
is that it's a living
system.  On one given night
they might find these hotels and
the next one, there might be a
football game near the hotel and
there are no hotels  available.
available.
So
they have to drive to the next
town and find a place to  to
stay there.  This idea of using
narratives to frame the complex
data set is something that we
have done over and over and over
again because it does give us a
chance to investigate these
things that are otherwise really
difficult to investigate.  I
believe that if aliens were to
touch down today and try to
understand the culture, they
would look towards the giant
data sets to see what was going
on.  How would they do that?
Maybe a similar tactic done
here.  This is a data set
mentioned in the introduction.
The MOMA permanent collection,
127 thousand objects and we were
approached by MOMA to do an
artist residency to see how we
can base art work about this
data set to help people
understand it, and help people
understand what is the character
of this data set and what is
some of the possibilities that
are in trend within it.  So what
do we do?  Well what do you do
with a CSV.  You load it into a
database and you start asking it
questions so some of the first
things we did was try to look
for some pattern and I wrote a
little -- this takes a title and
takes a title that is similar
and a little bit longer and we
do it again and again again and
again and again and
again and we get these poetic
instructions about the title of
art work.  I like them because
theybecause they arebecause they
are provacative and run
to read.  We are mashing things
together.  I think of it as a
cocktail party where the art
work gets to meet for the first
time.  This art work is like oh,
you're a trapeze girl and I am
another girl from another
planet.  They have never been
able to meet but in some
commonalities in the way that
the titles are structured, they
are able to meet and talk with
each other.  I meant to give the
learning in this talk, that
there is some obscene language
in this talk.  It's not in this
slide, coming up in the next
one.  We were particularly
interested in the structure of
the girl because there was this
sexualization of art and
gendering of art in the titles.
Here is the obscene titles in
the MOMA's database.  It was
interesting.  It came in a
period where artists for a long
time had been trying to
challenge expectations of
galleries.  Here is a painting,
it's all just black.  And now
they accepted that.  The next
step was called -- I'm not going
to read it -- but it's called
something like that.  But mark
Hanson who is one of my
collaborators was doing database
queries, he asked what is the
most common first name of of an
artist in the MOMA database?
The most common first name is
John, there are over 200 Johns
who have awho have a piece
in the MOMA data collection.
Here are the top four.  Here are
the top forty. forty.  Iforty.
I am giving you
a second.  So it was this piece
that really set the tone for
what we were what we were going
to do.  These are names and
what is the natural human thing
to do with names?  The natural
human things to do with names is
to read them.  They worked in
the past with the developmental
theater group.  We decided that
we were going to have 40 minute
performances and essentially the
actors would read the database
in the gallery and do it in a
way that was informative, and I
will play it, and again, there
is obscene language.  And I will
show you right now.  "No title,
shut the world, shut the
fuck up, a bad hand, ass
kicking, food eating, social
climbing mother fucker.  Shut
the fuck up.  The sequel, shut
the fuck up.  John fall,
John Morgan, John Awesome, John
Mills, John
Kicker.  Untitled, Robert.
People read between the fucked
up.  Fuck off, David, I shit
crystal for
you, David.
Paul, Richard, William, Peter,
Charles, Michael,
George, John.  We have the names
of every artist in the
database.
John, Walter,
Edward, Yan, Joseph, Mark, Jose,
Louis,
frank, Atto, Max, Steven, Jack,
Henry, Alfred, Alexander, Andre,
Harry, Daniel, Carl, Philip,
Juan, Bob, Bob,  Bob, Arthur,
Albert, christian, Jim, Bill,
Tom, Chris, Victor,
Todd, Antonio, Roberto, Tony,
Marcell, Jonathan, Boris, alAn,
mark, Ken, Kenneth, Joseph,
Herbert, Eric, Donald, Anthony,
Sam, Niccoli, Louis, Jocque,
Chris, Christopher, Alexander,
Vlad, Vladimir, Steven, Stanley,
George, Norman, Keith, Kenneth,
Jim, Kerry,
Rudolph, Ralph, Frederick,
Fernando, Doug las, Adam, Steve,
Nicholas, Matthew, Jorge, Hugo,
Jory, Francisco, Cardo, Bruno,
Miguel,
Michelle,
Marcus.
SPEAKER:  And how can we act
against people to produce the
data.  It was one of the ways
that I thought was one of the
most possible ways to have it
read and performed.  These
performances are built for these
types of things to be able to
present complex issues issues to
people in ways that don't give
them a prescribed answer but
instead give them a set of
questions that they might leave
with.
This is Manchester where we did
the cloudy with a chance of pain
project that we did before.  I
want to show you another project
that talks about unusual ways
to show data.  We took some of
the data from that study,
actually all of the people from
Manchester and constructed a 50
foot long bar graph that people
can walk under and see the data
and help to sort of guess
whether it's correlated to
certain weather conditions.
What I love about this is how
often do you get to to
experience to experience data
as a collective? collective?
Ascollective?  As a family?  As
a class?  As a group?  I think
that the methods for examining
data through a computer or
phone, the problem that we are
dealing with, data is encoded or
involved in, really do require
us to deal with those things as
a group.
This gave me a new metric for a
successful project which is that
any successful project we do
involving data has to be able to
fit an entire marching band
underneath it.  You know we use
the word public a lot when we
talk abouttalk about talk about
data, I would argue
that most of our engagements
with data are inherently not
public.  They are public in the
way that the white house is
public and not public in the way
that the library is public.
They are public in that we are
told it's for us but we can't
really go in.  We We don't
have the tools or access to do
so.  How do we make public data
public data more public data
more like libraries?  And I
would argue
that it is about understanding
this collective experience.  And
something very interesting that
happened to data over the last
few years, which is that our
public understanding of it is
changed.  When I give a data
talk, sometimes people come up
to me and say did you know that
data is collective and it's a
plural, it's plural and that you
should be saying dataman and I
I am I am saying I didn't
know that actually.  But the
average person does not know
that.  We use it in a different
way.  In society these days we
use it as a mass noun.  These
are some other mass nouns.  So
the way that the average person
uses data, it's something that
is invisible which is very very
very interesting.  And I had the
great opportunity to work with
the poet and photographer and
author, and built a project move
The Game Together and we asked
the Twitter followers, when they
were watching the world cup, to
take a photograph of the
television and make a hash tag
and we automatically centered
the television so they were on
top of each other.  It gives the
idea that there was some
collective experience happening
around the world cup.  Kaku who
is more elegant than I am.  He
says the time of the game is
more of a public time.  I love
the idea of public time and
mechanisms that allow people to
come together, not necessarily
at the same physical space, but
at the same time be able to
engage with what is essentially
a very large data set.  What I
love from this quote, the data
having us have the ability to
testify to each other's
existence.  At my studio we were
working on one last very new
project and I'm not going to
show you much of it it because
it because there
is not much that exists.
What we are doing in St. Louis
is building a community space
where people can come and
develop large scale maps
together about their experience
in St. Louis and to use the maps
to explore instruments of data.
neighborhood and project
traffic information, access to
healthcare, so on and so on.
And the idea here is that how do
we balance maps, this is a
typical map room, a war room
with these once.  These hand
drawn very beautiful maps.  This
is a map of somebody's paper
route when they were a child.
How do we balance maps like
this?  This is the map of St.
Louis that shows the incredible
racial divide that exists in St.
Louis.  How do we develop maps
like this one, the blided
districts in St. Louis in the
1800s.  With maps like this one,
this is a hand-drawn map of St.
Louis resident Gene Taylor and
here I think it lies with, how
do we deal with data?  How do we
present the objective and
lining with the objective?  How
do we present the cold clinical
magnitude of data alongside with
the human story?  I don't think
I have an answer for you.  But
I was doing some research around
this project and stumbled upon
this phrase called geocity.
Compared to what geography which
is what the world actually
looks like but geocity is
studying the world in how people
can actually see this.  I love
moving away from using data as a
purely objective thing, but
instead to understand knowledge
from any and all points of view.
JK Write who came up with this
idea, talks aboutidea, talks
about howidea, talks about how
geocity
is geography or everyone.  I
want everyone to think about
what data would look like if
data was for everyone.  What is
it like to live in data?  It's
to be used, live without agency,
it's to be overwhelmed by
complexity.
What if we were to turn that
around and enter an era of data
humanism where we might first
design data systems for the
well-being of the people from
whom it was taken.  We might,
whenever possible, provide
mechanisms for feedback.  We
might honor the complexity of
individual and reality.  We
might create real and
functioning data public.
Everybody in this room I think
in some case, is a data
professional in a weird a weird
a weird way.
And
I think it's up to us to build
these worlds.  I have been
thinking about this mostly
because I have a 13 month old
son who has to live in this new
world of data that we are all
collectively creating and I hope
if we consider these these
things these things and
primarily do this, we put
another layer of wisdom at the
bottom before we go about the
endeavor of collecting data to
make sure that the structures
that we build are livable and if
we do that, maybe the answers
are different.  What is it like
to live in data?  To be
empowered.  To be engaged, to be
equal, to be given new ways of
seeing -- to be given new ways
of being, and most importantly
to be at home.  Thank
you.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  so much, Jer.  Your
work is powerful as well as
beautiful.  I am a big fan of
love stories, especially that
one.  I love somehow you showed
the research and how the studies
are involved in the studying.
I think it's powerful and
interesting.  This next session
is a bit bit of bit of a treat
for me.  It gives me a chance
to highlight some Library of
Congress staff and partners
whose work I think you about
find interesting and relevant.
I will start us us off us off
and then we will
have Matthew Weber, an
assistant professor at the
school of communications and
co-director of Rutgers net-sci.
Matt and his colleagues Mulligan
and Lynne led a data session
here at the library.  We're
going to talk about the impact
in the web community and last we
will have Deborah Thomas, the
manager for the national digital
newspaper program and Leah
Weinryb Grohsgal, a senior
program officer in the office of
humanities and the officer of
the national newspaper program
and will talk about the recent
chronicle data challenge in
which members of the public used
used data used data in a
national competition.
First I will talk about my team,
national Digital Initiative
about who we are and what we
have done and what we are
going
to do in the future.  That's us,
national Digital Initiative.
welcome from national digital
initiative.  Let me introduce
you to my team.  There is me,
Kate, and Jaime Neer, there is
Jaime, everybody say high, and
Mike, do you mind standing up
and waving?  And Abby Potter,
and also, you guys met Jane a
little bit earlier and also I
think in the crowd is Eugene
Flanagin and Colleen who provide
the structure of what we are
doing.  If you like what you are
seeing, please tell them.  I am
here to talk about national
digital here but I want to tell
a story about the library's long
history of technological
information from Henry Avram who
worked
here and replaced an
analoging with digital records.
She studied in New York in 1919
and did pre-med.  She was in her
30s when she started this
program.  I like this story
because people say if you
haven't been codes since
diapers, you can't do it.  But
that's wrong.  She did it it and
it and
here to change the world.  We
created Mark which holds
information and digital
catalogs.  Does anyone remember
it?  There are colleagues who
don't remember it.  I really do
miss the beauty of them.  And
the smell.  Do you remember how
they used to smell?  That is all
I missed.  They were kind of
hard to use.  Right and what
Henry and the team gave us, is
the power to share that
information across oceans and
search it at a key stroke.
Right now I can sit at my desk
and search the British holdings
at the library.  In the past
that would have been possible.
Searching with a search a search
spring
is easier than looking up eagle
and see that was not the way the
way that the way that someone
intended to catalog it.  It
gave us sharability.
It's the kind of work that made
it interesting, application of
work here made it easier for
everybody's life.  We can swap
catalog records and have joint
teams where we can copy
cataloging and it really really
improved really improved all of
our lives.  I think
of Henryiette as a hidden hero
of computer science.  She is a
personal hero of mine.  She came
from libraries of software like
I did, and took this to home
and heart like I do.  She  She
did all She did all of this
before computers were networked
and before relational databases
were a thing, before character
encoding was really mature and I
would like to take a moment and
reflect on what she was able to
give us at a time when this
sharing of information was very
limited.  And I think I think
also I think also about her
story, story, it shows me the
power
of combining discipline which
she did in her own self and many
of you, you do too.  You have,
you know, your data science
background and you work in
libraries or you are a software
developer who is a journalist
and she did that herself.  We do
that also by having rooms like
this where we share our
knowledge and get to learn each
other.  That is where we see key
changes and where we can
provide cross discipline.  Her
work really started the digital
revolution in information
science and it is something that
we carry forward today.  Here
at the Library of Congress and
also broadly in the field.  I
think about her as the person
who really started libraries'
commitment to open source.  For
those of you that that work that
work in open
software in the library, we are
avid users and also standard
work, we are famous for getting
committees together and all
working together.  Right and I
think it really does lift the
tie and that is the kind of work
that I am really excited about.
innovation can look like a dot
in the timeline, but it's really
not.  People say what was
released to the public in 1938,
but really it was ten years of
releases but it looks like a dot
in a timeline in hind sight and
it still continues to improve
today.  We have teams of people
working internationally.
International standards that now
contain character support for
all currently-used languages.
It's this thing that continues
to blossom.  And I think about
that in relation to other work
here at the library like
lock.gov.  It's another dot in
the timeline but actually
continuous improvement.  We add
new collections all of the time,
my colleagues in OCIO and
library services put in an
enormous amount of work to
release the new treasures to the
public.  Just this year we
released a lot of new
collections including George
Patent's diary, the art ethnic
project and Walt Witman's paper
and I want to take a second to
look at this release.  We can
look at any other collection
like the ball room instruction
manuals, you should check them
out, or the 2014 elective
archives and I picked this one
because it's really special to
me and really exciting.  Rosa
Park's personal papers are in
the library for ten years and
contain 7,500 pieces of paper
and 2,500 prints and photographs
documenting her right for
activism and civil rights for
African Americans.  The
materials came here and assessed
and stabilized by the LC
division and categorized in
libraries.  Files were moved by
people in software, they were
assessed, validated and assessed
for access, met data was
transformed and rights were
assessed.  That is a few years
worth of work in less than 140
characters.  And those of you
that are librarians in the room,
you know this is just a job.
You know, a bunch of work to
make the information signable
and usable.  I want0 it make a
big deal out of it.  We make a
big splash for cool new websites
and exciting visualization but
the sustained and careful
efforts that it takes to get new
information out is something
that I think we should really
celebrate and I think it also
speaks to something that I have
been talking about which is
intention and sustainability and
I think about this in terms of
lock.gov and the sustained
effort it takes to getting new
collections ready and the
enduring power of mark and other
bibliographical standards and I
think of Henryiette as my
shining beacon because she
believed in the power of
infrastructure and
infrastructure and it's
something that I can get really
excited about.  I think
infrastructure is really cool.
It's the road we all drive to
get to interesting places.  And
national Digital Initiative can
become the cool new group.  But
I don't want to do that.  I want
things that lift the tide and
have a beautiful future.  With
that all in mind, as we were
doing our planning for national
Digital Initiatives I would like
to share the goal that we came
up with today.  First is to
maximize the benefit of the
digital collection to the
American public and to the
world. We have a lot of stuff
here at LC.  We have a lot of it
and a lot of and a lot of it
and a lot of it is
publicly available in digital.
We have 10 million historical
digital newspapers.  We have 1.2
million prints and photographs,
we have the personal papers of
George Washington, Lincoln,
Regan, Jackie Robinson.  We have
this really awesome team here
called Educational Outreach and
they spoke on K through 12
resources and they prepare
resources and help teachers get
material out to their students
from the library.  And I like to
think about how we can extend
the benefit that they give to
advanced scholars and to the
public and the curious and how
do we teach a new generation of
journalists to come to the
library forlibrary for reference
library for reference help
and resources.  I think that
would be the kind of thing
exciting to work on.  We would
like to create reuse of the
collection, the great mustache
of LOC.  I tried to grow one
today for example, it didn't
really work out.  People use
these for mugs and T-shirts and
and it's and it's really neat
to see that kind of economic
benefit for things that are in
the public collection.
And it's also fun and exciting
and it brings people to the
collection too, which is great.
But it also serves as an
important scholarly purpose too.
Back to the Rosa
parks collection in which this
has this powerful note, I felt I
have been pushed around my
entire life and at that moment I
couldn't take it anymore.  This
note gives incite as to Park's
heroism in heroism in America.
Other pictures show more as a
human.
And I love what was picked up
from the press and food bloggers
and I hear it makes great
pancakes.  How is it?  Anybody
tried it?
Peanut butter I think is the
secret ingredient.  But the
pancake paints the better
picture for us, that she was she
was a
person with family and friends
and was a real person and really
inspires us to think about the
power that we have, just being
ourselves and thinking about,
about, you know,about, you know,
what we can do and I think also
it brings people into the
collection.  So people read on
their favorite food blogs, this
thing.  And I hope it inspires
them to learn about Rosa Parks
and can bring them into the
collection.  The second goal we
have is to incubate,
encourage and promote, and we
have a really small staff.  I
like, it helps us focus and be
agile and do new things.  And I
think of it as an interface to
the outside world.  I used to
call it a membrane but I got
weird looks for that one. one.
People
told me to stop.  stop.  It's
the standard, thinking about
projects that are relevant to
the library and also being
involved very closely to the
library colleagues and what they
are working on and what they
are interested in and helping
the communication between those
two.two.
How manytwo.
How many of you
remember chemistry class?  This
is one of my favorite energy
diagrams, reactions, as you know
thermic reaction happens
sometimes and they need energy.
That is true with many of the
projects here.
We have great ideas, we have got
tools but we need a little bit
of help getting over the hurdle
and we can be the catalyst and
we are not the enzyme but what
we do have the power of, is
knowing people, knowing
technology and being able to
connect folks.  Sometimes a
little bit of application of
effort from an outside team at
the right time can get the ball
rolling and I think we can help
provide that.  I would like to
say that libraries are poor.
Right.  We are not Silicon
Valley but we are scrappy and we
like each other.  And that's
our power, right?  We are like a
stream over a bolder.  Our
problems may be moveable, but we
are many, we are focused and we
have a
very long memory.  Most of our
folks are building relationships
that lead to partnerships and
we hosted an
exciting event that brought many
librarians from all over.  And
we also we also hosted
unleashed
a few months ago.  In the
interest of no spoilers, I won't
talk about that because Matt is
up next.  I hope that I can
tell you a quick story about
that.  The teams were made up of
scholars, programmers and
librarians which is kind of
unusual, a difference from a
classic hackathon which is
mostly programmers and that
collaboration ended up being
really exciting to watch.  And
we had one team looking at some
some of
the Supreme Court web
archive data and were getting
result
froms a text analysis.  There
was a librarian on the team and
said I know a little about the
contours of the data and the
reason you are getting this is
blah blah blah.  There were
weird artifacts and he helped us
instruct a query for the
results to play out the way we
expected.
And I think that is the power
that the library really has in
data science.  Where else can
you go to get the data?  But
also to talk to someone that
really understands it intimately
and helps you understand your
research.  research.  We
are also working on a concept
for a digital scholars lab.  At
the Library of Congress we have
the John W.
Center which hosts colleagues
around the world to work on
collections and create a
community together and share the
results of their work with the
policy makers and the public.
And we are thinking about how we
can help support them with
advanced digital scholarship
research with the partnership of
the staff.  To that end we have
engaged with two outside
experts, Dan Shedonoc and
Michelle Gallagher.  Thinking
about something lightly that we
can reiterate over time and we
hope to have that report out
once it's completed and hope to
have something to share with you
soon.  I would like to
introduce you to Tom Wong and
Chris Adams, our inaugural
digital innovation fellows.
They are doing a fellowship that
is focused on demonstrating the
use of digital collection and
we hope to broaden the applicant
pool in future years.  Keep a
look out for this.  Biking will
not be a requirement.  That is
just a coincidence.  If you
don't like biking, don't worry.
And lastly this meeting today,
as you can probably tell the
theme for the year was
collections as data and this is
the cap stone of the of the  of
the event
where we invite you to chat all
together.  This is a particular
love of mine and I am excited
about it.  We are also exploring
more opens about creating open
source and share tooling.  How
do we evaluate and help with
technical skill building and
help with shared infrastructure
where we can have an effort to
get a large result. result.
So contact us.  We are small.
We are new.  But I am proud of
what we have been able to
accomplish already.  I hope
today that you will enjoy this
reflection of speakers that we
will put together.  I hope you
are excited to hear from them
and get the opportunity to make
friends with each other and get
to know them.  And think about
Henryitte AvramAvram andAvram
and see the power we can have
over the events.  I look out in
the room and see hundreds of you
and importantly see a network
of people that can help make new
ideas.  Thank you.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Good morning.  I'm
Matthew Weber, assistant
director in Rutgers University
and I am assistant director in
the Department of Communication.
Thank you for inviting me back
after the chaos that we created
in June.  I had the privilege of
being here in June with my
colleagues Ian Mulligan and
Jaime Lynne who are at the
university of Waterlou in Canada
Canada to Canada to host the
archives unleashed event. event.
It'sevent.  It's the second
generation.  I
want to tell you about archives
unleashed and what we want to
accomplish and why this is such
an important movement and
initiative for
engaging with collections in
data.  So archives unleashed is
an agenda and Jimmy and I put
together to assess the essential
problem of web archives being a
tremendous untacked resource to
scholars and something that has
tremendous potential for
research and we are well aware
of what we can do with them.  We
came up with this idea a little
more than a year ago when Jimmy
and I were at a reception, and
as we do, afterwards at the
reception we were standing
around a bar table and drinking
a few beers and talking about
the data sets that we have and
talking about how under utilized
the data sets are.  We said we
have to do something about this
and better educate people and
undo the power that the data
archives have -- we have to
unleash the archives.  Come on
guys, we have to do this.  And I
I should have run away
screaming at that point because
low and be hold, we came up with
a way to show people how to
utilize archives as a tool.  We
saw this opportunity to develop
a form for researchers to engage
with archives and learn about
the ways in which this can be
utilized in the research
agendas.  Web archives are an
amazing resource and access and
tools for utilization are often
a problem.  We are seeking to
address that.  We are seeking to
keep calm and engage in data.
Our vision behind is this
interdisciplinary and the goal
in this is highlighted, to bring
together different researchers
from different backgrounds
because in part, we realized
that in order to create and
bring researchers into the fold
to work with web archive data we
need to put together different
disciplines.  Point in case, I'm
a communications scholar and
historian and Jimmy is a
computer scientist and we come
from entirely different
background and we speak entirely
different languages as
academics and yet together in
the same room, we are able to
work with data and create
meaning out of that data as we
collaborate.  I am going to
borrow a story that Ian likes to
tell because I think it's part
of the conversation that we are
starting to have here today.
Ian comes from the world of
history, and I come from the
world of communication research
and we often, in the discipline,
look at data and look at the
data that we're given as a black
box.  Look at the way the data
is collected in the black box.
It sits in the box,
It sits in the box, we
go to it and say look, I need
some data on newspapers in the
United States.  Give me what you
have got.  And the data spat
out to me and I use it and I
create research and I never
really asked how that data came
to be.
What we started to realize is is
is that
we need to open that black box
and why it's so important to
have the different disciplines
represented engaging with one
another is by opening up that
black box, we can start to ask
important questions about what
the data are, how the data came
to be, and what some of the
under lying assumptions are and
how the data can better be
utilized in research.  I was
very excited to see Jerry's
slide on the Napa hotels in the
world, because I think it it
under it under
scores the problem of needing to
better understand what actually
the data are and how they came
to be and what they mean and how
we can better utilize them in
research.  Let's put this into
action.  We came up with this
idea that in order to better
educate researchers and better
educate scholars about the ways
that web archives can be
utilized in research, we need to
create a venue or scholars to
come together and exchange ideas
and educate about the tools
that are available.  We quickly
realized it takes an army.  We
have been fortunate to have a
lot of collaborators in the
initiatives.  We have support
from our university and Rutgers
university and from the
university of Waterlou and
the Library of Congress and
University of
Toronto and I can go on with
this.  I am amazed for the
people willing to support us in
the endeavor.  We came up with a
two to three day event where we
invite
academics, largely graduate
students, faculty, librarians
and we start with introductions
and start by getting people
networked and engaged with one
another and break people out
into teams and have people come
up with presentations about what
people did.  Let me show you a
little more about what that is
and what that looked like.  I
will highlight the last two
events we posted and the first
two events we posted. posted.
Theposted.  The first
was archives unleashed one in
March and the second was
archives
unleashed two, which was in
June.  This is academics in the
room together and starting to
engage with one another and
mingle.  What we do is bring the
40 or 50 scholars into the room
and assemble the archives
unleashed event, the data sets.
In the case of the event we
hosted at the Library of
Congress, we had a data set of
Supreme Court hearings.  Web
archives pages about Supreme
Court Supreme Courts and we had
archives about the elections.
We had Twitter accounts.  We had
donated collections from
Canadian government.  We put
these collections out there.  We
put the team -- the individuals
together in the room.  We asked
people about what people are
interested in.  Jimmy and I took
on this role to try to assemble
individuals as a team to focus
on particular on particular
questions on particular
questions whether that
be sentiment analysis, event
detection.  We were able, at
both of these events, formulate
the groups of of four of four to
five
individuals that would then
spend the next few days together
working on a research question.
In order to help lubricate the
process, we believe in the
importance of socialization and
it's critical for the event that
it's not just everyone in a
room and we are getting getting
everyone
out and engaged socializing
with each other.  We get
everyone out to a bar and
engaged socializing with one
another.  We do the
fun getting-to-know-you games
and then we come back, day day
day two, day
three and we put everyone to
work.  We spin up virtual
machines using donated computing
resources.  We allow the teams
to have access to high
performance computing needs that
they need to quickly analyze
and crunch the data.  We also
bring social scientists.  We
bring communication scholars and
historians to the table so we
can also be asking critical
questions about what the data
means.  We have a lot of
applicants who will come to us
when we put the calls out to the
event.  They say I don't have
any technical skills but I have
interesting questions that I
want to ask about the archives.
We want to be asking the
critical question of the data
that are be abstracted from the
web archives.  We have lightning
talks where we offer scholars
an opportunity to share the work
that we are doing.  Again, to
build the community and to help
each other engage with one other
and then ultimately at the end
we share the work that we have
been doing.  We come back
together at the end and present
on the research that we were
able to generate over two to
three days.  This is the photo
of the group that came together
for Library of Congress and in
just a couple of months since we
hosted the event, we have been
following up with everyone who
participated and it has been
amazing to see how teams have
continued to stay in touch with
each other and carry on the
event.  The research agendas
that we started in the student's
three-day workshop.  We share
and engage and ask questions to
each other based on the research
research we research we
generated.
We formed connections.  I am an
academic and researcher and I
can't help but study the
research that people bring to
each other.  And I study the way
people bring in collaborations
and mapped out socio grams,
metrics, the way that people
archive at the event.  This is
the Toronto event.  Think back
to Jer's image of the 7th grade
classroom.  This is the scholars
engaging with each other and
forming connection over two to
three days and something people
who you would talk to and
exchange ideas with before the
event and who you had exchanged
ideas with after the event and
we formed very close knit groups
out of this and close knit of
clusters of researchers.  And
also we pulled individuals to
see if they were satisfied with
the experience, satisfied with
the engagement and we we are we
are patting
ourselves on the back  back
here.  back here.  People
walked away generally happy and
feeling that they have walked
away across barriers.  We also
saw some really cool research
coming out of this.  It's only
two to three days but we are
able to generate incite since
the data we have gained access
to.  Kate mentioned the Supreme
Court data and this is a word
cloud visualization of the URLs
that were in the Supreme Court
data and you start to have some
interesting head scratching
moments, for instance, you see
doubleclick.net and this is
where you have the head scratch
moment where you say I am
looking at Supreme Court data
and this is where it's helpful
to not only have the computer
scientists and then you have the
collection to start to realize
that there is quirks in the data
and clean this out and pull out
double click which is an
advertising hub and advertising
website and able to abstract
more valuable meaning on the way
the websites are connected.  We
are able to generate world
clouds around the confirmation
boat.  To see a little bit as to
how people were voting,voting,
whether
the confirmation candidate was
being supported, not supported.
Also to see some of the key
words that were emerging and the
themes emerging around the
candidates based on the text in
the archive web pages.  Only two
to three days.  This is an
initial snapshot here.  We are
also able to move a little bit
further.  I mentioned team
looking at terrorist networks
and ISIS Twitter data and they
were actually able to take this
a little bit further and found
that there were particular types
of Twitter accounts served as
amplifies on Twitter to amplify
certain messages and themes in
the conversation and able to
identify the characteristics of
the Twitter accounts based on
the data that they had
available.  We are moving
forward now, we have an event
planned in San Francisco, and we
have a 4th event planned at the
British library in June of 2017
and we are working on building
a sustainable model for this.
The work has been driven by
myself, and Ian and Jimmy and
the collaborators that I
mentioned at the beginning.
Moving forward, we need to
create a broader educational
model and educating researchers
and librarians about ways to
open up access to the data saids
and so Kate referenced archives
unleashed LLC and we are
working to create a nonprofit
organization around archives
unleashed, to build a more
sustainable model to bring in in
interdisciplinary teams to
engage with the web archives and
create the necessary skills out
of the data sets.  We have the
models that will move us beyond
the archive unleashed event and
build us under the momentum that
has been created so far.  If
you have questions about the
event or would like to learn
more, I would be happy to be the
point of contact, shoot me an
e-mail.
If you replace the
.com with.CA, you can see the
2.0 projects that it up as
well,
and also linked on
archivesunleashed.com.
Thank you for having me here and
thank you for listening.  I
really appreciate your time.
[Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  slides for us?
Oh, cool.  Thank you.
Thank you.  Good morning.  A
round of applause.  Yes.  Good
morning, I'm Leah Weinryb
Grohsgal and I am senior program
officer in the division of
access at the national
endowment.  This is Deborah
Thomas who is a program manager
for the national digital
newspaper program at the Library
of Congress.  MPNP represents a
long-term effort between the
two agencies between chronicling
America which is a historic
database newspaper.  We talked
about the efforts.  This is the
culmination of sustained
efforts.  This builds on the
U.S. newspaper program which is
the effort to micro film the
newspapers before we awaited
that.  At this point we have
millions of digitized newspapers
and contributed by territories
across the country.  One of the
best things is that the Library
of Congress has made all of the
data open and created a
well-documented API to explore
it in a number of ways.  It's an
incredible collection of data
waiting to be used for
scholarship, research and
education and public
programming.  I am here to to
tell to tell you
about a successful contest that
I ran at NEH to help
chronicling in America.  Deb
will talkwill talk aboutwill
talk about what is
available and after that, I
will explain the challenges.
Deb?
SPEAKER:  Thank you.  I
made the magic happen.  All
right.  So well this is
newspapers, historic newspapers
in particular and I am just
going to showto show youto show
you a
few -- I am going
to show you a few examples of
newspapers.  It may or may not
show up on the screen.  At any
rate, newspapers have something
in them for any kind of
discipline or humanities study
or social sciences.  As you can
see from the images in the
background, there are
advertisements, advertisements,
there are news articles
on scientific events.
There is economic articles.
There is geniology and
literature.  Any kind of thing
that you want to study can be
found in historic newspapers.
The growth of the national
digital newspaper program in
particular was to enhance access
to American newspapers.  Our
whole goal with the program was
to create a national level
collection of what is currently
today a distributed collection
across the United States.  The
Library of Congress has a large
connection of American historic
newspaper but it is not the
collection of American historic
newspapers.  The American
historic newspapers is actually
archived in state libraries
around the country so using
digital technologies we are able
to bring this material back
together again through
the
partnerships with the national
down with humanities.  We have
created digital resources and
collective content through
states.  Eventually we have to
cover all 50 states and
territories as they are able to
participate.  The structure of
the program is focused around
shared resources.  We share the
cost of programs along with the
national economics and
humanities who provides funding
from each state to digitize
materials from their state-based
newspaper collections and they
digitize the collections
establishment by the Library of
Congress and the Library of
Congress receives the data and
aggregates it for the long time
and makes it available to the
public.  One of the key focuses
is focusing on pace scaleability
so the national library can
make this last into the long
term and to ensure the data we
get at the end of the program is
usable with the data that that
we that we get at the beginning
of the program.  So we have
gradually increased the size of
the program.  We started in
2005 and now we have 40 states
and ter
ritories.  We focus the
structure and the resources for
planning planning ahead
for technical change and
sustainability in the fact that
we have ensured that, through
various mechanisms, the data
that we receive is all fairly
consistent.  We have a very
detailed specification, which
has been has been described as
richly detailed.  And we have a
fair level of confidence that
this material is in fact going
to last into the future and
whatever the next form that
digital data needs to take to be
usable in a system of the
future, we can move it in that
direction as a whole data set
and we won't be dealing with
every individual piece from 50
producers.  So this was out of
the chronicling America website,
LLC.GOV -- no, it's chronicling
chroniclingAmerica.LOC.GOV or
from the Library of Congress
home page.  It provides access
to searching the newspapers and
browsing them as well. well.
Thiswell.  This is the
user interface available.
This is a map of the states
participating in the program so
so
far.  As you can see, it's
happily very green.  We are
still working on filling in all
of the other little spots.  But
this year NEHNEH just
announced grants to Alaska,
Colorado, Maine and New Jersey.
We are very happy to have them
join the program and joined the
other 40 states and territories
including Puerto Rico and the
district of Colombia which the
Library of Congress represents
Congress represents which
is all available on the
chronicling America website.
Currently the status of the
website, today we have 11.3
million pages online.
That is approximately 75
terabytes of live storage and we
have archives kept off line.
We have 44 states and
territories participating in the
program.
We have representation content
from 40 states and territories.
We also have, in addition to the
actual digitized newspaper
pages, one of the tasks of the
awardees when they select the
digitized newspapers, that they
want digitized, is to create a
500 word essay about the
significant historical context
of that newspaper.  Why was this
one particularly important
enough to make available to
digitize what is available.  We
have 1,100 of the essays that
have been written by scholars
and knowledgeable researchers
researchers  researchers and
librarians around the country
that really put the newspapers
in their place and time and
explained why these were
significantly important content.
content.  In content.  In
addition, just
the 11 million pages represent
2,100 different titles.  But
that -- I talked a little bit
about,
one of the goals of the program
is create the amount of content
available through the program
and through the Library of
Congress website that the
selected amount of content, we
are only working with 2,100
titles so far.  Out of the 153
thousand titles published in the
United States.  That gives you
a sense of the scales of the
newspapers in the United States.
This is going to be a slice off
the top and hopefully it's a
very research and valuable slice
to research and scholars.  And
in addition, for reasons of
sustainability and
archiving, we have digitals
that were created during the
archiving process.
Just a sense into what this
allows you to do, the site has
two main features.  One is
digitizing newspapers which are
full text searchable at the page
level.  You can search by
place, time and key word which
which is which is really
the important thing when
looking at newspapers.  You have
a certain amount of information
about every issue and page and
can navigate within them.  You
have visual search highlights
that are in red.  I don't know
if you can see it on the screen
or not, that indicate where your
key words are in the page and
gives you the chance to zero in
individually to see where your
articles interest and where your
results may be -- you -- you
may -- you may be willing
to spend the time zooming and
panning into the material.  In
addition, there is the ability
to manipulate the image on the
screen and make it full screen.
The other kind other kind of
other kind of
data which is part of the
chronicling America website is
the U.S. newspaper directory.
directory.  directory.
This sort of
forms the backbone of all of
the newspapers that we might
want to digitize and represent
the program that Leah mentioned,
the USMP program, the United
States newspaper program, which
is to identify catalog and micro
film the nation's newspapers.
All of the records cal logged
in the program, were identified
and cataloged and stored in
world cast which is part of the
OCLC data set.  OCLC makes that
data openly harvestable and we
have put it on a
newspaper-specific interface for
users to find out about
newspapers that have been
published in the United States,
even if we don't have the
digital copies available.  The
records have information about
who held them,  elsewhere,
elsewhere, it's
in the records.  And provides
more information for resources
than -- more information for
researchers than enhancive
access to newspapers across the
country.  So the U.S. newspaper
directory is also searchable by
place, time and key word and it
includes website links to
individual locations where the
materials may be found.
Finally, well not quite finally,
what is available and how is it
available?  Leah mentioned open
access to the data.  What that
means is that the data is
available for harvesting or
reuse outside of the individual
interfaces that we provide
through the website.  So we have
digitized page images.  We have
optical character recognition
which is machine-readable text.
We have meta-data which
surrounds every page and and
issue
in a standardized Mets format
for mod description
characteristics, which describes
the place and time of that
particular issue, as well as the
newspaper directives.  All of
this information can be taken
out of the site and analyzed in
different ways for researchers
that don't involve the actual
website.  So the ways that we
make the data available is
through open API as well as
through the public website.  We
provide stable URL that are
helpful for many reasons.  In
particular, they are human
readable so you can project and
predict what the next URL you
are accessing could be.  There
are machine-readable views like
JSON which makes it a bit easier
to play with this stuff.  And
there are preset data sets that
that we have that we have
created specifically on the
request of researchers who
really just wanted to access the
OCR for example so we have
created the batch downloads that
people can access and take away
for use and manipulation.  And
now I will turn it over it Leah
to tell you about the specific
uses that can be made.
SPEAKER:  Thanks Deb.  So you
just heard about the incredible
amount of data that we have
available.  And the number of
ways that researchers can access
it.  Chronicing
America is one of the best
known resources that have been
used by NEH and the Library of
Congress.  As a historian
myself, I used the site well
before I came to NEH for my own
research.  The site is used
heavily through the user
interface and there has been a
few large scale digital
humanities that are cool to look
at.  We want more people to use
the data and at NEH we decided
to host a context to get people
thinking and creating about
different projects.  We used
challenge.gov which is a
platform by the federal
government to host competitions.
It's around since 2010 and it's
part of the government agencies
to promote innovations using
prizes and challenges.  This
asks the public the question,
how can you use data to explore
history?  We left the parameters
broad and we encouraged
participants to be creative and
see what would interest them and
see what they can get through
the open data.  Projects that
create map, visualization tools
and were able to mash up
chronicling America in order to
get the results.  Because the
chronicling America database
covered so much in the pages
from north to south, east to
west across the country from
various cultural standpoints, we
think the sky is the limit.  We
have got many interesting
entries.  I don't have too much
time to go go deep go deep into
each
of them but a short look at the
six winners will give you a
brief variety of what we got.
You can find more information
about the winners of the project
on the NEH website if you are
interested.  The first prize
winner was Lincoln
Mullin, American bible
quotations in U.S. newspaper.
It quotes biblical newspapers to
see how the bible was used for
religious and political purposes
and how how it was how it was a
text where you
will find sermons in Sunday
school lessons that are
distributed across the country
but you find the bible used in
every side of issue including
slavery, womens suffrage and
capitalism.  Next we had a tie
for second place.
One second prize winner Andrew
Bale, American lynching.  This
uncovers America's long and dark
history with lynching,
America's catalyst for public
killing and platform for reform.
There was information from
Lynchiing from Kuskegan
University and used to give
information from America through
visualization and also wants to
connect that data through the
stories of the victims.  Sorry,
I didn't distance the slide.
That is a quick look.  The other
second price went to Amy drew
and Jason Drew for the
historical agricultural news.
This is a search tool for
exploring information on the
farming technologies and
America's practices of the past.
The group sees farming as a
look into America's history
including social, economic,
political and cultural.
Additionally see their project
by focusing on big data.  By
narrowing down into one subject
area, have created a useful data
set that can be kind of
abstracted from the massive data
in case people don't know what
to do with it, because there is
so much of it.  So the
challenges third prize went to
another team, Christi palmer,
Caitlin Poly.  And this passes
the geographic distribution and
the positive and negative
connotaiton overtime and all
have chronicling America and
show the work that you might not
expect.  And they left it all
open so anyone inclined to do so
can put another word that they
are interested in.  Other prize
went to Claudia and Sont.  They
made a really good point when
explaining the origins of the
program.  Many use Google Emgram
viewer to track books across
the United States and many times
books are published and come
out in multiple editions,
potentially screwing the results
depends on what people were
talking about at a particular
time.  The newspapers capture
the public discourse almost
better than anything else.  This
site is is build is build on
the chronicling America data and
allows
users to discover patterns and
watch news go viral, so to
speak.  For example you can
track terms like
scallowag which gained current
s in the 60s.  And also ray
Palin and
Sentaped high school in New
Hampshire for chronicling
America.  These students used
word frequency analysis for
patterns and news coverage.
They broke into teams and news
that caught their interest,
interest, for example
Ferguson, uncle Tom's Cabin,
the KKK and the labor union.
According to Palin, it was
similar to writing a paper in
that students had to identify an
important historical question
and research the answer.  Using
data however, allowed them to
learn a whole different set of
skills than writing a research
paper.  I realize I didn't have
much time to go in depth in the
projects, but only provide
teasers, the vast array of
context represented.  I think
these hold several collections
for those of us who hold data.
I have been interested in the
type of projects that come out
of chronicling America before
working at NEH and as a
historian I used the site for
civil liberties, union groups
and free speech.  It's one of
the only free accessible sources
for the community.  This
collection holds so many
possibilities as a data set and
it was good to see this
challenge.  Many of the winners
officially told us that they
were happy about the contest
because it gave them a deadline
to do a project that they wanted
to do for a long time.  It may
not be possible to always host a
contest like this but it might
be a good thing if you want to
gather a group and stir up
excitement about it.  I want to
call attention to how many teams
we had as well.  Also it's
important people are working
outside of the lines and I think
it's important that we can.
Mr. Palin pointed out -- what he
pointed out extends well beyond
the lessons in secondary school
that he is teaching.  This
intellectual work involves as he
pointed out, similar
questioning and identifying to
any research and should be
valued in the academic community
no matter what you are doing.
Finally I think the contest
points to the the
importance of any collection
with maintaining contact with
the communities processing the
process.  Not just putting the
data out there but trying to
understand how people are
inclined to use the collection
and learning from there at the
same time that they learn from
the collection.  Thank you very
much.  And we are happy to
answer any questions, you know,
during the course of the
reading.  [Applause]
.  Hello.  Thanks everybody.
We're going going to going to
take a
quick 15-minute break.  Let's
be back at 111 o'clock.  We are
live streaming so we need to
stay on schedule.  We will be
back at 11 o'clock to talk about
collections as data.
. .
SPEAKER:  We are
getting ready to start.
Welcome back everybody.  This
is a reminder we are live
streaming and if you want to
participate online, use the
#asdata.  Additionally, some of
you have the handouts today that
were kindly prepared by our
colleagues in collections and
services about possible
resources that researchers are
interested in using collection
as data might use. Can we pull
up the blog post please?  So if
you go to our blog which I had
on my slide earlier,
blogs.LLC.gov/thesignal.  Those
of you watching remotely, you
can access from the blog site.
The next part is developing
methods for development tools.
Elizabeth Lorang has been
working with the chronicling
American data sets to hold not
just answers but message return
research for all.  An associate
professor and humanities
librarian at the university of
Nebraska-Lincoln
and also doing research at UNL,
her experience includes
immunity and research and used
the NEH funded project that
seeks the potential for
discovery and digitized
collections.  Next we will hear
from Ricky Punzalan from the
college of human studies at the
University of Maryland and
includes dynamics of utilization
and digitizeing in settings and
he also provides reunification
of dispersed archival
photographs online which he will
speak about.  Also closing the
session is Mark Bouslog who uses
the largest platform for
people-powered research and
discovers research that was
previously considered
impossible.  His research works
includes the relaunch ofs and
let's get to work and let's
introduce Elizabeth Lorang.
SPEAKER:  Good morning everyone.
I would like to thank our
organizers and our
hosts for the opportunity to
share work with you and also the
opportunity to hear about the
projects that you are all
working on and the conversation
that all of us can have over the
course of the day.
The project that I will be
talking about today has been
possible only because of the
contributions of the research
teams past and present.  As we
are talking about the work
today, I want to acknowledge
that team.  I would like to
acknowledge professor Lee Katz
as well as my former under
graduate student Grace Thomas
who delivered to this project in
key ways.  I couldn't be more
excited that grace is now on the
staff of Library of Congress
and has been here for about a
month now and also able to be
here today.  So my presentation
today is in three parts.  First
the statement of a problem or
challenge that I think we face
working with digital collections
and working
and developing digital
collections and also something
that me and my teammates are
working on to address that
challenge in a different way and
also the long term of where we
are headed next.  The first part
then is the challenge, and the
fundamental challenge that we
are working to address is that
all of the wealth of the
digitized information available,
finding the information
relevant remains difficult for
most cases.  The challenge
documented most recently by
Green and Courtney and 2016 and
scholars working with digital
collections of materials, the
authors found that one of the
most prominent challenges in the
collections was the inability
to search effectively through
the collective material and the
findings align with other
studies over the past couple of
years that show the difficulty
of finding items in digital
collection and also the degree
to which more fine-grained level
of significant detail can be
significant for successfully
analyzing for us.  The
difficulty of finding material
and relevance arises in part
from one reason, the level and
degree of description of items
and collections.  But the
difficulty of finding materials
and relevance is also due to the
ways in which platforms and
interfaces engages with and
describes access to materials
including text-based searching
and even when there is an API
for most people, that is still
going to be a barrier to access
of some sort.  Addressing this
challenge of connecting people
with items of interest is going
to require efforts on multiple
and creative fronts.  In
response to this challenge, my
team, the image analysis for
archival discovery team is
focusing on the digital images
and collections rather than the
machine-readable text.  Our work
is based on two beliefs.  The
first belief is that locating
relevant material and digital
collections is often a difficult
endeavor and will be
increasingly difficult and
second, we leverage potential
for the millions of images that
we are creating as we digitize
the records.  The question is
what more can we do with the
digitizing records and what
intents might the digitizing
yield?  Both aspects are
increasingly interesting in
image-based methods for
identification and discovery.
One significant area of
development is an area of image
recognition and image searching
of primarily visual work
including art work and mass
photography, such as photos
posted to online platforms.
There is increasing array for
computer signs for application
in the industry.  The emphasis
however, is very much on images
of art work and contemporary
photography and items that we
understand first and foremost to
be visual work.  As my team
engages with these questions, we
are interested in what, in
turning the focus to image
analysis of textual materials
and looking at the digital
images of textual materials.  In
returning to the title of my
presentation, we are interested
in what happened when we look at
text from images.  The slide is
in an unsophisticated fashion
to show where we are with
computer vision versus
contemporary photography and the
archive and discovery.  The
first image is an image of a
slaw through Google search
images to not only see the
results that I can get, but
Google knew what it was not
just sloth.  I got right to the
key.  So if we contrast that
with an image of a 19th century
letter that went through a
similar process and the results
I think are a little more
varied.  The images look kind of
like the image that I
presented, but the sense of what
I am interested in at this
point is being tweeted as items
that are handwritten.  We can
see the real potential for that
to be able to pull out the
collections that are
handwritten.  But if what I am
interested in certain types of
handwritten items that have not
been described?  Here is an
example quickly of a newspaper.
And again, the recognition was
pretty good.  I think enlarged
part, these are the fact that we
have so many digitized
newspapers and digitized from
microfilm.  But I want to look
at the fourth exam which is a
poem that I cropped from a
newspaper image.  I was not
expecting to crop newspaper
images from poems.  I am one of
the few people that does that.
There is not a huge part of them
at this
point.  But there is a goal here
between what I think is
interest of what would be the
possible results.  First and
foremost, this is recognized by
the Google search at this point
as me being interested in
handwriting and it's not the
case here.  Also as I was not
expecting to find newspapers as
a result.  I was thinking that
maybe there would be some
printed poems, the range in the
Gulf of that effectiveness of
these sorts of searches thus far
from something like
contemporary photography to
wanting to find specific types
of items within digitized
collection.  There is an
emerging body of work in the
arts and humanities interested
in the visual signal or
analytics in the text material.
Recently had analyzed image
poetry and images and also the
archives allows the users to
explore the archives by drawing
the shape of a poem and search
poems in similar shape.  It has
the potential for thinking about
textual materials and
particularly the visual is the
meaning maker of the text.  Both
of the projects however, begin
with known preselective items
from a purpora and they are
starting when we know what we
have here an item of interest.
My team and I are extended
analysis approaches for
extending discovery and this
takes us to part two of my
presentation.  Sort of the
experiment that we are currently
working on.  So our work now
looks at whether we can identify
poetic content based on
historic signals.  We are using
the collection of chronicling
America newspapers as a source
and we want to see whether or
not the newspaper features any
poetic content and where it is
on the page.  We have been
ambitious in our goal to
digitize as little poems and
finding articles that have
multiple-linked poems.  To see
if this works, we have created a
classifier from newspapers that
feature poetic content and not.
qualities that we believe are
important, translating them into
development features and
setting a set of sample images
where we knew the ground truth,
whether or not the image
contained poetic content or not,
compiling the features for both
set of content and making them
into an artificial network and
finally testing the classifier
on unlabeled images.  We
published earlier results in the
work last summer and at the
classifying training stage, we
received provision and recall
under 95
percent and precision showed
how many times we were correct
with poetic comment and recall
showing how many times we
correctly identified poem images
out of poetic images.  The
numbers dropped when we tested
the classifer under 75 percent
and 62 percent.  But we decided
to under take a larger case
study.  We did not want to
overfit our approach for such a
small set of images that we used
for the initial test.  So at
this point we know we have more
work to do but we didn't want
that work to reflect only the
very small sample.  We have
recently under taken work to
look at a much larger set of
images.  Specifically we moved
to a case study of chronicling
America newspaper for 1836 to
1840.  We have two goals.  One
is to scale the system and the
second is to test the accuracy
of the classifier on the set of
data.  We focused on the
five-year period 1836 to 1840
because at the time it
represented the first
chronicling in America work and
we now that we can find a
specific amount of poetic
content from this period.  The
first step in the process was to
develop the script from
batch-retrieving images and now
we have a script that allows us
to perceive the images, we were
working with parameters at this
point but in the future we will
add parameters as well through
through
the city or the state.  We
received nearly 22 thousand
images, all images from 1836 to
1840 but chronicling America is
rapidly growing and we are
working with a subset of five
years.  Getting the page images
was the most straightforward
part and it was not without
complication.  The system that
we developed for evaluating
features does not actually
process the entire page at once.
Instead we process a full page
image as an overlapping image
snippet to see whether those
snippets feature poetic content
and in the earlier stage we
created the images manually and
now we needed an automatic
approach to the process.  We
needed to make sure that the
images themselves are good in
order to increase the chance
that we will have accurate
classification.  We developed a
process for evaluating all of
the page images to see if they
can be effectively segmented and
against several set of rules,
something that we did
automatically and then broke
each of the pages that past into
the subsequence of it.
Approximately 8,800 page images
passed the presentation process
and yielded 500 thousand
snippets and the images go
through a series and process
from the images on the screen
and we capture the images and
that is what we use to measure
the features and do the feature
extraction.  The work is still
very much in process.
And while we don't have big
results just yet, hopefully we
will by the end of October.  We
do know a few things at this
point. First we learned about
the historic pages as well as
the duplicative process that
bought us to chronicling
America.  A variety of factors
about whether a page can be
segmented, the videos, the
number of illustrations and
number of text expanding in the
columns and the micro digitized
image.  We know that we want to
know at a high level of accuracy
how good our classifier is.  We
need to know the ground troop
of the pages and the snippet.
We could have done some sampling
but at this page, it's a
research project and we want to
know at an accurate level how
accurate the classifier is.
This meant that I manually
classified the 8800 pages so we
can classify.  According to the
work that I did.  Of the 8,800
page, 1678 of them contained
the poetic content and 1,000 of
them did not.  Again, the
machine
learning pages that are at the
snippet level and the machine
learning suggests that there are
4,440 pages creating poetic
content which is much higher
than my poetic
classification and we overlapped
on 785 pages.  We know that we
have work to do here and where
we are headed next is to do,
first we need to then be able to
look at the snippet level which
means that I am evaluating the
90 thousand snippets to
determine the classifications
and we can do a detailed
analysis on where my
classification and the machine
classification agree and where
they differ and start pulling
some things out from that.  So
this is why it slowed down a
little bit at this stage.  Once
we have the manual
classification and the machine
classification we will begin the
work of deriving detailed
statistics and thinking about
the ways in which we can further
improve the classifier, that
might be techniques to make sure
that we are not quite as
aggressive in returning snippets
as truth.  We can look for the
only concurrent snippet that is
classified as true, for example.
And then we will have to see how
accurate the features that we
think are important for
signaling poetic content turn
out to be.  We will be turning
to an understanding of what we
get from our classifier results.
We will be analyzing the data
set, and doing some written
analysis and doing an
early-stage look at how our
classification for newspaper
content and languages other than
English compare with our
classifications of newspapers in
English since 1836 to 1840 and
that includes some newspapers in
Spanish.  We can start testing
this idea that the image-based
approach for textual material
should be language diagnostic.
So in the longer term then, and
I will hear both -- when I
created the slides last week, I
felt compelled to talk in
fairly-broad terms and only
yesterday I learned that the
research team received IMLS
funding to continue the work and
we have a short course for that
work.  We are embarking on a
new partnership with the
colleagues at the University of
Virginia where we seek to
broaden the software among
digitized newspapers and reforms
and make the broader sense of
image analysis for
classification, identification
and discovery and retrieval in
distinctive libraries.  Given
the potential for scholarly
impact, we seek to have the
poetic confidence and cross a
number of boundaries including
graphic, temporal and
linguistic. linguistic.  I
can talk more about the work
that we are doing in the grant
but ultimately, hopefully the
work will help develop the
collection, prerelease and post
release of the collection.  We
seek to work with librarians to
help and classify materials and
have the researchers' ability to
impose new questions of
digitizing.  We hope that this
works and creates more
interfaces that allows users to
use query collections beyond the
text-based search and themes
such as publications.
Before we can get to the
interfaces however, we need to
create the under lying data as
well as broaden the sense with
what is possible with what we
can build and this will require
us to work with text and image
as well as to see text as image.
Thank you.  [Applause]
Okay.  Hello everybody.  I
really appreciate being here.
You know, I am one of those
people who is basically a
librarian through and through.
I have a bachelor of science.
And at 18 years old I decided to
become a librarian.  At the
Library of Congress -- I am from
the Philippine so it's a
pleasure to be here of the so if
anyone is watching, I am here
it's awesome.  [Cheers and
applause].  Okay.  Enough about
me.  Let's talk about
reunification which is one of my
passions.  First I would like
to preface this conversation by
talking about, you know, the
digitization has become a
fundamental responsibility.
When I say this occasionally I
will get nasty looks from other
people because they don't
appreciate the idea.  You know,
we have to wake up.
Institutions are expected to be
doing digitization, I know that
there are resource disparities
but I teach introduction to
archives and I am now expected
to teach my students, putting
digitization as part of archival
practice.  So this is part of
our realities right now.  As
cultural heritage institutions.
With digitization we facilitate
the discovery, impact.  There
are studies that indicate
that having a digital, will
help people discover and use
resources more broadly.  We are
providing digital product.  We
are rethinking our work as
heritage institutions and it's
also redefining what it means to
perform library archives and
museum work.  It's also -- this
conversation of conversions and
collaboration has been happening
even before digitization and I
think digitization is one way to
ensure that institutions are
truly collaborating by sharing
resources and expertise.  So the
way we handle the disperse
collections into the archival
community in the past is that
first we acknowledge them in our
finding ways, saying this
collection is also found in five
other institutions and
sometimes we are comprehensive,
sometimes we are not.  Another
thing at the theoretical level,
we try to
expand notions of ownership and
what it means to have records
in our custody and finally, we
are using technical standards
and tools in reconnecting and
linking collections together.
Here is one quote from 2001 by
Janette Bash and she says
standards such is the DAD have
the fragmented collections in
creating distributed collections
through the online linking of
finding aids and she is talking
about this in context of the
records of U.S. Virgin islands
and to move to move contemporary
times, we hear the term virtual
reunification which is a very
short definition would be
allowing the dispersed
collections to be brought
together.  It's a highly
collaborative endeavor and will
allow multiple institutions and
multiple scholars in various
disciplines and multiple
expertise within cultural
heritage work.  It has the
digital.  The problem with many
dispersed collections is that
it's almost entirely impossible
to reunite them in the physical
format because one, you
encounter geographic
limitations.  Things are in far
places.  Physically, sometimes
materials are, you know, in
different formats and quite
challenge to be brought together
in the digital form and also
have the diplomacy.  In some
virtual digitization projects in
Europe, it involves multiple
institutions or national
institutions.  Here is some
examples of virtual
reunification projects.  There
is many out there.  These are
some.  My favorite is the Walt
Whitman archive and I am sure
it's familiar to many.  It
brings the work of one person
and also, you know, from various
institutions and trying to do
multiple ways of engaging with
the material.  Reunification is
bringing together the whole
collection, it has its deep
roots in the analog world,
specifically in the humanities.
You know, in art history there
is such a thing as catalog
reasonates or in music, complete
works and in literature you
have scholarly conditions and in
history, we have what is more
related to archival work,
historical conditions.  We have
going to different authorities
trying to collect all writings
of Thomas Jefferson, for
instance.  So there is
a long scholarly trajectory of
bringing together projections.
There is lack of attention to
photographic materials and there
are projects out there looking
at image processing and battle
recognition.  There are projects
that, you know, would exhibit
photographs, for instance, but
they are not at the particular
scale where you have them from
all over the place, different
institutions and multiple stake
holders and truly, you know,
bringing them and doing
scholarly work with those
materials.  It's also a way to
do the
repatriotion, making it through
digital needs.  But there is no
returning to what it truly means
of something that digital.
More through success and less in
barriers.  When I read the
literature on this subject
people are saying yay, we did
it.  It's difficult.
Congratulations to us because we
have done it.  But actually, we
learn from barriers, from
projects that tell us that these
are the problems that we
encountered.  So that when we do
it again, we know things to
expect.  And also it's unclear
about institutional
collaboration.  When ten
institutions are involved and
one of them is let's say a
historical society in one county
versus the Smithsonian, there
is imbalance between the
resources and prestige in that
project.
So there is a lot to, you know,
be done and discuss in the
barriers.  And in the world of
digital
repatrization,
anthropologists studied that
there is a problem with the
notion of returning copies of
artifacts to native American
communities.  Is it really
returned?  Is it really
repatration.  Not all
communities want it to be
returns to them.  Many are happy
with the digitals that they can
use in the classroom.  There is
really not one solution to the
issue.  Where does the  return
happen?  Is it for the community
or the scholar community that
they are referring to?  So my
project looked at the photograph
taken in the Philippine in the
early 1900s by colonial
administrator that was assigned
in the Philippine Muster.  He
was a
zoologist and because of his
interest, he started to document
the different groups in the
country and in the process,
managed to amount the cache of
photographic materials.  Here
are some examples of the photos.
And here is more.  So the
rational is that for us to be
able to manage this new
territory called the Philippine,
we need to understand its
people and more importantly we
need to understand their
resources so we can trade.  So
that was the whole premise
around the surveys that he did
in the early 1900s.
So the photographs of
Muster are currently in more
than ten institutions but I
looked at ten institutions for
this study.
There is an effort to
consolidate them in the 1970s by
doing, you know, like a union
catalog of some sort where they
are located.  There is a
research demand on these
photographs and it's in various
stages of digitization and there
is some funding available for
this.  And yes, reunification is
not happening.  So I said this
is probably an ideal case to
study and examine, you know, in
a context where something is
likely to happen and yet it's
not happening.  What is stopping
it from happening?  That is my
particular question at that
time.  So I went to ten
institutions that collected
these photographs.  Two of those
are -- I would classify as
natural history museum.  Four
are anthropology and museums,
two are archival institutions
and archives who are special
collection.  You will see, and I
will get back to this, that in
these multiple institutions, you
know, the photos are different
formats, and different types of
state or states in terms of
digitization.  You know, you go
back to the idea of, you know,
if you want to bring something
together that is dispersed.  Who
decides on behalf of the
communities when only
institutions are talking?  How
do you display the images when,
you know, if you want to produce
something scholarly, another
problem that I have seen is, you
know, there are many
dimensions.
When you say, I am really
finding something that is
disperse.  Are you referring to
the physical distance that they
are scattered.  Are you talking
about temporal sort of
discussions because they were
dispersed at different
moments in time.  Providence
and I am using different
providences from the ownership
and material.  And there is also
the challenge of material.
Here is one digitization, the
elementary one that I created
for myself to show you some
notion of dispersesdispersing of
geographics in different
places.  It can be
providential.  In one
institution, it's
done through the pathagrapher by
the museum of natural history
and the museum of anthropology.
Sometimes it's dispersed and
does not go in one direction.
It's also
temporal.  It was given to
different institutions.
And the earliest collection as I
found was at the national
archives.  And also materials,
sometimes the photograph would
be in a scrapbook.  Sometimes
it's a lantern slide.  Even if
you compare two scrapbook
images, are put in different
chronological order or two
different scrap books.  There is
a lot of researchers that are
interested in the meaning around
the changing of this, you know,
chronological representation of
the photograph.  And also among
institutions that I have
interviewed, they seem to have
this notion of you know, we
can't show these photographs to
everybody, so we have to make
sure that not, you know, we are
more responsible around, you
know, who gets to see the image.
So as far as these institutions
are concerned, you have to see
it first because they need to
work on the collection and the
source communities of course,
the different groups that take
ownership of the images and
researchers and scholars and
maybe the Phillipene immigrant
communities are living in the
U.S. so it's a different notion
of access.  I know that many
information professionals are
very much in love with universal
and hindered access.  But it's
just not the case for
ethnographic collections within
the community.  So finally, I am
leaving you with three
questions.  The question is,
what does it mean to assemble
the whole?  There are many
dimensions to dispersspersing.
Getting all of the dimensions
together within the project.
What is the object of
reunification.  Sometimes we
actively care about fixing
relationships, fixing
relationships with communities.
Is that what we want?  The
outcome is that we have good
relationships in communities
that the material recombination
or assembly of these things are
a way towards that.  Another is
the solution, what really is the
problem.  Is this sometimes,
you know, I hear of available
technology that will solve
things and do a lot of things
for us.  Is this a solution in
search of a problem?  So thank
you very much.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  Can you duplicate or
split the
screen by chance?  I think the
web
developer would
know how to -- thank you.  All
right.  Perfect.  Well on a
personal level, I may be the
most surprising and unlikely
person today as
not long ago, I went to the
library to escape the chaos from
my 1-year-old daughter of
combing but programming books,
to build an app of my own.  I
had recently resigned from a 10
year career as an accountant and
auditor to pursue a passion for
web development.  Shortly
thereafter I started my current
dream job as a web developer for
Zooniverse.org and it's a
surprising tool that will unlock
the data of your collections,
in one likely ways that you will
not imagine likely for the
Zooniverse.  It's one of the
largest platform and Zooniverse
team members have orthodox
backgrounds and PHDs in if
economies, humanities,
philosophy, there is data and
research through the
ambassadors.  Today I want to
introduce you to the diverse
projects that focus on
transcription projects and give
you a brief overview of the
project builder.  It all started
with galaxy zoo in 2007.  Like
many
astronomists, there was more
data that they can classify
before they can ask the
interesting question about the
universe.  One of the
classified, going insane, or
spend the rest of their life
identifying.  The pattern
recognition for the initial
classifying that humans excel
at, while computers yet do not.
The solution was to harvest the
resourcing.  It has the
information classified as
historical or realistical.  The
results were incredible.  There
were over 150 thousand people
contributing and it was
eventually determined that the
crowd source consensus was as
good as classifications shown by
professional
astromomers showing that we have
gotten it right.
Some of the volunteers are
listed as co-authors, regular
everyday volunteers.  Galaxy zoo
otherwise thought was
impossible.  It gets more
exciting.  We had a legendary
guitarist, Brian May who is a
PHD
astronomer and we have a PHD
teacher from the Netherlands.
The researchers looked into her
question and turned out it's a
galaxy sized glass cloud in the
neighboring galaxy that recently
shifted from active to quiet.
Scientists knew of it and never
captured the phenomenon.  Was
the first person in history to
witness it and was named after
her.  It illustrates that the
more people you engaged in your
project, the more likely someone
will make an amazing
serendipitious discovery.  Each
project has a perform where we
can talk with each other as well
as volunteers and experts.  In
the project, the first
discussion is for specific
images and the next is general
questions and there is specific
discussions that are unique to
this project.  Now, we often see
the serendipitious discoveries,
and a key to a successful
project is that the research
team engages with the volunteers
through talk.  This is the
current landing page of projects
and since 2007, there is over
45 active projects with several
hundred researchers that have
led to over 100 peer review
publications.  The galaxy zoo
papers have had thousands
citations and reuse of the data.
The galaxy zoo story encapsulate
three stories that I want to
emphasize.  The volunteers will
conclude to the success of a
project and crowd sourcing is
more about serendipitious
discovery and reduces accurate
and reliable results.  Science
galaxy is a transcription
process that relates the
historian scientists and the
scientists of today.  With a
camera, they had to draw what
they saw.  The drawings have
been locked away in the pages of
the Victorian articles, and
today through science gossip,
they can unlock the origins of
the citizen science.  What may
have taken a diligent historian
over ten years, it's
accomplishing news that we
thought was otherwise practical.
One volunteer found the image by
Maple Roads and asked in talk,
if it was the first female
contributor and her question
inspired the community.  They
discovered numerous illustrated,
included many uncredited.  One
volunteer's question brought the
collection to life in an
amazing and
unexpected way.  One of my
personal favorites where you get
to rely on penguins for science
and you tag
penguins in
regions and you can see the
winner of the context in the
lower right.
I'm not sure that all of them
are volunteers that shared that
level of enthusiasm.  But the
number one reason that the
volunteers do participate is to
participate in the scientific
projects.  They are fascinated
in a project or it's just plain
fun.  We have more than 1.5
million volunteers in over 237
countries ranging from age to 5
to 95 years old.  It's an
endeavorous group making real
contributions to science.  My
personal favorite is volunteers
capturing hundreds of images
from national parks providing a
powerful new window into
Africa's most elusive wildlife
species.  It was incredibly
successful.  In the first three
days alone, and projects the
back laws of images and there is
a creative publication that
shows that the crowd is as good
as experts in the consensus
scenarios compared to the 98
percent accuracy in other
scenarios.  Again the crowd gets
it right and personally, I know
the difference between the
harder beast and the wilder
beast.  To collaborate what I
mean by consensus, Snapchat has
the 25 images and ten agree,
thereby reaching a consent
issues.
The volunteers are on the
right.  And those can agree so
far there is one drafting the
images.  While this image is
challenging, one volunteer
thinks there are four
wilderbeast, and the other a
buffalo.  The certain image is
just not possible to get
consensus and 25 people will
classify.  Experts can't agree
on these images and though these
images are the minority, most
or over 70 percent of the images
are retired with the consensus
before getting to the 25
classification maximum.  Now we
will focus on some
transcription
projects starting on data,
museums of the web top prize
winner.  In addition to creating
art, many artists wrote diaries
and letters that contain sketch
books that contain details
about their lives and processes.
Volunteers transcribed these
processes from the data
collection and revealed the
secret lives of artists.  I like
to have the artist work open in
one window and classify in
other window and gives
appreciation for the art and the
artist themselves.  For
documents such as this, OCR
doesn't work.
Which is why we need to
transcribe them.  Transcription
can be quite challenging.  It's
not as straightforward as
clicking on a penguin but we try
to make it as straightforward
and simple as possible.  We
utilize the transcription
method.  I am going to refer to
it line by line.  And we don't
ask volunteers to transcribe an
entire page or even transcribe
the entire sentence.  You simply
ask them to transcribe one
visual line at a time, that they
feel they can do in confidence.
This creates a quality and
collective effort.  Each line's
XY coordinates transcription is
paired with an algorithm
creating consensus and reducing
the need for experts.  Today's
rate of accuracy is 95 percent
which is in line with OCR
accuracy which is 94 percent
for gray scale and 93 percent
for bitonal.  Again, showing the
rates.  In collaboration with
the library here in Washington,
D.C. and under transcription
project that we love called
shakespear's world and helps us
understand his life.  With the
line by line process, there is
added complexity for the type of
historical document.  What we
have learned with this project
as well as others is that if you
have a great UI for volunteers,
they can accomplish complex and
difficult transcription.  Again
it helps to break the
transcription process down to an
approachable level.  Documents
are provided between recipes and
letters and for those
interested in delicious dishes
or juicy gaps, I prefer that
it's fascinatefascinat
fascinating.  And there is a
wonderful blog that updates and
shares great stories from the
project.  Next transcription
project is decoding the civil
war.  You can witness the United
States civil war by
transcribing and discipling the
method and codes by the United
States military telegraph
including one from Abraham
Lincoln, two weeks before the
death.  It's incredibly
interesting and it's other
telegraphs requesting whiskey or
clean under wear.  It beguns
the
gamut and it's a remarkable time
for the team in history.  And
hopefully you can see in the
variation, this is a method from
the previous transcription.
Volunteers we had asked to do
telegraphs before proceeding.
An additional method that we
worked on years ago in
collaboration with the public
library is scribe.  The method
of scribe is that one marks the
structure and a different
volunteer does transcribe.
Scribe is open source like
everything we do.  I encourage
you, if you want to do a
transcription work, check out
scribe.  It will be helpful for
you.  There is also what the
Smithsonian uses where one
volunteer transcribes and an
expert reviews it, and there is
feedback on that cycle.  There
is no right or wrong method.
The method depends on the
project.  Going back to decoding
the civil war, this was
recently launched within the
project builder.  A little over
a year ago, we launched the
project builder to create a
project and it's incredible.  We
are really proud of it.  Right
now anyone can build their own
project for free in hours.  Go
to Zooniverse.org and you're on
your way.  It's a detailed
tutorial and message boards
online, if you would like to try
it yourself.  This is a screen
shot.  Don't worry about the
details shown.  My intent is to
give you a general deal for the
interface.  In the menu from top
to bottom, we have the project
section, the work close section
and the subject set section.
Likely your collection,
typically in our case, images.
So we are in this video.  You
can upload subjects into the
project builder and we support
hosted images.  It can include
meta data and other IDs that can
either be shown or hidden from
volunteers and once you have
your subject set into the
project builder, you can then
create what we refer to as a
workflow.  It's the sequence and
task that you ask volunteers to
do and we have many types of
task including text tasks
especially for the transcription
projects, drawing tasks, drop
down tasks.  Some are behind in
experimental flag.  So ask and
we will enable you.  Also the
workflow editor, you set the
subject for how many times it's
classified before it's no longer
shown to volunteers.  So once
you have the subject set, you
have completed the core of the
project.  Here we see what a
volunteer sees while classifying
within the notes for the nature
project where volunteers
transcribe the labels that we
recently relaunched after
rebuilding within the project
builder.  I worked closely with
this project.  It has been a
wonderful experience and has an
incredible research team and you
can see two text tasks to where
a volunteer can collect the
name and number, and then three
drop-down tasks to enter the
month, day and year, all that we
referred to as a combo task and
this is an example of what you
can build and what a volunteer
can then see.  With the project
builder you can also add other
collaborators or people to help
you.  You can add content for
the learning page or create the
team page or research page to
give details about what you are
looking to accomplish.  You can
create tutorials and field
guides to help volunteers
classify.  You can set up the
incredible talk that I mentioned
earlier happened.  And you can
export aspects of your project
that happened such as volunteer
classifications such as on day
one or whenever.  The review
process can be featured on the
main page and you can share a
link with it to anyone.  A
successful project articulates
the purpose well as
straightforward and simple as
possible, detailed help for
volunteers and an active
research team that helps
significantly.  So the
Zooniverse is expanding at a
speedy rate especially with
transcription projects that we
love to collaborate with you on.
We are working with experts to
further our research to make
sure that we are not wasting our
volunteers' precious time and
we are open on mobile.  We are
open source.  Check us out on
git hub.  We want you to help
you join us and find science
that you thought was otherwise
impossible and won't make you
jump in the antartic seas but
you may end up in there.  And on
a final note, we are also
thrilled to announce two
upcoming open calls for partners
with text or audio
transcription projects, custom
tools or interfaces.  It's hard
to express how excited we are
about this.  The open calls are
made possible by the three-year
efforts to better support this
community.  As part of this
effort, we will take the lessons
learned through the new
custom-built projects to include
the tools that we offer to all
through the project builder.  So
thank you for your time today.
SPEAKER:  So we're going to have
time for questions.  Liz and
Ricky, if you want to join us up
here.  During this, we have
about 15 minutes or questions
and if you have a question and
you're in the audience, raise
your hand and we will have
volunteers with
mics that will find you.  I see
we have one hand raised in the
back already.
Also on Twitter if you are
following along, you can tweet
your questions using
##asdata.
I'm going to mention this
quickly because we're going to
for lunch right after.
We're going to break until 1:30
after the question round and
just a reminder, if you leave
the building, you have to pass
through security to get back in.
So come back.  Plan for that if
you leave the building.  If you
don't want to leave the
building, you can go to our main
cafeteria in the madison
building.  And if you meet by
the information desk, a library
Congress staff will help you go
through the tunnel, so just that
quick piece before we start.
Do we have somebody with a
microphone in the back here?
Do you want to start back here?
Smithsonian library, the
Smithsonian transcription center
and the national museum of
African American history and
culture.  We launched recently a
transcription project
transcribing the freeman's
bureau records, the era of
federal documents and we
launched it just a little over a
month ago and my question to
the last speaker is what kind of
incentives do you offer to your
volunteers to continue with the
process?  How do you deal with
with some of with some of the
difficulties or the challenges
with the transcription?  What
kind of system do you have to
keep them going?
SPEAKER:  So yeah, the
transcription is challenging.
It's difficult to keep
volunteers engaged.  We have
found that talk in the community
that builds around these
projects is really the strongest
way to keep people
engaged.  And not only helps
people ask questions or get
through the difficult challenges
that might be related to that
specific transcription project,
but it also helps people explore
interesting ideas that they may
have.  Usually people who are
getting involved in the
transcription projects have the
interest in the material
of course and they may have,
you know, they come to to it to
it with
interesting ideas or ways,
perspectives and when you have
people sharing this together
through our forum talk, it just
builds on
itself.  And that is what keeps
people engaged I think to the
highest degree.  We don't have
any other -- like occasionally
our research team might have
like prizes or you know, give
aways and whatnot.
But that is not really the core
of it.  I mean, in all
honesty, one of the things,
people participate and continue
to participate because they want
to further the purpose of the
project.  So our volunteers are
primarily motivated.  And they
get kind get kind of get kind of
hooked into
it.  And once they get a little
practice transcribing,
they often continue to.
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Great,
we have another question here.
Yup.  Go ahead.
SPEAKER:  Hi, this question is
question is also question is
also for the
last speaker.  For the tool
that you mentioned and I am
actually really interested in
your audio tool.  Are you
limited to what language you can
apply this to?  Like if I have
a collection on straight check,
would that work on that?
SPEAKER:  Well so, I have to
check -- so I am kind of just
thinking out loud here.  We can
can build like a UI that can
subscript.  That would be a
custom -- I'm not sure if we
currently have that capability
but that is a potential project
that could be feasible and we
have lots of plans including
internalization so if we were to
incorporate that on like a
global site level, it might also
complement a specific project
or collection and keep that in
check.  Yeah.  So you know, I
don't think we --
well, support that today but
the technological barriers don't
seem too large.
It's the wonderful thing about
the recent funding, we can
explore these types of
challenges much more easily now
going forward.  So I have to
check to give you a specific
direct answer of what we can do
today.  If we can't, we hope to
in the future.
SPEAKER:  We have a couple of
questions from you. you.  you.
SPEAKER:
Hi.  I also am interested in
the project of the last speaker
and I am coming at it from a
peculiar angle, I
spent time as a volunteer as a
senior living residence and
everybody is limited in what
they can do.  And everything
successful in that environment
until now, has been seniors
seniors  seniors doing
English language teaching using
Skype with students from around
the world.  And that is super
successful and and I
can imagine some version of
this can apply in that
environment as well.  I am just
thinking, is there a possibility
that there  would be
let's say a simpler interface
overlaid on what you have now,
so that people have a lot of
time on their hands but limited
abilities could be effective and
useful and have some productive
activity in their own life.
SPEAKER:  Yeah.  Absolutely.
The projects really run, there
is a wide range of difficulty in
the projects.  Some are out
there right now and I guess I
should be embarrassedshould be
embarrassed toshould be
embarrassed to admit this
but I am not.  My favorite is
the penguin lodge and Snapchat
which are very approachable and
while some certainly are more
complicated like some of the
astronomy and transcription
projects, there are some that I
think wouldn't be very
accessible to like the people
that you are
working with.  And sometimes we
will, you know, we do a lot of
educational outreach too, so we
do try to consider making the
project successful to as many
people as we can.  That is an
interesting area.  I'm not sure
if we fully considered it.  But
I think right now, there would
actually be some projects
that might apply.
SPEAKER:  You have a question
here?  Here we go.
SPEAKER:  Hi.  I work for data
storage company, and often we we
we think about how you're
going
to store all of this stuff.  So
all of you store mountains of
data.
Right.  You are working with
that all of the time.  So my
question would be, how do you
possibly store all of that, and
then how long do you store it?
And then how is it similar or
different for each of you
because you have such
different projects?
SPEAKER:  So for our project, at
this point, we have a
manageable amount of data
because we are maintaining the
images after we have processed
them.  And then the features
data set.  I am not in a
institution that has a data re
repostory and the expectation of
the institution will be the
place that manages that data and
we work with deepen, as one
example.  So we will we will
have we will have to see.
We are -- our needs are not
necessarily for, it's not
preservation forever.  We are
looking at managing the data for
reproducibility for X number of
years and I think I think at
this point I think at this point
it's
five years.  So since we are
not the collectors of the
original images and we don't
need to maintain the digital
images.  It's not to say that we
may not run into some
challenges but I feel like
institutionally we are in a
pretty
good place for that.
SPEAKER:  Well I do have copies
of some of what I study and I
believe to keep stuff safe.  So
I put them in multiple hard
drives and I also have copies
that you know, I use for basic
processing and work so I have
digital pile with a better
resolution and more preservation
copy.  So I teach introductions
to visual
digitization and I follow the
model of what I teach.  But I'm
not -- I definitely don't have
collections of the level of
repository that would make, you
know, large corporal materials
such a daunting task.
SPEAKER:  We actually also --
we're not necessarily
responsible for maintain the
images or the collections over
time, some are going to create a
project, they are the ones that
are responsible over the long
term.  Maintaining and
organizing those images.  But
just from like a technical
standpoint, UWS, the sources
that host a lot of our
information.  I guess we are in
the clouds for the most part.
And actually I'm a developer.
And in terms of the entire back
end picture, I think, yeah,
essentially it sounds sounds
like sounds like we are
all kind of somewhat similar.
SPEAKER:  Okay I think we have
time for one more question.
Here in the back.
SPEAKER:  This question is for
Ricky.
He was intrigued by your grid to
show the reunification.  I
wonder if these have been used
for indigineous collections or
is it typically for
anthropological field work?
SPEAKER:  So the model that I
did was primarily to explain the
complexity of virtual
unifications mainly for people
who are in charge of
collections.  And because I do
tell them that, you  you know,
you know, if you are trying to
capture the
whole, you need to have to have
some
--
at this point I don't think
it's possible.  You know,
consider this as a way to
analyze the problem for
yourself.  And you know, create
a representation that would
somewhat allow the
representation and different
aspects of
dispersing.
This is mainly for the graphics
collection that I studied but I
do think that other types of
collection could use this model
as well.  For native American or
indigineous communities, I am
starting a project that was
recently funded by IMLS called
evaluating our stance.  And this
goes to our communities.
Looking at the impact of
digitized collections once they
are downloaded because we are
quite good at doing research on
like how do we discover ability,
you know, when you search for
something, how quickly can you
get something that you are
looking for.  What happens once
the image is taken by a person
into their home.  What happens?
Do they keep it?  Do they use it
for something else?  What is
the impact of it?  So I am
taking that model more to inform
my research on that project.
So yeah, this is an ongoing
conversation, if I would put it
that way.  So you know, I am
definitely learning a lot as I I
I move
on.
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Okay.  Thank
you.  So we will have to break
here for lunch.  Again, be back
here at 1:30 and leave time for
security.  Thank you.
This is a test.
.
is a test.  This is a test
SPEAKER:  Hi everybody.
This is a test.
.
is a test.  This is a test
SPEAKER:  Hi everybody.  Hello.
Hi
everybody.  Welcome back from
lunch.  Thank you so much for
coming back.  I was a little bit
worried.  And so we are having
are having a are having a little
bit of trouble with the closed
captioning here.  We're going to
have a chat for a little bit so
you don't leave and lose
interest.  Those of you you who
are live streaming, join with
the hash tag as data.  I was
looking at the registered list
and all of the people that are
here.  Would you please raise
your hand if you're from a
library please?  Could you raise
your hand hand if hand if you
are from an archive?  Could you
raise your hand if you are from
a media organization?  Awesome.
Awesome.  One moment here.
University.  Museum, museum,
obviously museum.  Hello.  Thank
you for coming.  University and
not a library.  Good good good.
What else?  Like you are here by
yourself because you are just
wanting to wanting to make
friends and be
cool.  Oh, federal agency.  Oh,
yay.  Thank you for coming.
Our friends and brothers and
sisters.  Sorry.  So what else
can we talk about right now?
like jokes.  Does anybody have
any questions?  We can take some
questions if you can yell loud
enough.  Someone up there have
a question.  Hello.  Oh, we
have a system, we have lots of
folks in the audience and maybe
if anybody wants to jump jump up
jump up and
answer on my behalf.  I don't
work for OCIL but from my
memory, we are used a tiered
source system and then we have
mere line storage
for our access
system.  Anyone else?  How we
looking?  We getting there.
Okay.  Why was Why was six
afraid of nine?  Thank you.
Why was six afraid of seven?
Because seven ate nine.
Delivery.  I don't know.  One of
the things -- when you saw my
presentation earlier, it showed
a a picture a picture of the
stacks
in the Jefferson building, and
one of the things that was
really interesting about the
building building here building
here was
that the
stacks are actually
foundational support so you
couldn't remove the stacks and
the shelves from the Library of
Congress without it collapsing,
which I think is kind of a
beautiful beautiful metaphor.
As Thomas Jefferson said, I
cannot live without books.  He
was not very well
liked by some people.
[Laughter]
great question.  My friend Leah
from Neh first asked how I
first heard about
Henryiette Avram.  A friend of
mine introduced her to me, he is
a software developer and really
awesome.  Any other questions?
You people are leaving me
hanging.  I don't mean to blame
you.  Justin
Whitman,
hi Justin.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  It's hard for me to
give the entire perspective of
the inside.  I am thrilled.  She
is a huge inspiration and I
will say that when we did a
welcome  video and video and a
welcome photograph,
manymany of
you may have seen it on the
Facebook page.  A huge generous
applause getting ready for her
arrival really spoke volumes to
me about how excited the people
were.  We couldn't
be as happier.  A question from
Twitter?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  It's not very
good.
[Laughter].  Not very good.
Yeah.  Yup.  The question was
great.  The stand up comedy
routine.  I think it's very
well-known -- so the question is
how do do I do I feel about
meta data?
The
history of meta data data has
been studied for many many
years and I think that we have
come to the conclusion, after
years of intense investigation,
that meta data meta data rocks.
Thank you.  [Cheers and
applause].
SPEAKER:  Well how many
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Well how many jokes do
I get from from late from late
fees and
returning library book.  As far
as I know we don't have late
fees, am I right?  They cut off
the account.  Yup.  But anybody
over the age of 16 16 is 16 is
welcome to come here
and get a reader's
card.  So please do.  I would
also like to mention that we
have a couple of jobs posted if
you check the jobs page at the
at the  at the Library of
Congress.  Might as well well
squeeze every drop of juice out
of the orange. orange.  If
orange.  If you go
to the jobs page at the Library
of Congress, one of the
exciting new jobs is the chief
of digital collection and
management services which is
posted right now.  And I think
that will shape the digital
future of the Library of
Congress, so please apply for
that.  Anybody else have jobs
that they are advertising for?
No other questions.  So thanks
to the office of equal
opportunity and diversity
program, we have live streaming.
I believe someone is on the
phone listening and live typing
what is going on.  And we also
have our awesome interpreters
live here.  [Cheers and
applause].  Oh, my gosh, we have
a question from the
front here.
Do we have any pirate shanty in
the collection?  Yes, we do, in
fact, Nikki Saylor right here.
You can Google and find pirate
shanty.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Another great
question.  There are also pirate
maps.  If the geography and
maps collection, if you get get
a get a point
to head down there, which I
really recommend, lots lots of
lots of good
stuff.  They have a whole
section in the collection full
of maps of fantasy places, maps
of places that don't exist in
the real world like riverdale
and Lord of the Rings places,
it's really neat.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  I would like to repeat
that joke.  From Dan Chedna
from the audience, he says if
you would like to process pirate
maps as  data,
do you know what programming
language is used?
Arrrrr.  [Laughter]
.  I have a .  I have a
rebuttal.  A pirate's favorite
love is the sea.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Oh, good question.  I
would like to repeat the
question.  The question is where
are we on the schedule?  And we
are on "after lunch".  The next
step is concerns for data
scholarship but we are right now
working to get the closed
captioning working so we are on
pause on the schedule.  It
doesn't say it there, pause,
because we just invented
it.
Asks what are the concerns for
data scholarship and I would
like to tell you that I don't
have have concern for spoilers.
I don't want to ruin everyone's
good ideas good ideas by
good ideas by telling
you
now.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Oh, that's great.
Thank you.  One of our
colleagues mentioned that if you
are interested in the maps, I
am way more interested in the
fantasy than the real world, we
have the several division blogs.
You can go on blogs -- if you go
to blogs.LLC.GOV, you can find
it there and they did a series
over the summer for blogs from
imaginary
locations.  Yes?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Another colleague from
the Library of Congress says
related there is an exhibit on
literary maps.  If you go
to the exhibits exhibits
exhibits page.  Any
other treasures that anybody
wants to highlight.  There is a
lot.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Yeah, so please
interrupt me Deb or Leah if you
would like, but we have many
non-English language newspapers.
We do not have Russian
currently, but it's
eligible for selection.  We
have thousand of pages in six
different languages currently,
and that is
a fact that I knew. knew.
knew.  Deb did
not have to tell me.  I am
given the signal that we are are
okay are okay to start.  Thank
you for
indulging me while we got ready
with the live captioning.  We
will begin again.  So before we
begin, I just wanted to mention
another resource that is
available for researchers
working with collections and
data.  You heard a lot about
chronicling America which is
part to make available newspaper
pages.  We have WDL, the world
digital library which is between
the Library of Congress and
hundreds of partners throughout
the world to highlight a place,
the gems of their collection and
what is exciting is all of the
meta data is
API.WDL.org.  If you are
interested here we are very much
available to you.  The
developers are very much
available to you if
you have questions about it.
Let's begin.  The second half of
the symposium is to talk about
protecting data and privacy and
honoring copy rights very
seriously and the commits can
have down stream especially with
access to collection data at
scale.  We are excited to
bring you a group of speakers
who will talk about the tools.
First we have Bergis Juleshave
Bergis Jules who ishave Bergis
Jules who is going
to be talking about the
community and developmental
collection for the media
content.  Bergis is at the
university of California river
side library, the community own
consortium at the university of
California.  Previously
designed
the
DC African center.  And then we
have Nicole Saylor
documenting folks culture
around the world.  Collections
range from the earliest
recordings of
1890s out of a wax cylinder and
the nation's oldest and largest
documentation including
stories, and other creative
expressions from people in the
student.
Today will discuss
engaging
with communities and API driven
accessioning of digital folk
life.  Then we have
Maciej and he is here today
because he writes so warmly
about his love and keeping it a
place with connection of
knowledge.  He said quote the
web we have right now is
beautiful, it shatters the
tyrany of distance and gives you
a way to bear witness to people
half away around the world.  We
built it by accident.
Yet we are already taking it for
granted.  We should fight to
keep it , end quote.  I think
some of the ideas will open
today's topic.  It's my pleasure
to welcome Bergis to the
stand.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  Okay.  Thank youOkay.
Thank you forOkay.  Thank you
for having
me.  Right after lunch people
are energized and now I'm going
to talk you about my concerns
about collecting social media
data.  I am excited that this
session is part of the program
today, because we don't do
enough thinking around, you
know, the ethics of doing this
stuff.  And how to protect
people, so I am really glad to
see this panel is part of the
program and I am glad to be
part of it.  So all right.  So
at a basic level, documenting
the new is a project to build
free and open-source tools that
are easy to use for collecting,
analyzing and sharing Twitter
data.  It's a collaborative
project between UC river side
and the Maryland institute for
humanities at the university of
Maryland and Washington
University in St.
Louis.  The doc now team, the
development team has been hard
at work over the past ten
months, you know, really trying
to build something great great
that great that everyone
will be able to use and I am
really excited for what is to
come but today I'm going to
focus less on the technical
parts of our work.  What has
been really exciting -- what has
been the most exciting part of
the project in my opinion is how
much people from all kinds of
backgrounds have engaged in some
of the ideas that we have been
addressing and I think those
ideas can help us address some
of the more serious implication
of data especially as they
relate to
social media data.  So because
our work was inspired by the
activism and protest that
followed the police killing of
Michael Brown in Ferguson
Missouri in 2015, we had the
responsibility really not to
forget that there are in fact
people behind all of this data.
This is why doc now has such a
focus on ethics for long term
conservation.  We are really
interested in how our building
of these collections might
affect peoples' lives.  It's
also why we are being really
transparent with our work, at
the same time trying to help
build a community of people who
also value these ideas.  So
really, you know at the higher
level, doc now is about a couple
of things in my mind.  It's
about valuing people enough to
care about how we collect and
store their data and helping to
build a community of archive
professionals engaging with
content owners in equitable and
safe ways to use their data.
These two things are priorities
above our technical work on the
project and a lot of credit
really has to go to Ed Summers
for the project being framed
this way.  Ed has been my
partner in crime over the past
couple of years doing this work.
And he is also a principal
investigator on the doc now
project.  So we all agree that
there is an immense value in
social media data.  Especially
as it relates to our work and
archives on libraries.  I am
primarily interested in
collecting that type of data,
especially Twitter because I
think it presents tremendous
opportunities to present some
aspects of African American
history and culture.  For
example, this is a few -- this
is a graph from the research
that talked about how young
African Americans are the
highest users -- among the
highest users of Twitter
especially, right.  So a large
number of African Americans are
found in states where they feel
free to share and engage in
issues that matter to them,
especially considering how
little information we hold in
our traditional collections
about African Americans, you
know, I think this is a good
opportunity to at least learn
about some of those issues, if
not collect data about them.
So we have also seen the value
that platforms such as Twitter
had in amplifying voices like
the movement for black lives and
Howard spring and several other
social justice events that have
played online.  This is a
screen shot from the shot from
the brilliant shot from the
brilliant work
of
Freemomt, Macleson and Wayne.
I highly suggest you check it
out if you get a chance.  It's a
90 something page report that
the impact that Twitter and
other social media had on
spreading the message in
Ferguson.  All of this is good,
but we should also acknowledge
the significant responsibility
and embrace the data that makes
that accessible and we should be
prepared to do prepared to do
prepared to do this work
in ways that don't compromise
people's safety or presents
their data in ways that distorts
the original intent.
Because we know we are not the
only ones interested in
collecting this kind of data,
right, so this is a screen shot
from a -- this is a screen shot
of an e-mail from the ACLU
California last week published
published a published a report
about the growing use of
social media collection tools
via law enforcement, especially
local law enforcement and were
able to get their hands on a lot
of documents for this, and this
is a screen shot from an e-mail
that a company, GOpedia which
is really popular in the states
right now, is sending out to its
clients about Ferguson.  Saying
hey, we have a lot of good
stuff on the Ferguson protesters
here.
Click here to view the
collection.  And you know, here
I think the ACLU articulates
really well the danger to people
of color and other minority
groups when police start using
these kinds of tools, right and
for those in the back, I will go
ahead and read this.  The
racist implications of social
media surveillance technology
are not surprising.  We know
that when law enforcement gets
to conceal the use of
surveillance technology to also
get to conceal its misuse.
Discriminatory policing that
targets people of color and
surveillance technology
supersized the impact of racial
profiling and abuse.  So So
there So there is
some real issues that we have
to consider here.  How will our
collections of social media data
be different than those built
by law enforcement or private
security firms?  I think that is
a question that we all need to
think about.  Here is an image
of two prominent activists who
became well-known during the
Ferguson protest.  Here they are
labeled as threat actors by a
private security firm.  Here on
the left, and Jonetta Elsy.  I
think this is in relation to the
Baltimore uprising when they
found out this this company was
doing a lot of data collection
for local law enforcement.  So
it's ait's a scaryit's a scary
situation because these
companies are increasingly
interested in this data as a way
to punish people for being
active citizens.  When Ed
Summers and I am dropping Ed's
name a lot here today, going to
owe me a beer after this, when
Ed Summers first made a blog
post about the Ferguson Twitter
data set, a private security
firm first reached out to him
asking him if they can access
that data.  It's a really
concern for our profession to be
aware of.  How do we make sure
that the massive Twitter data
archive being built right here
at the Library of Congress
doesn't become a tool that these
groups can use against already
marginalized people, who are
concerned for the police to stop
killing them.  So how will the
library respond to requests from
private security firms and law
enforcement for the data?  Part
of the answer is that we have to
directly engage with people
using social media for how
collecting this type of data
might affect their lives.  I
think that would be an important
way for us to come up with some
policies around offering public
access to some of this content.
It's a difficult task.  But I
think it's possible and you know
it's especially tough because
of the number of people who can
engage with an issue on a social
media platform at any given
time. That number can be
daunting.  I'm not sure how
large the LLC Twitter data set
is right now.  But I'm sure it's
significant.  In the last week
it has collected almost 2
million tweets related to the
killing of Keith Scott in
Charlotte and Terence crutcher
in Tulsa.  I think it's it's key
if we are willing to drop some
ideas about professionalism in
the midst of neutrality over the
people in the communities.  So
last month, the doc now project
hosted our first advisory board
meeting in St. Louis.  And this
was an opportunity to get our
awesome advisor board members
and some of these names and
faces are familiar to you.  To
get together for a deep dive
into many of the issues that we
have been raising around social
media web archiving, ethics and
technology over the past year.
And this was a really, you know,
we have six really great panels
of inciteful and challenging
discussions.  And I really hope
that you will check them out on
our website, docnow.IO when when
you
get a chance.  Because I don't
think this group of people
really have been brought
together before in the context
of sort of archiving digital
media or web archives.
Definitely check it out if you
get a chance for the meeting
page on our website.  But I want
to focus on just one of those
panels for the last few minutes.
I think it's a great example of
the type of community work we're
going to need to engage in in
the future if we want to
continue building these types of
data sets as archives.  The
panel was made up of four
activists from Ferguson.  Who
were some of the many organizers
in Ferguson after Michael
brown's killing
including who was expertly
moderated by Jonathan Fengleson
who is a faculty director at
Washington university.  I am
thankful for the activists
joining us.  These are people
with 9:00 to 5:00s and they are
students and they took time out
of their day to be with us for a
good chunk of the day.  We
appreciated that.  They added a
richness and a realness to the
event that we wouldn't have had
otherwise.  You know and they
talked about their lives before
Ferguson and talk about their
lives now.  There are some
really difficult conversations
that happened on that panel.
It's about an hour and a half
long.  The longest panel of the
day.  I think that there is some
really good stuff in there.
Check it out.  I am seeing my
five minute cue here.  I will go
ahead and stop here.  But I
want to share a short clip from
that panel with you.  It's about
six minutes long so I will just
leave it open and then we can
get into conversation that way.
So let's see if this will work.
It
worked during testing.  So So
you So you all are
in a room full of people who
are really interested in
documenting the now, right, try
to be able to capture what is
happening.  Particularly with
social movement as it's
happening.  Right.  And so one
of the things that is really
interesting is that -- sorry,
you're going to hear from Alexis
first and Kayla in a second.
This is a story that you all
helped create.  Helped make into
a global story, but at the same
time, it's a story, and in many
ways, attempted to control via
Twitter but at the same time
it's a story that comes so big
that it's also beyond any of
your controls, right, so one of
the questions that I really
wanted to get at was, how do you
all want the movement to be
remembered?  And where is some
of the things that you would you
would  you would like people
doing research around your
lives, your work, what are some
of of the of the things that you
want them
to be conscious of?  You can't
stop them.  them.
Right. them.
Right.  But what are some of
the things that you want them
to keep in mind as
they are doing that work?  All
right, so, really iffy I guess I
am more so talking to the black
folks in the room, the
movement, like don't watch out
the internal politics.  And like
the argument -- like don't
watch the way the homo phobia
and the sexism,sexism, sexism,
don't
watch the way there are live
stories about what is happening
to people like internally and
like people felt unsafe and
unsafe and people
fighting next to you.  Don't
leave that out because we have,
in all of our movements, people
are so hurt and bitter.  And
this is why a lot of the
arguments are happening online
and this is why like they don't
really bother me because this
also humanizes our movement and
I don't think we have got that
with anything we have had.  It's
always been persistent.  We
just aren't.  We are like
depressed.  We like to drink and
smoke.  We have kids.
We have jobs.  We are married.
We are like scorned.  We are
human like whatever.  Actually
humanize the people out there,
these
everyday people, because they
are bitter just like ya'll in
this room.
And you just can't.
SPEAKER:  Really quick I saw the
sign.
SPEAKER:  So for me that's
really important.  And the other
thing I would add to that is
just the idea idea of idea of
the social
media experts, super
democritized and somewhat
perpetuates that for those of
you who have -- like I have
15,000 followers, whatever, it
changes.  But it's a lot.  And
so people -- like mistakenly put
your value at how many people
follow you.  And leadership
isn't based on how many
followers you have online.
Leadership is based on how many
how many  how many people
you are invested in and
developing on the ground.  One
of the most important thing that
I felt like I accomplished over
the past two years were not
told on social media and they
did not need to be told on
social media and the space
that you see where we are lifted
up, we are standing on the
shoulders of hundreds of giants
and Ferguson was not because the
four of of us of us go
together and fight the black
generation because thousands of
people in St. Louis say yo, this
is messed up and we're not
going to let that stand.  We see
those people at Target,
hopefully you don't get to
Walmart.  Or when you go to a
fast food spot, you see the
people that say I want to give
all of myself to a space and we
go back to life.  We have been
ethically blessed and we
worked for it and also part of
the equation that put us into
the elevated space.  And our job
is also to fight for those who
are not in our faces and try to
do that, but that's your job, to
tell the story and find those
people.  If you can't find the
people, at least create space
for the narrative to be build,
like for the rest of my life, I
owe people that I will never
know.  And I take that shit so
seriously.  Like every state
that I represent, my mom and
grandma are behind the window
that I can't see.  That's the
way I behave because people
literally sacrifice their lives
and comfort for one person.  And
we have somewhat benefitted
from it and somewhat been super
traumatized by it.  And accept
that, and like tell our
wholeselves and I made the
commitment in therapy because I
didn't go to therapy.  And I
made this commitment that says I
will love, and I commit to my
community to love the entirety
and that is the not romantic
story.  We are hungry and didn't
didn't have didn't have food.
That's the subway lady
having no money and then
getting cancer and making a go
fund me and reaching out to
Ferguson activists and say I
have cancer and reach out to us
every night.  That is a story
that a lot of people don't know.
But it's so important that that
is how we sustain that
kind of community.
SPEAKER:  All
right.  Okay.  All right.  All
right so that's all I have.  And
I look forward to the
discussion.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER: Hello.  This is an
extremely tough act to follow.
follow.
Thanks forfollow.
Thanks for that.  I want to
thank NDI, Kate, for this
wonderful opportunity to
participate in such a
terrific event.  So my talk is
a rehash of a paper that we put
together for the upcoming eye
press conference.  So it's less
about the ethical considerations
of this work and more
about the technical side of the
work.  But I am certainly happy
to talk about ethics in the Q
and A.  I  I would like to give
I would like to give a shout out
to the
co-authors and I invite them to
chime in and correct and expand
as needed.  I welcome that.  I
want to shout out Julia Kim and
Melissa Linberg and they pushed
us through the presentation and
we couldn't have done this
without them.  I want to
acknowledge Betsy Peterson and
other leaders in library
services and and web and web
services
for seeing where the
experimentation and
implementation can exist.  So
today I will be talking about
the collaboration among my
library colleagues.  Web
contents for preservation access
that moves us beyond classic
web archiving methods and focus
on two community collecting
projects.  One to solicit and
harvest community-generated
photos off of flicker and the
other is to gather information
over a fairly-new form of
application.  So both projects
involve a public call to action
and prompt public engagement in
building library collections.
They leverage our partnership --
by leveraging or partnering with
third-party software platforms,
these efforts allow us to focus
on preservation and long term
access of records while still
supporting immediate and dynamic
engagement in the community.
Kate got into it a little bit.
A background on the American
folk life center.  We are a
large ethnographic archive.  And
these extensions include audio
visual documentation of visual
art and cultural expressions and
oral history in the access of
songs, stories and other
creative expressions of people
from diverse communities.  And
as mentioned they range from wax
cylinders from 1890 as we
talked about yesterday in the
other building, to the digital
collection and many others.  We
have pretty much every
technology in our collection.  I
will mention to you that we are
perhaps best known for our
collection of field recordings.
The performances of songs,
instrumental music by little
known musicians and also by
famous musicians such as
Elizabeth Lorang Cotton and
Molly Jackson, Jerry Morton,
Johnny Cash and so on, many who
did performances
right on this stage.  All right
so moving ahead, maybe, the
American folk life center was
created in 1976 by an act of
Congress and we have a
wide-ranging mandate to preserve
and to present folk life so I
am showing you a snippet of the
verbiage from the legislation
that defines what folk life is,
and sort of sets our tone for
collecting the scope.  Which I
would say is broad, if not
wildly ambitious to try to get
all of
this documented.  So I want to
point out that the digital
collecting initiatives that I am
going to talk about are part of
a long history of the archives
of soliciting public
collaboration in documenting the
cultural record.  You know with
the founding of the archives,
Robert Gordon went out and
recorded singers to document
American folk song.  Of course,
Alan Lomax right after Pearl
harbor who has been the
assistant in charge of the
archives, sent a telegram in
field workers to various
locations throughout the United
States that the man on the
street interviews gets peoples'
reactions on what happened.
happened.  Wehappened.  We have
since built on
that tradition for doing the
same in 911 and the same
commemorating the inauguration
of the first African American
president.  And so on.  So of
course with the proliferation of
smart phones, tablets and
wireless internet connections,
network communication is
increasingly where the cultural
record is being documented and
AFC staff has long recognized
this need to preserve folk
expression on the web and until
now, has not had but paper tools
to do them.  You'll see we have
a very respectable collection
of scam e-mails in our inboxes
printed out.  But any way, we
have since evolved and in June
of 2014, we worked with Abby
Gratt's team in the archiving to
create a web culture collection
and we study with colleagues
that use digital culture and
capturing a set of sites.  So we
are up to about 49 sites
changing from know your mean.
There is a pepper spray
everything mean.  Feel free to
Google that later.  All right so
our -- just briefly, yeah,
I love that one.  Any way so we
are looking at sites that
document communities that are
engaging with each other, DIY
communities, spanned
communities, people talking
about urban legends and these
are extensions of the kind of
documentation that we have in
the
analog.  All right.  So by
way of background, the Library
of Congress has been collecting
web archives since 2000 and has
a well established practice for
establishing and processing the
collections.  Most website
collections are harvested via a
tool character.  And they are
saved into a format called work.
The crawler works from a list of
known seeds that are starting
URLs and then it -- you are
doing a great job.  And it
crawls to a specific depth from
each one following internal
links on websites.  There is no
verification against the
original source.  That the is
not possible in the context.
But the results are subjectively
reviewed and these methods are
are  are appropriate
for collecting documentation of
everyday life.
But they are different and
distinctive fromdistinctive from
the
abilities that are offered in
the two projects that I am going
to talk about in ten
minutes or less.
Okay.  We first started working
with the library developers to
collect user-submitted
photographs via flicker that
documented day of the dead and
other sort of other sort of
constellations of holidays
that are late October or early
November.  Participants were
asked to post photos to flicker
with that hashtag.  We have done
it again since last year.  And
then have a creative license
accompanying that.  We have
since expanded that.  This is
the 40th anniversary of the
center, and so we have asked
people to document their
traditions and do the same
thing, because the end of the
calendar year, we will be
working again with developers to
pull that content into our
archives.  So the flicker
harvesting project, like the
project that I am going to to
talk to talk about
in a minute, have the contours
well suited for approaches and
processing.
There is no external link in the
data.  No easy list of fees
that are linked to the
collection externally and most
of the data was collected --
well in the app and so the data
sets need to be treated
differently in terms of access.
But in the case of story, well,
in flicker, access is being
handled by these third parties.
So that is
off the hook for now.  Okay.
So any way, at the library we
have seem to have settled into a
rhythm where we treat digital
data sets sets and sets and web
harvesting as two independent
and related practices.  Data
sets are generally collected in
time or tag bound chunks by
querying an external API.
Downloaded onto LP storage and
baggage structure and continued
through the usual workflow.
Depending on whether they are
preservation or online access or
both.  Let me move quickly into
the story core example.  So
this venture is an extension of
a long standing relationship we
have had with the story core.
Story core started in 2003 and
now among the largest narrative
projects of their kind and
interviews have been collected
at mobile booths and permanent
story booth located in New York,
Chicago, San Francisco and
Atlanta.  The traditional
interview is two people who knew
each other talking for 40
minutes in a booth and each
recording is preserved at the
Library of Congress, the
American folk life center.  And
then these snippets of the stuff
gets broad casted on national
public radios.  And so since the
inception of the project in
project in
2003, the signature, what we are
calling, you know,
face to face story core, is
where they have gone through
more than 67 thousand
interviews.  Then in 2015,
founder Dave Isay won the Ted
prize and when you win the Ted
prize, get one million dollars,
which is great.  And Dave wanted
to create an app.  Which is
great.  And he took the app for
story core global and he did.
And we were like okay, let's do
this.
So we worked with story core
developers
to put something together.  And
that is what I will talk about.
At story core developers, they
worked with the software
developers here at the library
to identify and design and
construct this transfer
mechanism, the team agreed that
an API would benefit both
parties.  The library would
receive or fetch and then it
would allowwould allow thewould
allow the expose collection
instead of spending staff time
pushing it out to us.
Story core developers considered
their content fluent, library
developers were addiment that we
need things to be fixed.
Right, and so explaining this to
an external partner was
beneficial for us, because it's
a technical factor that the
library world that exposes
archival preservation practices
more broadly.  This is where we
were going to go to explain
that.  I couldn't do it.  Any
way, so each interview packet
consists of meta-data files and
there is an optional upload
photo selfie with your partner
in JPEG and an MP3 audio file
and these are discrete packets
that are served up.  They were
happy to add the check sum
feature which is a digital
finger print of some sort which
can be made be made later be
made later for
errors.  And the MP3 was hosted
at sound cloud and was not sure
if sound cloud would be cool
with adding that.  They were
after, a little bit of back and
forth, happy to do that for us.
So that made it a lot better.
Decisions had to be made like
what about the associated meta
data.  Do we care about likes?
Do we care about
description tags?  We
certainly thought tags were
incredibly important for meta
data.  And so any way, once the
developers were happy with the
general design of the transfer
mechanism, then both parties
began to iterate and the API
side and the library on the
sketching side and I will go
through a few technical details.
In doing this work just to jump
to the two big errors that we
were trying to protect against
were one, a single file where
the check is destroyed.  And the
second class would be losing
access to correlated errors
which is practice and mistakes
where somebody follows a bad
practice or relies upon bad code
and inventory can help identify
those sort of things and making
a good copy.  Okay so this this
is this is how
the
development is going.  I will
just move ahead.  All right well
in closing, you know these
projects have enabled AFC to
engage a broad public to
collaboratively build the
collections and able to do so in
an automated way and a way that
bakes in sound preservation
practices, which we love.  And
if there is time to play a one
and a half minute clip.  Okay.
I would like to close with this
clip from a story core
interview.  And I want to say,
that this is a tremendous
research research corpus,
research corpus, these
interviews,
and they do get dinged
sometimes for being
advertalntly sentimental.  And
same thing like on Friday.  So
enjoy.  I
will leave you with
this.
SPEAKER:  One of the last
questions basically is to take
time to tell your interview
partner what you mean.  So I'm
going to say that to you.  I
absolutely adore you.  You are
easily the best thing that has
ever happened to me in any way,
shape or form.  While like you
said earlier, there is so many
things that we can be unsure
about in our future, I can
always say that I know I want
you in it.  So in the home that
we have built together and the
lives that we have made together
with each other, and in the
family that we have started with
our little furry friends here
Asia,
Colleen, Atcot, will you give me
the greatest honor,
will you you marry
me?
SPEAKER:  Yes.
[Crying].  Of
course I will.
SPEAKER:  What better way than
to talk about all of the
wonderful things that we have
done in our lives so far?  And
then to think about the great
thing that going
to happen in the future.
SPEAKER:  You're so amazing.
SPEAKER:  I didn't tell you this
yet, but this could also be
saved in the Library of
Congress's archives.  Forever.
So that
So that everyone
So that everyone can listen to
this.  I love you so much.
SPEAKER:  I love you too.
SPEAKER:  This could have been
my interview/surprise proposal
to my wonderful girlfriend and
now fianc.  I am now the happy
of the man in the world.  Thank
you.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  I have never had a.
SPEAKER:  I have never had a
simultaneous translator before,
pumpernickel, flap jack, moose
handles.  My name is Maciej
Ceglowski and I run a web
archive of 20,000 people so to
be invited to the Library of
Congress is like a kid tied to a
tube and then then coming then
coming to tell NASA about
propulsion.
Like everyone said, it's a
special honor to be here.  It's
a special thing for me because I
am usedam used toam used to
talk about
the U.S.
government as a big scary
adversary and here I am in a
government institution that
despite the fact that we went
through a metal detectivor
to
to be
here,
during
the panel of September 11th,
Carla Haden who was on the
library association look a
provision act that requires
libraries to divulge what they
were reading and she did this
with
ridicule and now she is working
at the Library of Congress.
What a woman.  For me it is
depressing to think that those
provisions that seem threatening
and un-American look almost
quaint now compared to what we
have done in it the commercial
internet to destroy privacy.
Libraries have a commitment to
protect information that
relevant patrons are reading and
amazon knows every book that
you have read,read, Googleread,
Google has your
correspondence and web history
and your phone company knows
where you are, based on a device
that you choose to carry with
you.  And in some ways, the
commercial internet is the
opposite of a commercial
library.  The libraries exist to
inform.  The web is there to
extract as much information that
known about.  There is no
alterior motive in a library but
in the web, every link is there
to show you an ad.  As a
librarian I have made enormous
advances in technology and I
want to talk to you about
machine learning.  I rather you
hear it from me or out on the
street or from your friends.  I
come to think that the
machine-learning techniques that
are mistaking are like like a
like a deep-fryer.  If you never
deep fried something in your
life, you taste and it's amazing
and then you taste and if
you're like this is work with
anything.
And you're right.  In college I
had friends that worked at the
snack bar and they would deep
fry cheese and candy and pens
and it all tasted good.  And if
you sit on it in  college,
college, it
kind of gives you a little bit
of hangovers.  The statistical
techniques and names keep thing,
AI, machine learning and next
year is going to be a new buzz
word.  The correlation is that
you feed your computer lots of
data and it recognizes the
structure.  In any deep fry
situation, you want to ask what
is the stuff being deep fried?
In the 70s, where I am from, a
person brought a craft fryer in
Italy and called it, and you had
to stand in your own line for
blocks.  If you brought your own
chicken, in three minutes it
would be deep fried and the most
tasty thing and then the health
department shut it down, it was
it was never clean and the
stuff inside of it was basically
black tar and that was and that
was the and that was the flavor
secret.  So what
is your data getting fried in?
These algorithms train on large
collections that you don't know
anything about and Google
operates on things 100 operates
on things 100 times
bigger than what we are
familiar with in humanity.  I
refer to this as machine
laundering because you can
smuggle in conceptions based on
how you train.  For example if
you go to Google translate and
plug in a horrible article about
Syria, you get something in
English that looks like it's
from a native speaker.  But if
you put in, in Arabic, a kid's
letter or a passage letter, it
looks like frankenStein's
monitor
r.  It's just other
ideosynchrosies.  If you use
optimal character recognition,r.
It's just other
ideosynchrosies.  If you use
optimal character recognition,
you may see it.  I would be
weary of anything with social
networks without careful
thoughts of where it has
trained.  I find it helpful to
think of alga rhythms as
graduate students that you don't
really trust.  If you want an
index or want them to go through
(1) 000-0000
photos where there are horses,
or if you want to do social
analysis or census data or want
adult supervision in the room,
but the sudden issues of bias,
it's the opportunity cost that
irk me.  The uniques deal with a
lot of potential for surprise.
If you are going to search for
patterns in your data, you're
going to find patterns in your
data.  Woo-hoo.
What gets lost in that data is
really interesting and fresh.
We have seen entire fields
disappear.  Economics came
first, sociology and political
science is still trying to get
out, bioinformatics is out there
and trying to get out there for
a while.  The computers are a
tool and eliminate some trudge
ri
ri.  If you deep fry some
things, it's tasty.  I don't
think we have internalized the
eeeenormity of the step.  I am
laughing because the Andrew
Mullen foundation once hired me
as a program officer, that was
crazy of them.  When I was a
program officer I remember
working with the J store and
finding out that 50 percent of
J. store records, not only had
no one read them, but not have
seen them and part of that was
because it was extremely
restrictive agreement as
publishers and part of it was
failure in your imagination.
You have everything under the
sun and no attempt to connect it
to the academy.  We completely
flubbed Wikipedia and I remember
my boss went as far as whether
to print a a copy a copy of
it and publish it that way.
That is what we saw.  And then
later after leaving Mullen I saw
the librarians fail to engage
in the early days.  Services
that later grew to love,
basically because of the lack of
trust and openness to an
experiment
around unstructured tagging.
And when And when we And when we
talk
about data, a lot of our
language is extracted.  You talk
about data flow and data mining
and data crunching.  It's like
a rocky substance that you have
to smash to get the jewels out.
You need the right condition,
the profitous climate and a
sprinkling of bullshit.  You
need the ability to accept that
you don't know exactly what is
going to grow.  If we take
seriously the idea that
digitaling the collections are
reasonable, we have to give out
control.  It should make perfect
sense because human cultures
are normally diverse.  It's
normal that there are different
music and culture and distance
and you delight in the fact that
there is one hundred different
type of cuisines but when we go
online, the dynamics narrow and
programmers meet the needs
everywhere.  And we think it's
normal to build a social network
for millions of people.  I call
this the mormon bartender
problem, where you imagine you
can think your way through it.
I will give you an example of my
own website.  I run a very
vanilla archive where people
save their information for
later.  I have a priest who
searches for sermons on it,
which I am happy about it.  But
the biggest users on my life are
users of fan fiction.  You're
going to pretend you don't know.
But the librarians are avid of
it.  These are people often
highly neurotic set on various
pictures in the universes.  If
you always thought there was
sparks, this is the culture for
you and I encourage you to
explore it.  Came to my site and
to them, it's a search engine
and publication tool and it's
not an archive at all in the
sense that I intended it and
they do a lot of technical work
to make it suit their needs.
For me it's like watching bees
arrive and make honey and honey
comb and make sure that you
don't get stung.  It was really
a wonderful experience but made
me think that the internet has
to get a lot weirder than it is.
People are tired of the deep
fried data flavor and they want
substance.  They do interesting
things but you have to trust
them first.  In an institutional
setting it can be frightening.
grants online other than the
hope that it will be
interesting.  It takes more
courage to award such a grand
grant.  It takes time for
someone to use a project that
might make a cat video.  I
realize that is not the royal
road for a ten year in most
institutions and it takes
courage to commit to
maintaining those collections
for a long period of time.  But
search for intelligent life in
the internet means that you have
to put away the life in the
internet about who the
communities are.  I thought the
phantoms on my site were
pursuing a hobby.  What I didn't
realize is that online the
frivilous blend easily.
There is a seminar on feminism
where young fans use the issues
to explore gender identity and
use phantom to discover that
there is something called gender
identity that they are allowed
to have and think about in
question and do it through
something that they genuinely
enjoy and make writing in a way
that might make a Russian critic
blush and they coach each other
in writing better.  They coach
each other in technology.
Because serious people enjoy
frivilious things, it becomes a
secret educational system that
works in thriving ways.  In an
upcoming talk, about describe
things similar with the boy band
One Direction that has a fan
following of young women and
they have technical achievement
that media companies can't get
with, developers, video editors
and journalists and they don't
think of it that way, and end
quote, these interests are not
serious so they don't matter.
These women would not never
dream of applying to jobs that
they are already doing.  I am
convinced that our time is much
better spent trying to reach
them and engage them than trying
with the
same algarhythmic toys.
There is the question of what is
already on the internet.  One
approach is going to the people
who have control in the data,
the big companies and partner
with them and study it.  I think
this is awkward though because
the very thing that the Library
of Congress objected to in the
patriot act is the bread and
butter.  Much of it would never
pass ethical standards in
academia and the data is there.
There are no laws that constrict
or constrain us from how ever
we want, want, and want, and I
know
that you
can hear the data calling to
you.
It's saying study me.  Preserve
me.  The fly-by-night companies
are going to lose me.  You can
try to add layers of ethical
paint and say that you are
really helping but but I but I
worry
about legitimizng a culture of
surveillance like that.  I am
very uneasy when I see social
sciences working with Facebook
for example.  In the absence of
meaningful privacy protection,
the privacy is click okay and
pray.  Since we have yet to see
a really big misuse of personal
information, we are just kind of
hoping that it doesn't happen.
Remember we live in a time when
the spiritual success is on the
sense in a lot of western
democracies.  Having large
unregulated information
harvesting people without their
their  their knowledge
is just dangerous.
Don't legitimize it.  People
face social pressures to abandon
their privacy.  Being on social
media is an unexpected part of
getting a job or an apartment.
The border patrols wants to look
at your social media.  Realize
that the behavioral modification
is not consentual.  It's an
illusion.  I want to talk
momentarily about my bread and
butter which is websites.
Forgive me for my technical
talks.  The average website is a
giant pile of steaming garbage.
context but the way it is.
It's full of java script and
what does it mean?  You have
everything in the browser and is
the dynamic out on the page of
an annoyance or is it a valuable
window in the life of  2016?
2016?  Which are
we supposed to archive?  How do
we pull it in?  Who should it
be targeted to?  You know, you
end up in the situation where
you have to build a simulator of
the entire computing
environment of today and I don't
think future generations will
forgive us for doing that.  Game
developers have already
wrestled through this program.
They have stuff that we can
learn from, because
they have tried to emulate games
that are hard implemented in
software and the reason they are
able to do it is because they
are passionate about playing the
games and teaching it to their
kids.  Communities pop up as
kind of a life saver.  One
problem in an institution that
the Library of Congress faces,
is that you can't just role up
your sleeves and say archive how
ever you can, because what you
do will be considered normal and
everybody will follow.  I see
the problem.  And communities
can happen.  An example from
live journal that might help.
It's an early blog site that was
quite popular.  For every
little post you can have a
thumbnail type image and what
was happening, people would use
the images as a post.  People
would have hundreds and
thousands of these images and
became sort of an art on how to
do commentary.
Live journal was not aware of
it.  It was a retro active limit
and they destroyed a lot in
their archive without knowing
that they did anything.  It's
easy to say that if you talk to
your users you find out about
this.  A lot of it falls into
the cracks when you use multiple
sites.  It's not limited to
one0 or two places.  The only
way to know how to preserve is
to talk to them.  We have more
than enough storage.  We can't
recreate the environment without
bringing in all of the
operating systems and browsers
and ads that exist now, which is
an impossible task.  Focusing
on communities, like I said,
means relinquishing control.
It's scary.  There are some key
steps we can follow.  Making the
materials available in open
formats without restrictions
with a serious restriction
restriction to restriction to
having a URL being a permanent
process goes a long way.
Publishing text as text.  APIs
that we have seen talked about
today, which I find very
encouraging, and a commitment to
fair use that is a copy right
office has also shown, so people
can freely create and pitch
this stuff together without fear
of automated robots and fear
lawyers.  I want to give my
wishful closing memory of the
place that I never thought I
would be wishful about, the
Glenview public library.  I grew
up in the suburbs of Chicago
and like the nerdy kids I spent
half of my adolescence there and
half checking out books.  It
was the world on the internet
and I never understood why the
urban library existed or who
funded it or the values of it.
It was like the landscape to me,
like lake Michigan.  I had the
right to learn.  I can ask
questions and learn my way to
the answers and taught me to be
quiet in public spaces.  For the
generation that is growing up
today, the internet is the
window in the world and to them
it just exists.  At the take it
for granted.  It's for us that
are aware of how contingent it
is, that you need to worry about
it. The coming years are going
to decide what extent the media
is for consumption and for what
extent it's going to lift people
up and how much of a tool it's
going to be for social control.
As it exists today, the internet
is a big shopping mall.  There
is two big stores.  Facebook and
Google and of course there is
an apple store in the middle and
a food court with lots of punks
and lots of surveillance
cameras watching everything that
happened and outside in the
parking lot there is the book
mobile, which is you guys, just
to add classiness to the place.
This isn't my dream of the web.
My dream of the web is for it to
feel like the big city.  A
place where you rub elbows with
people that are not like you.  A
little scary and chaotic and
full of many things that you can
imagine, and many things where
you can't and also for people to
be themselves and for people
for people to for people to
create
their own spaces and to learn
from one another and of course
room for big, beautiful, huge
tremendous library.  Thank you
very much.  [Applause]
. .
SPEAKER:  So Nicole can join us.
We're going to do fifteen
minutes of questions and then
take a quick ten minute break.
Let's first get to the
questions.  I
believe we have the folks with
micro phones and
also you can tweet your
questions.  To as data hashtag.
Are there any questions in the
audience here?  A couple right
here.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Hi, this is
for any of the
speakers who would care to
respond.  I have discussed this
with
Nikki a little bit in the past.
I am wondering if there is a
point where we are either going
out as informed scholars or
informed members of community
and trying to gather the data.
But we are not necessarily at
least in many libraries, taking
the step that let's say an
anthropologist would do and go
back to the old
school epnology in old-school
anthropology.  And although we
are getting a little better,
libraries tend to think of the
meta data that we collect as
neutral and as we know, no
meta-data is completely neutral
and I'm thinking about of the
thought process of the meta data
or the collecting.  If the
three of you have any thoughts,
that would be interesting.
SPEAKER:  Okay it sounds like
what you are asking is more
informed collecting.  And I see
this is something that
archivists also do in some ways.
But we have seen the
move away from that when it
comes to web or social media
archives.  I think we sort of,
you know, take that distance
that you feel from between
yourself yourself and yourself
and that type
of collection and we just say,
you know, it's too big of a
problem to deal with to try to
engage and at least that is what
I am seeing when I look at the
collections out there.  I don't
see enough engagement with the
people producing the content and
that is something is something
that is something that we're
going to have to go back and big
out.  I would definitely agree
with the idea that
eponagraphy is a good model.
The communities out there remind
me where you go in the
helicopter and throws spears at
you for a while and then you are
able to talk.  We really need
to reach out to people who
wouldn't be freaked out by the
idea of talking to archivists
and realize that the people do
not just have value in their own
lives but the richness of what
we consider to be the online
world.
SPEAKER:  I think what of what
we are doing on another project
with analog materials called
traditional knowledge and
labels, we are working with
communities -- they assign the
labels and we will pilot a
project to put their labels and
definitions of their labels
online.  So the labels denote
the cultural preferences of the
tribe and maybe something is
supposed to be listened to
seasonally or by women only or
whatever, and so you know, the
folk life center is actively
working on that with its oldest
materials from 1890s right now.
But
yes, it's with scale to DH and
blah blah.  It's very high touch
and long-term relationship
building.  I think
that we have to be doing that.
other questions?
Well for the recording we'll
need it.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  So I am
curious if you are not the
Library of Congress, if there
are copy right issues with web
harvesting?  I personally use
web scrapping or scraping and
I'm not sure how to say it.  I
know you were going to talk
about ethical issues and I'm not
sure if you can bring it up now
and if this is part of it.
SPEAKER:  Yeah so we have to get
permission from the site
owners.
At least
At least in the
At least in the class of the
website
that we are most interested in
that are focus on cultural
expression.  There are some
sites on our wish list that we
not getting implications to do
that.  So, does that answer your
question or not?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Yes.
SPEAKER:  Any other questions
from the audience
here?  Do we have any coming
in through Twitter?  If we
don't have questions, I may cut
this short and invite everybody
to come to the -- after our next
session after 5:00 we are
meeting at the Hawk and Dove
for the social hour.  Because
we ran over with our technical
difficulties, we will stop this
now and go to break.  We will
come back in ten minutes, ten
after 3:00, 310.
So back here in ten minutes
please.  Thanks. .
SPEAKER:  Hey everybody.
Welcome
back.  Hi everyone.  In the
beginning of the program I
asked how we can encourage
collection tore used by data,
scholars and librarians.  They
are a facilitator in the
community advocate.  Each of the
speakers that you will now hear
are involved in projects that
will empower and provoke
communities to seek.  Harriet
Green, an aassociate
professional University
of  of  Illinois of  Illinois
at
urban-Champaign
and
digging
deeper
to mind, trust and empowering
resources will help train the
trainer program to support
digital scholars on academic
campuses.
When the group
When the group was
When the group was initially
thinking
about the topic, the input of
technology and humanities to
speak with our next speaker
Trevor Munoz to speak about the
university of Maryland who is
working at the center for
humanities and African American
culture center initiative and
besides being the associate
director, also an No, I didn't
dean at the University of
Maryland libraries and in both
roles
fosters digital programs
between librarians, activists
and other researchers.
Close out the session, we will
hear from Marisa Parham and
Amhurst and hear about the
initiatives that serve
Amhust, Holyoke and
Massachusetts.  It helps create
creative work and brings incite
to the implementation,
development and critique of
technology.  Our team first
encountered Marisa when we first
read her series in digital
humanities when she asked who
can create the abilities and a
question that we ask and think
about every day.
Please welcome to the stage,
Harriet Green.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  Thank you, Kate and I
am really excited to join this
day of invigorating discussions
about the data and as Kate said,
I'll talk about methods for
scholarship research. Ly talk
about the issues that motivated
our project and talk about the
project itself.  As you have
seen and heard from presenters
earlier today, digitized content
is changing more rapidly as
teachers ingrate the data into
the work and scholarship and
work of strategic library and
thinking in support declares the
vision in the future and in
2033, the research library will
have shifted from its role as a
knowledge service provider in
the university to become a
collaborative partner within a
rich and diverse learning eco
system end quote.  The future
declaration frames how
librarians and research queries
that challenge our skillset and
library services and it has been
made evident today what reaches
humanities and social sciences.
So in light of all of the data
that we have in humanities and
social sciences, how can
libraries prepare for supported
data driven research?  I won't
repeat the point given already
about data but I wanted to
highlight this information from
the commonwealth report
published about ten years ago
from the American council of
Americaning Societies and it
defines concisely but thoroughly
that richly diverse type of
data that research needs.  And
the report goes on to say that
cyber infrastructure is not just
the hardware and the software.
It's the people and to quote,
the cyber infrastructure between
humanities and social sciences
works between the amateur and
the creative scholars, the
teachers and students and it's
not just the data that is as
important as the information
that goes around it, contributes
to it and eventually integrates
with it end quote. So equal
importance to a data is the
teacher and librarian or
researcher that explores and
expands the data.  And examines
what libraries are and should be
doing to engage to engage in to
engage in digital scholarship.
There have been
a number of studies in recent
years that looks at how
libraries are accommodating the
recent personnel to serve in
scholarship needs and
amok among others found that
the support is relatively new so
that the responding library, 57
percent of the scholarship
library personnel has joined in
the last five years and 74
percent have been doing the work
for less than five years and
digital scholarship report is
frequently contributed across
the libraries from librarians
and archivists and professional
support staff and student
assistance.  Support for digital
libraries is growing rapidly.
And on the individual level,
other states have examined what
librarians are doing now in
digital scholarship and what is
needed.  There are two volumes
that present a variety of youth
cases and groups such as ACRL's
digital humanities interest
group and special groups for
organizations that have the
communities that are involved in
DH are growing.
And then several libraries have
also begun to link programs to
train the librarians in digital
scholarship school such as
University of Maryland's
incubator, which we will talk
about in a minute, Colombia's
library and several others.
Despite the
Despite the initial advances
there
is still a ways to go.
How can we empower all academic
librarians to engage in
scholarship and new forms of
research?  This is where our
project intends to step in.  We
proposed a project to the
institute of museum and library
services which they will fund to
use the Hati trust digital
project resources.  I will talk
about how it uses the skills
specifically by connecting
librarians to digital
connections via skill building
and research methods for tech
mine.  First to talk about the
motivation and philosophy for
the project.  To set the
context, our work is based in
the Hathi trust digital library.
Many of you may be familiar with
the Hathi trust digital library
which is over 5 billion pages
at last count.  The Hathi trust
digital library provides equal
access and preserves digital
content.  We enable researchers
to gather the information from
the library and work and data
sets and analyze and produce new
findings.  The Hathi trust
research center is jointly led
by the University of Illinois
Urbana-ChampaignUrbana-Champaign,
and worked on the research
services and support.  We
facilitate the access to textual
data so at the moment you can
obtain access to the public
domain corpus as full text and
other more granular context and
our goal is to provide out of
copy right and copy right text
for consumption research and my
colleagues are working on the
development very soon, more
details can be on the website
about that.  As we develop the
resources in the HTRC we
increasingly realize to make
effective research for users, we
need to learn about their work
and learn firsthand what they do
and large scale technology
research so in the last year we
conducted a user assessment
study consisting of of about
fifteen or sixteen interviews so
far of scholars from a variety
of disciplines and librarians
and the team members, did some
initial analysis of the data
that we have coated to develop
preliminary user personas.  The
digital librarian and the
faculty member and the students.
We are finalizing the analysis
and the personas are not
concrete by any mean but they
characterize the different
levels of users that engage with
our data and the faculty and
researcher with advanced tools
or advanced need, the newer
graduate researcher that is
exploring methods and tools and
then there is the research
personnel that is establishing
here as the librarian and the
persona of the librarian
particularly caught our eye in
the front of what we have been
considering.  As we seek to
engage researchers in using the
Hathi trust digital library, we
realize that librarians are a
critical linch pin to the data
and the tools to provide matches
to data and tools to the
researchers.  And so in 2015,
we were awarded a three year
Laura bush 21st century program
from the library services to
develop a digital library
service program as titled there.
I want to highlight the word
empowerment in our title because
empowerment is key to our
program.  We teach librarians
about the fundamental approaches
to text mining and how to work
with textual data and I will
explain in a minute how to work
with others and the textual data
is a course to the HTRC, the
course of the curriculum is the
text mining and the goal is to
help librarians promote digital
digital more digital more
broadly.  Helping librarians
with new context for the
services that address the
particular needs for faculty
ensuing digital scholarships and
active research projects to  to
become part to become part of
the institutions and
to provide foundational
knowledge to transform academic
library scholars and data into
more data intensive
collaborative learning spaces
into the use of knowledge that
enables them to participate in
the scholarly dialogue.  The
colleague team is listed here
led by me and then there is Beth
and Steven Downey and we have
four partner institutions who
span different sizes and types
of higher education.  So the the
university the university of
bloomington which
is our HTRC partner and
led by Angela Courtney.
Lafayette college, a liberal
arts college, dean Neil and
Northwestern University and
University of Maryland, Chapel
Hill, Louis was the original and
now Amanda Henry is joining our
team.  So the project began in
October of 2015, again, and we
spent the last year developing
the curriculum that keeps the
trained librarians and the
professionals using the tools in
text mining research and this
year we are launching pilot
workshops at all five
institutions to test drive the
curriculum.  To talk about the
curriculum in a bit of detail,
it's the tools and services in
the HTRC.  We teach them to work
with the HTRC portal which has
users build data sets of text
and the corpus and the Hathi
trust digital library and the
algorithm that is in the portal
as long as the caveats as
mentioned today.  We are
preaching them how to use the
Hathi trust data and we realize
that librarians function in a
variety of different contexts
and our focus to teach about the
fundamentals of text mining and
perhaps what we might call data
science skills.  We introduce
participants to the command line
and how to harvest data through
web scraping and how to clean
data anddata and howdata and how
to run basic scripts
for data manipulation and basic
type of text analysis.
The curriculum is targeted
targeted at targeted at
beginners mostly
and the platforms that we use
in teaching such as python
anywhere are aimed at make the
skills as widely accessible as
possible in various teaching
environments so we ultimately
aim to build foundational skills
in text mining in librarians
through the trainer approach.
After they participate in the
workshop we hope to put them on
the road to developing the
foundational skills and they
also will be given a full speed
of instructional resources and
tools to teach their own
workshops at their own
institutions.  So next year
after we after we do after we do
the pilots and we find
the curriculum a bit more, we
will conduct a nationwide road
show workshop that will train
professionals at major
conferences and key geographic
areas around the United States
and teaches the HTRC tools and
the principles at thethe
principles at the largethe
principles at the large
scale text mining.  We will
refine the materials one last
time and have the tool kit that
has the last package for
materials and resources that all
librarians can take and use and
will be hosted on the open
institutional repository and
another outcome we hope to build
is a network community of
librarians who want to continue
these conversations and share
their experiences as they begin
to keep text mining and digital
scholarscholarships at the own
institution and has the
assessing of the process of
research development and
examines strategies for LIS
professional development.  In
this way we help to build a
community practice around a
curriculum as the trainees
become trainers.  So our project
I believe will be a significant
step forward in addressing the
question of how do we build
skills in digital humanities and
digital scholarship in the data
in our libraries and I suppose
there are a couple of bigger
larger issues as we think about
librarianship.  So first has
been made clear by presenters
today, we need to
reconceptualize our work and
engagement and not
all librarians are collection
managers but most of us touch in
various ways collection and
analyzing and architecture and
interface design and with our
own collections as well as our
own holding and throughout the
landscape from the vast digital
resources to the Hathi trust and
the digital collections,
librarians will have to engage
with collections as becoming
familiar with data acquisition
and think about the broader ways
that users want to engage with
our collection in the digital
format.  And a lot, another key
area and opportunity along with
this is how librarians can
engage and point in the research
life cycle.  Scholars across
the discipline are gathering
data and looking for the library
as a source of research support
beyond just providing research
and reference guidance and this
is reflected in the changing
nature of who we are hiring in
the library for areas such as
data
Curation and data analysis.
The 2013 report from college
research and libraries notes
that quote research
collaborations between faculty
and librarians continue to
benefit both partners.  Faculty
benefits from library resources
and librarian expertise and
librarians benefit from the
opportunity of the significant
partner ofpartner of research
partner of research and partner
end quote.  The valuable
reports is only a number of
studies that the partnership
between researchers and
librarians is more necessary
than ever.  So in conclusion I
believe that projects such as
ours will categorize thought
processes on how to train
librarians to meet the demands
of the data-driven
scholarshipscholarships.  You
might consider the question,
what does the librarian need and
respond for whom the research
is needed and how can the
librarians share the skills and
supportive research for digital
scholarship?  So as we think
about translating our collection
into usable and accessible
data, I believe that the
research connections with
librarians and faculty users
will be key to our success.  I
want to thank you again for
supporting our project and the
Hathi trust digital library and
the institution.
Thank you.  [Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  A nice Switcharoo.
SPEAKER:  A nice Switcharoo.  I
learned after a long painful
experience that I can't type my
password and talk at the same
time.  My computer is very
secure but I definitely can't
multi task in that password.  So
I want to say that I am
absolutely thrilled to have been
invited
to speak today alongside people
who have been doing the work.
I hope that this is not a jaded
thought, because speaking at the
Library of Congress is not all
that.  But it is.  I am pleased
to be on that panel for two
reasons.  Mycopanelists are two
people from whom I have learned
a lot and who I look to continue
to learn, and also the topic of
developing communities of
practice, is one that I have a
lot of complicated feelings
about and that I love
to talk about.  So I am going
to try to do this in the context
of the initiative that we are
working on in the University of
Maryland,
Synergies Among Digital
Humanities and African American
History and Culture: An
Integrated Research and Training
Model and I want to make one
other personal note that I
engage with collections,
collections, wecollections, we
personally
I engage with collections in
data in a number of ways.  I
occasionally write code to do
some analysis and satisfy
curiosity and have the data
visualization.  However, my main
job is to work with people, who
are doing things with
collections or want to do things
with collections and these are
both analog and digital
collections or maybe more
precisely to help bring together
humans who are engaged with
data.  data.  So I want to
talk about the ways in which we
are thinking some of the issues
that arise in the context of
this initiative.  Synergies
among
digital humanities and African
American history and culture is
too long.  We call it the ad hum
initiative.  It's important
that the African American part
comes first.
AADHUM.  So this is our project
hashtag.
Where hopefully we will be able
to have further conversation
about the topic.  What you are
hearing today is also one voice,
from what is already a sort of
large and multi facetted
initiative.  This is me.  That
is my Twitter handle and my
contact information.  Of course
I am also speaking to you as a
member of the community, and
really multiple other
communities.  The people who
have been working hard for two
years to make this initiative a
reality at Maryland, the team of
people beyond that, who are now
joining the project and
contributing their skills and
yet even though this project is
only really seven or eight
months old, already the number
of people, the community of
people who are engaged in this
work is quite large.  So I can
only speak to, you know, the
limits of my personal experience
and my reflections on the work
that we are collectively doing
together and I think it's
important not to forget.  That
we are always in meshed in the
larger communities and I will
come back to that point in a
second.  So the website for
today's event explains in the
kind of intro text that the rise
and the tools of analyzing data
has allowed researchers to
create new models of scholarship
and inquiry.  I'm a humanist so
I can't help but picking at the
terms of the debate.  So I
think that one way we can then
understand the communities of
practice is as one model of
these new modes of scholarship
and inquiry.  Which is to say
that communities are part of how
accessible digital collections
may be coupled with or may
failed to be coupled with tools
for processing and analyzing
data, to do work that matters to
other humans.  And so my basic
premise is that the world of
collections and data depends
upon the design and nurturing of
communities and the phrase
communities of practice, I think
is important to realize that
this is a subset.  Right.  The
phrase community and practice is
a term of art and comes from a
particular place.  To sketch
this history very briefly and to
do it absolutely no justice at
all.  The original Nexus for the
context of communities of
practice is in workplace
anthropology and understands
adult learning and improving
adult learning and provides ad
hoc and improvised ways within
workplaces to quote get the job
done when existing existing
knowledge existing knowledge or
managerial
direction falls short and of
course people who engage with
the idea have been interested in
how these practices create and
reshape the identities of
workers.  And thus surprisingly
the communities of practice have
been taken up and discussed as
a managerial tool, especially
for breaking the traditional
barriers and promoting quote
innovation.
Andrew Cox has provided a brief
overview in the practice in a
2005 article in the journal of
information science for those of
you who are interested anymore.
And the progression that he
traces is certainly a more and
more organizational study,
managerial approach for the
community to practice.  What
should we take from the career
of our community to practice.
As a concept to take back with
us for our reflection on how we
think about collections of data.
Certainly there is much to like.
Learning as an active social
process, not a mechanical
transfer of skills and
knowledge, the emphasis on
improvising the suit and
breaking down barriers and
building among like minded
folks.  I think the theme around
today's event is certainly the
expression that we feel when we
use terms like community
practice.  And we want to find
others that are doing the same
things we are doing.  That can
be beneficial and also block us
from seeing other things.  What
might the two acceptances of
practice be for thinking about
communities in the context of
collection not allow us to be?
I think there is a tendency to
treat communities of practice as
though they might be an
emergent property of material
and method.
Right, if you make materials
available and you have people
who might be expert in certain
methods or who are becoming
expert in certain methods, they
will find each other.  They will
do amazing things and certainly
that is true.  And some of the
central scholarship in community
in practice can be read to
support the quazi emergent idea.
But in my experience, this is
really almost never the case.
We are not seeing something
important that is actually
happening.  It's important to
remind ourselves that
communities are not spontaneous
or organic.  And to quote the
wonderful critical theorist
Miranda Joseph who has written
beautifully on the idea, to
invoke community is to engage
the question of belonging and
power.  And that I think is one
area in which the work we're
doing within the AADHUM
initiative is asking us to push
beyond the communities and
practice that we have inherited
in the organizational context.
In the context it notoriously
has done little to work with
power of notion and dominance
which is an important element of
the community that is we live
in.  It's important to
understand that communities of
practice are always communities
within other communities.  The
work of designing them, because
it is intentional design and
nurturing them will be done in
the communities which we already
live, the destruction of power
and relationships between people
of different backgrounds and
experiences that exist already.
We don't get to sort of wipe the
plate clean and work in narrow
technical terms about community
of practice as if they were not
implicated in the American
community, the DC community,
whatever community we find
ourselves living in, the campus
community, that we have to sort
of take this into account in
terms of both designs and
nurturing.  It may be not
everyone in the community comes
to work with the same sort of
emotional experience of things
happening out there in the
world.  And so this is why it's
imperative not to get the active
work of community development
fall below the intention and
this work demands every bit as
much for the collection and
development of tools and we are
responsible for the communities
we create or fail to create.  I
think listening to the talk
earlier, you know, we are
working towards being maybe a
little bit more like the the fan
the fan
section communities that we are
hearing about and that might
look different from the way that
we understand the communities
of senior scholars and academics
of the public.  So to try and
explain a little bit more of
what I mean in concrete terms, I
will say a little more on how
we working through the
challenges in the AADHUM.  It's
funded by a grant through the
Andrew W.
Melon foundation and we are in
one year of three years of work.
The work of AADHUM is led the
center for Synergy and the
humanities of myth or the
direction of my boss Neil and
also partnering in the
initiative are the center for
global migration studies, the
David C. Driscol center and the
culture for African Americans as
well as the library where I
report to my other boss and the
work is led by our faculty
member and includes post
doctoral associates, research
faculty and staff and advisory
board of scholars for multiple
disciplines in the African
American culture of history and
librarians have the assistance
and we hope that faculty
students and members of the
wider community that we hope to
fold in.  And it's worth saying
since Harriett mentioned that
the incubator which is part of
the initiative, where we have
gone from the first generation
where it was gone from building
up skills and capacity along our
librarians to a model where
everyone is all mixed together.
And we take on that greater
challenge of having all of these
people mixed together with
their different experiences and
expertise because ultimately I
think that is the way that we
need to be working and for the
goals of the AADHUM initiative
initiative is initiative is to
advance and expand the
fields of digital humanity and
African American cultural
studies and develop the pipeline
for the next generation of
scholars who engage in the
intersection.  Which is to say
that we are directly engaged in
building communities of
practice, in building
communities and that the
communities will be a measure of
our project as much as any of
the scholarship whether it be a
project or public
programming that we also
produce.  We be willing to be
measured by the community we are
making.  That is a critical
part of the work that the grant
has set itself out to do.  So
rather than produce a single
research project, AADHUM seeks
to transform the African
American community and the
social studies field.  To
accomplish this goal we will do
a number of things, foster
scholars and students and
working at the intersection and
will facilitate and creating and
revising new sources at the
University of Maryland in
disciplines related to African
American history and culture
which is frankly all of them.
And to provide training and
development opportunities to
support local and regional
participants in receiving and
producing the research, and I
will come to that part in a
second.  We are also planning to
organize the national
conference to bring together
those parts of the network that
we can -- who are doing digital
research like this, that we can
touch and we can reach, and to
oversee the digitization and
description at the Driscol
center and the ASCLOR archive at
the library that are relevant
to research, labor, migration
and artistic expression which
are the core themes which we are
organizing our work and I want
to stop here and say also that
this is only sort of the latest
entry in work that many people
have been doing for a very long
time.  Right, again, we're not
wiping the plate clean.  We're
not newly bringing into being
this collaborative community for
people working into digital
ways and people studying African
American histories and life.
There is a long history of such
work and we are happy to be
joining that conversation.
Trying to do our part.  So let
the central point be lost in all
of these details.  The way that
I would describe our community
of practice, our community,
AADHUM is a community invested
in the study of African American
history and culture.  And I
want to phrase it that way
because I think that often
because of the history of the
term communities of practice, we
find ourselves using it in far
too technical intent.  That it's
about skill transfer or
achieving some sort of
organizational mission.  And so
we are putting the idea of all
of the different ways that we
can use digital methods and
tools and digital collection to
study African American history
and culture at the center.  And
by no means does that mean we
are giving up being invested in
a vision of digital work, that
explores new ways of using
computing and informed by you
know, the scholars who have
studied African American history
and culture before the project
even began.  And a lot of the
work right now is sort of
imagining the programming that
we call the digital humanities
incubator because we have it
from the past and my colleagues
Catherine and Lynne are doing
this work and I am reflecting
the work they are doing and the
incubators has been an evolving
process where we focus on the
idea of incubating project
ideas.  Building particularly
skills and capacities such that
librarians can do digital
projects.  And that had some
positives as far as they went.
But then the next time you got a
chance to run this it
programming we decided that we
would put the data at the
center, and that has been a new
idea that has sort of stuck with
us.  Right.  That we put the
data in the center and asked our
community all of the ways in
which they might wish to respond
to it, without presuming that
we know particular methods or
techniques that we need to
communicate outward to them.
The scholar of visual culture at
Laura Wexler makes a nice point
with regard to crowd sources
and talking about how we go
beyond sort of using the crowd
for data collection or data
production and being open to all
of the other ways in which the
community might wish to respond
to a given data center or given
collection and also be open to
taking that in.  Even if it goes
beyond simple transcription.
The idea of the incubate is
evolving, we are evolving this
idea with the ethics of building
a community fully in mind.  So
this perhaps means, how do we
stay in touch with people who
come into contact with us or
engaging with us for longer than
we might, if it was simply
skills training.  How do we
build an ongoing relationship.
Another aspect of it is, where
do we do this work?  Right.  We
are all sort of embodied people.
And the spaces in which we do
this work and who else is in the
room, and a lot about who can
access and feel like they are
part of the committee.  That is
an aspect that we are really
thinking about and there are
some key practitioners who have
the partsdesign and citing the
feminist in technology that says
we need to get need to get away
need to get away from
viewing things as discrete
objects and network devices and
instead view design work as
quote entry development into
regulations including context
and alliances that make
technical systems possible and
as in Helgram Write this is hard
design work or various
practices and technology can
currently under go change and
demand what they call continuous
infrastructuring and aligning
of partly conflicting interest.
So I think it's useful to think
about the work we do about
building community
around the collections, around
the data as the work of
continuous infrastructuring and
think about the people in if our
communities and the work that
they are having, the goals that
they have, the work that they
they have.  they have.  And the
infrastructure that we do, how
how do how do we imagine
aligning all of the conflicting
interest and not getting caught
up in the rush of finding
people who are just doing things
like us, but think about doing
the hard design work of
continuous infrastructuring or
designing
and nurturing communities.
Just as a closing thought,
communities of practice may be a
fine starting point to how we
imagine access and youth model.
It can't be the stopping point.
It's between 20 and 30 years old
and of course does not make it
out dated in the humanities and
people have had a lot of
interesting things then.  And in
the spirit of being good
interdisciplinary borrowers, we
should try to engage those ideas
as well and that is
particularly important as we do
this.  To think about how we
make collections as data into
what Miranda Joseph calls
legitimate sites of empathy and
concern.
Thank you.  [Applause]
person.  So just
give me a moment.  I will go as
far as to say the dream is dead
but it's not thriving.
Unfortunately I have my bag.  My
mommy
bag of
dongles.  I have been interested
today in sort of thinking about
how things can be pulled
together, right.  I am not here
necessarily to pull things
together, but I am always
interested.  This is when the
problems are coming at the end
of the day, I am always sort of
interested in where we can find
connections between the things
that have always been said.
This is the way that it's the
end of the day and there is so
much to say because I am hyper
stimulated by all of the stuff
that people have said before, so
I want to begin today by
thinking about the kinds of
issues that emerge when we think
about data as a personal
matter.
Often we speak of collections at
large and thinking about small
things.  Right, there is a way
in which we talk about
collections when we think about
digital humanities and work and
archives and so on.  When you
are thinking about the raw
material that constitutes
collections, you are often
talking about personal
things.
Right.  At some point much of
what we refer to in collections
is personal.  That's what I want
to talk about today.
Collections, the boxes of
receipts, piles of play bills in
someone's closet.  I had the
huge privilege of being able to
go to the national museum of
African American history and
culture opening this weekend and
a lot was made I think
rightfully of how so much of
this sort of material history
has been left out of
conversation because it has been
flown away in the addicts of
people in the conversations
previously.
So it is really sort of weighing
on me as we prepare to talk and
think about collections.  I
also want to think about what is
gained and loss in a transition
from one kind of space to a
local and a personal and to
other kinds of uses, the
archivals to computational and
so on.  Even though I refer not
to belabor the usually dicotomy
I pulled the term Datum story
telling because it helps me
think about data, to reveal
theestheestheestheestheescavated
and think about what is at
stake in control and management
and thereof.  If we accept that
there is value in data, we need
to accept that our lives are
strings of data.  I am thinking
here of reason work.
The work done by Louis Pulvacich
and each artist goes through
all kinds of personal
information and conveys the
personal information tracked
over a week into hand-drawn data
visualization.  I found this
super interesting, right.  I
will put it back so you can see
a little more.  I found this
super interesting because there
is a way in which you took this
notion of tracking, right, the
watch you wear, the wearables
and so on and made it back to
what we usually think of as an
analog art.  Right.  So I was
interested in how they talk
about it as well.  This is a
quote.  We have also conceived
their data as a personal
documentary.  Rather than the
quantified self-project which is
a subtle but important
distinction.  And instead of
using data to become more
efficient, we argue we use data
to become more humane and to
connect with ourselves at a
deeper level.  Life is partly
the data and still transformed
and produces nearly liable law
material for art, story and
visualization.  In dear data,
each datum is self-consciously
employed to tell a story.  Datum
story telling then is a way of
thinking about intentionally in
the archival development and
without losing at the same time,
the people, despite of the
human.  And later on I want to
interrogate the notion of the
human a little bit.  But for now
we will go with it, right.
When thinking about the data,
the human, the person is a
reference.  And I'm thinking of
a person who can self-manage,
disseminate and remix the trays.
This reminds me of the work that
we know happens at every at
every  at every age.
Telling
stories and telling to our
personal collections, rounds our
sense of self very much, in the
sense of what is familiar and
the metaphor I use for it is
digging in the crate.  The
archive that you are constantly
digging through and you are
digging through it in the
interest of being able to show
people something new.  So the
archival is specifically
specifically  specifically
deployed and it sounds very old.
It
sounds
corny
when
you
say
it  like that like that but
when you
are there, it's the
meaningfulness.
And it's corny.  It's this old
sort of -- God it was really
embarrassing.  I was looking for
it and it was essentially a
coke commercial that had would
be in a moment of marketing and
it was the own sort of, you
know, Mary J. Blige and method
man commercial and in the
commercial they were playing the
song, you are all I need to get
by and there were kids up
stairs looking for the hip hop
version and the grand parents
downstairs listening to the
Marvin gains version and they
have the floor, up stairs, right
and you have the kids jumping
up and down stairs they are like
yes, they finally found the
truth.  So the notion of digging
the crate is always found
really interesting.
And I think it's useful for
thinking about the individual
making choices to generational
and communities.  It also brings
the idea of duration and the
idea of the past itself is a
collection because of the
historical contour.  The crate
brings with us the joy of
discovery, a joy amplified by
what the discovery will enable.
What is more difficult to
conceptualize is the limits.
There should be a limit to that
digging.  And in titled the
digital afterdigital after life
digital after life of
lost family photos, described
the work done, you can see it
here on the screen, called faded
resistance.  There is profound
photographs of African
Americans, and what I was
talking about in terms of the
stuff in flee markets, right,
the collection of photographs,
so no one knows to whom they
belong but we know my virtue
that they are important to
someone, how do we fill that
gap?  How do we think about
this?  The anecdote is released
in the project and we might
experience a transition from
data to datum in the
increasingly digital life world.
Who took these photos?  Who do
they depict?  The basic
conceptual details we would have
usually expected from snapshots
that are missing here.  The
absence of this information is
bitter sweet.  We
are
bewilded and there was a
surprising term.
The facial recognition
technology began to match them
with real people.  We were not
sure who wassure who was doing
sure who was doing the tagging,
intrigue
d and worried he sent a message
to one of the individuals who
was tagged in several of the
pictures.  There was no
response. A few weeks later he
got a request that he take the
pictures down.  Of the
experience he had already been
thinking about how databases and
tags are not neutral.  How can
they wind up being hostile
towards communities of color.  I
can totally understand.  Quote
this man was saying we are not
really participants.  The black
body is used as a commodity and
something prevailed.  You are
not welcome.  This is not art.
Get the hell out of our lives
and I understood it.  Insofar as
the collection that speaks
curation we can think about the
rightful sense of danger and the
danger and the very danger and
the very idea of being
collected might bring and the
invasive work of conversion is
the object of moments into data
and the parsing and the
combined.  It's important to
note that I am actually quite a
technical person so it's a
shadow technical talk behind and
thisityity I'm talking about
data.  I am thinking will JSON
and the ways in which we break
larger things down into smaller
compartmentalized mixable units,
right, the shadow behind it,
like the tech shadow.  But I
only have so much time so I am
rushing through the other part
for now.  I wish I can have a
super hero name.  Like tech
shadow, whatever.  Sorry.  I am
also taking with the problem of
disappearance which by the
thought works against this work.
work.
Andwork.
And one examples has
the code turn to, actually it's
this one.
This photo.  As you read the
back of this photo, he says
quote it's suggested that it's
paced into an album and that
it's ripped out and people who
are familiar with this even
through the blackness that shows
the particular kind of glue
that was made to last and then
it was nonetheless ripped out.
Right, how do we map and mark
the transition?  How do we think
about it as well.  This is no
glue stick decision.  As equally
significant then to us in this
image is hidden from us.  Much
of what is at stake in example
comes down to ownership.  The
idea of personal collection is
an exercise in exclusion.
Right.  My example is I have
been doing work for the last few
years and butler managed the
archives which is just amazing
but whenever I am working at
some point I am overwhelmed by
the sense that I have to be
careful and thinking about the
archive as her collection.  It's
a collection of her stuff.  But
insofar as she died suddenly
and unexpectedly and young.
Researchers live with the fact
that she had little hand in the
duration.  I wonder what she
would have thrown away, little
flips of paper and receipt and
all kinds of information, right.
On one hand it's for researchers
like me but because she so
carefully practiced her life, I
know that her delusions would
have probably be just as
instructive, as a
somewhat  somewhat incluesist
inclusivity.  Digging in the
crates and permission that can't
always co-exist when thinking
of the path.  Many have taken
the ethical questions of taking
the archives and so on and I
want to think about this for a
moment as a way of introducing
the mission mission of mission
of how we
might mourn in the midst of
opportunity
so I will move on.  At the
forefront of thinking about
purpose in the in most digital
works and the commitment to open
as we hear this a lot, it's
important works and many of us
pointed out, unlock some of the
negative oppressive ownership
relation
with resource-enabled entities
collecting with willing and
sometimes not others where you
get all of your stuff.
Regardless the openness and
publicness and access on a hall
mark with the colonial
approaches to archive making,
and I believe they are.  I am
also nonetheless interested in
the meaningfulness of exclusion,
illusion and deletion and
sometimes in the name of the
narrative making.  The
meaningfulness, in other words,
the story telling.  I am
thinking here is Michelle
Caldwell's work and thinking
about the employment through the
archival materials.  The
theoretical foundations for
community-based archives,
reminds us that quote the memory
archives are not just memory
activists but visionares whose
work receives space and time.
In the lining archival work with
memory and the future, rather
than only the historical
recovery of the past, Caldwell
gets us to think about our own
archival project and quote not
just about documenting a more
diverse identity of the past
based on the present but rather
by uncovering previously untold,
ignored or misinterpreted
history, communities can imagine
and reimagine different
trajectories for the future so
it's not just enough to say we
are going to expand our archives
by putting all people into it.
Right.  The notion of
empowerment is about making the
archive available in such a way
that it can be done by the
communities that need it most.
Right.  It's an important
distinct.  Thinking about  about
this, about this,
I would argue, gives us the
generic possibility of eliciting
data, computationally.  And
it's also titled network
knowledge and digital spaces,
methodology and Emily
asked us to think about quote
story telling is knowledge
making in a place of knowing
it's not the place of one
individual who has passed down
to others instead it's the
network state in the role of the
community as the knowledge
partner.  Again, I offer not all
of this as a commentary on the
difference between story telling
and the local versus data and
the machine or something, but
that if we are thinking about
about how to about how to
decolonize what
is collected, we must be
thinking about knowledge
transfer and thinking about
different design and interface.
The motion quote of knowledge
is seated in the context and
emerges when we're supposed to
listen to it.  The idea, right,
is that you can't necessarily
approach an archive already
knowing what you are expecting
to get.  A proper  proper
archive is proper archive is
something that comes
up all day today, right, the
idea, right for the archives is
a depository teaching you that
you are not going to know what
you get when you get there.  But
this is a compelling designed
problem.  How do we enable
these arrivals sns, right, and
points out quote
decolonization is not just about
the designs but reshaping the
crafts men and crafts women
about reshaping the matters and
reform need not to look at the
resisting models and not to use
them as paradigm.
When there are so many archives
or archival collections there
are models, right on different
kinds of repositories that
assume you are working with the
material at hand.  The digital
is in fact different.  I know
many people are talking about
this but when we are thinking
about what they can do, we need
no lost art form or lost world.
So with humanities we try to
work on ways of intellectual
understanding and the practice
again that shadows the
background it.  I am talking
about real projects and JSON and
all of these things right to
think about the different
realities and different
visualization.  One example goes
beyond the riot.  That has been
a really interesting project
and I will say a little more
little more about little more
about it
quickly.  It works with what
are essentially very localized
collections that are small
magazines made in small
communities between friends and
as you can imagine, this imposes
a wealth of information about
women's lives, right and the
last 30 to 50 years and holds
enormous information, right,
about all about all of the ways
that
the girls interact with pop
culture and ideas about growing
and so on, it's impressive but
at the same time you are
exquisitely dealing with
material that was made on some
level to walk a very fine line
between the private and the
public, right, they arethey are
madethey are made to be shared
and
they are private.  That's a
difficult line to think about.
Twitter and Facebook, same
place.  It's kind of private.
You would not just jump into
someone else's Twitter
conversation if you don't know
the people.  Just start thinking
about what that means, right.
So they changed the project, not
just changed the project but
served the project again about
thinking not just a repository
but thinking quote subcultural
digital platform, right, and New
Hampshire college and mount
Holyoke college realized that
not onlynot only doesnot only
does the collection enable
a vast number of computational
mapping and visualization
possibilities but the clicking
-- sorry, eliciting the
narratives and meaningfulness of
the incredibly localized and
specific texts also makes
creating some form of encounter
interface that enables you to
understand the experience is as
important as the self-code.
That the experience of
navigating the archives is as
much as an educational
experience as finding the actual
object which the archives hold.
we have been talking about in
archives in reproducing a moment
of discovery, right, a moment
where you realize this is it.  I
did not know this was it.  How
did I live without this?  What
is this?  Much like musical
improviization, it
has an incredible archive
and what I am calling archives
is meta data machine readable
structure because if we imagine
the way that we would like to --
the way that I would like them
to, I am getting away, it's a
sad day, but the ways that we
want them to work, right, then
there is a way in which we have
to go in the opposite direction
of what one imagines this
conversation might go, right, we
turn back to the machinery, we
turn back to the compartmental
life and turn back to the
smallest bits of data because it
produces the flexibility that
makes possible more kinds of
interfaces and more kinds of
exchangeses.  We have to break
it even more than we realize.
This means moving away from
retrieval on the archive person
and enable the user to
personalize the encounter and
bring what they made to the
archive and by virtue of the own
specificity make their own
things.  I am happy to say more
about this in the projects and
also the kind of resistance that
you want us to think about.
When to exclude and when to
delete.  Many items in the
collection were likely produced
by people who never intended for
them to be disseminated that
the kind of scale that
digitization makes possible and
they might want to share
something else and something
that none of us could imagine 30
years ago.  Again if we imagine
the most critically informed
decolonial future oriented
perspective on archives, that
work must still nonetheless,
graph with the refusal of data.
At any moment, datum, the
individual must be recovered
from data never to be returned
again.  I'll stop there.  there.
[Applause].
there.  [Applause].   so again I
think we have Mike for Q and A
out
here.  Do we have any questions
from the audience
for our panel?
Do the panelists have any
question for each other?
SPEAKER:  I totally do.  I was
really changing my whole my
whole level my whole level when
I was on the hot seat.  But I
was really compelled by this
notion in the community of
practice that is something that
can't be spontaneous and
something that takes work.  And
I was justering wondering the
kind of work that you do, what
the challenges look like.  It
was in your talk, your talk was
like the bomb, but if I was to
step back, it was a little out
of place where you said this
thing that some people might
come to work that day and might
not be feeling all of the weight
of the world and things
happening outside and I think it
was an amazing way of when you
are doing the good work and
doing the work that matters,
right, and then you are working
with the team and everyone does
does  does not have the same
relation with
the work, can you say more
about that?
SPEAKER:  Right, I think it's --
so one thing I didn't get to say
was that part of the sort of
trying to imagine this structure
and sort of keeping our
community sort of before our
eyes is I think to grappel with
the ways in which our different
experiences are producing the
new knowledge right there as we
are having the different
experiences and not to say that
stuff is outside of the work
that we are doing and to try to
understand how to comes into the
work that we're doing and
whether it's my experience that
day or someone else's experience
or all of our experiences to
find out how those different
ways of coming to the work then
shape the work, rather than
trying to draw the boundary and
say if we only keep all of those
things outside we can get on
with it.  So I guess that was
partly what was on my mind.
SPEAKER:  Other question back
here?  If you can yell, I will
repeat it.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  (Inaudible).
SPEAKER:  Sure service something
from Marisa's talk about
thinking about question in the
archives and interfaces to what
is deleted or missing, to what
we ourselves need to protect in
the archives so I wonder if you
have reflections on it as well.
Just as a sort
of general way of certainly,
being in being in tune being in
tune for the
record is not a new thought but
trying again to return to the
conversation that we are just
having about what do I see from
my perspective and what do I see
from their perspective and can
we piece that data together.
Now I am trying to put it
together with the idea of data
and idea and I'm not going to be
able to do it on the fly.
Certainly there is that.
Thinking about being conscious
of the ways in which the people
who might be in this archive are
in the archive because they are
being represented there, you
know from like by the state or
from some other body and not in
their own control and maybe we
want to recover their story but
maybe we also sort of don't want
to ex foes, you know,
populations that you know have
been mistreated in certain ways
and there is a lot of it that
goes into it.  We're at the
beginning of the process and I
am learning from my colleagues
about what they want to bring to
this and what they want to look
for and I think we will have a
better answer for you in a year
or six months and we are really
kind of at the beginning and I
am wondering if you really any
reflections on that.
SPEAKER:  I really don't know.
There is so much in that
question.  It's the question of
translation, right, between
media and thinking about what
happens when one thing becomes
another.  I think the question
of exclusion, right, you have
exclusion that sort of personal
agency and choice trying to talk
about it and then there is also
exclusion as protection which
I'm really compelled by the
social media stuff thinking back
to what is terrifying to think
about, right.  And so there is a
way in which imagining what
should be excluded has to take
into account the imagination of
the future the archives can
produce and at the same time
understand the way in which it
works in the present.  That's
what we what we are talking
about in
a way that we are talking about
exclusion,
it's a person who is standing
there and remains and says no
more, right and I am babling
around this and you can sort of
see it like where we are trying
to, both of us, you more so,
this is something that you are
thinking about on the ground
right now and like I was saying
with the project sort of
thinking about what it means to
have to, at every moment, also
understand yourself as a steward
and what constitutes yourself
as a good stewardship and at
many times it was not given to
us.
Nobody said please take these
things and do this stuff, right.
SPEAKER:  To have
humility about the
stewardship.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  You talked
about making librarians for
digitally sufficient, how will
you get in contact with the
programs in your local area?
SPEAKER:  So we are reaching out
in terms of our pilot workshops
-- so yeah we have natural
contact already with librarians
who are interested and we are
promoting at least the pilot
workshops and each partner
institution has plans to not
only work with their own, but
reach out to other librarians
and start bringing them in and
we have started reaching out to
programs and librarians in the
area in Atlanta and then
thinking at the
conversation conferences and
conferences and howconferences
and how we
reach out to libraries and
digital scholarship centers and
anybody who has natural
inclination can be interested in
this work and there is a number
of outlets that you can reach
out to as well.
SPEAKER:  Any other questions?
Right here.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Professor
green, and the whole panel, in
your training there is a lot of
talk about collaboration today.
Have you thought about training
the librarians and the
researchers together?
SPEAKER:  Certainly that is
something that we are thinking
about doing and thinking about
the ideas of mutual informing
expertise and ignorance between
the many different ideas back
and forth in the training rather
than thinking of it as one set
of experts delineated in the
front of the room.  We are try
trying specifically to do that.
SPEAKER:  In HTRC workshops we
do that already and teach
librarians and researchers in
the workshop and the grant is
specifically focused and
targeted and man dated through
librarians but we are developing
the training and curriculum so
librarians are able to teach
researchers across all
discipline and research
questions so it's an interesting
challenge with the curriculum
addressing what librarians
librarians need librarians need
to
know and their
needs and also thinking
through, how do
we enable them to then train
and serve audiences.
SPEAKER:  And at digital
humanities we have a very
explicit set up where we very
actively encourage -- so we do
most of our training around
projects and develop the
training so we can develop a
sense of what people need and
offer a little bit of the
workshop to get the appetite so
people want to learn more, in
terms of bringing their own sort
of subject area, but we have a
very exquisite very exquisite
rule very exquisite rule of
flattening
out some of the relations
whenever possible and the staff
as soon as they are equally
eligible for the BPI together on
projects, we encourage projects
to have to work across campuses
and also across the categories
as a way of sort of emphasizing
not only the collaboration like
yay team but emphasizing that
the subject positions also bring
different kinds of expertise
even if they share a common
interest the sharing of the
expertise is somewhat mandatory.
I
hate using that word.
SPEAKER:  Okay.  Can we have the
microphone down here?
Okay
Okay so we
got seven minutes to go.  A
tweet came in from Dr. HatFord
and the question is, it's not to
anyone specifically, but in in
general, the communities as a
practice are not represented in
cataloging schemes and digital,
so how do you manage the levels
of those?  Great question.
SPEAKER:  Yeah I mean that
question, I will respond because
I feel like I was trying to
talk a little bit about that.
It's a challenge.  I think that
is the thing, I said it very
quickly and it's really not a
digital scholar.  But I think
it's incredibly important
because Bimbay is trying to get
us to think about the way that
inclusion is nothing without a
transformation of the actual
structure, right so I think that
is absolutely true that in many
ways the communities are not
right, and aren't represented in
the interfaced in the way we
use the archives and I think
when we're thinking about the
inclusion narrative where you
imagine life is a big pot and
get all different kinds of
people in it, we'll be okay,
right, I can't lie, it will make
me happy.  But at the same time
there is a way in which we are
talking about transformation by
default, we are thinking about
the digital, there has to be a
technical structural
transformation, right, so I am
not trying to dodge the
questions but I think that
people are looking that using
different ways of using other
kinds of programs that enable
you to produce interactive
interfaces because I do think
that interactivity does not sort
of solve or fix everything, but
it does get us a little bit
closer to thinking about the
calls and responds and the give
and the take from various
communities, right, that could
really be useful for thinking
about the work of archives
in the
digital.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  To what degree
are people represented in
archives or seen in others.
That's a question from Elise
Ednall on Twitter.
SPEAKER:  I mean it's certainly
true that we have more
collections of state records or
organization records and that
the idea of that sort of
community archives which is in
the control of those people,
relatively newer, that is not a
very satisfying answer to that
question.  I think it's a
dynamic that we all need to be
aware of and it shouldn't come
as a surprise.  But for instance
there is some of the work that
Jared
Drake is doing and informing a
lot of the questions and a lot
of the archives right now.
SPEAKER:  I think unfortunately
the answer is that they are not,
right, the stuff we have, the
materials that we have the most
of are the things that were
probably selected in the least
desirable ways, right, which is
another thing to reckon which.
I think a lot of the talks today
reflected that is why what you
are doing is so important in
just empowering more people to
actually create the collections
and also technically -- not even
just technically, but
collaboratively more people
create the archives as well and
those are two things that have
to happen and not just the
question for the future, but
it's something that we have to
think about because at the end
of the day, most of it is not
going to sound very good because
it's not actually a happy path.
have to end there.  Thank you
for sharing your work and your
thoughts with us.  And let's
give a round of applause.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  closinger
speaker today came earning
agraduate degree in it history
from university of California
University and went to library
school.  Since then Thomas has
held positions at University of
Illinois at
Urbana-Champaign and was hired
in UC santa Barbara.
I was the kid that always got
sick before the holiday.  This
is my holiday.  When asked in an
interview what a humanities
curator does, he said quote
translating a researcher's
disciplinary competencies so
they have purchased in the
digital digital environment
digital environment with
materials
that they may not be accustom
to working with.  This
commitment to making the
database more accessible can be
seen in the recent launch with
James Baker which helped use the
command lines that come up when
looking for digital resources.
really cool.  We asked him to be
the closing keynote speaker to
help make the future a bit more
accessible too.  Member of the
global outlook digital
humanities, member of common
practices, manager of data, it's
my pleasure to welcome Thomas
Thomas Padilla.  Thomas Padilla.
[Applause]
.
SPEAKER:  Okay.  So we are
finally here.  I would just say
at the out set that I am really
honored to be a part of this
conversation.  It wasn't so long
ago that about siven years
actually that I got on a plane
and flew to DC.  No job lined
up.  No internship lined up,
purelily based on wrangling one
of the manu script curators to
give me a tour and  it was in
October and I would like to say
it's a beautiful day but it was
pouring and freezing and I took
my shoes and luckily they let in
me at the back to let me in to
see George Washington's diary
and set me in on this path and
made it extra special that I am
actually here today.  I would
like to start by thanking Kate
Ward and the rest of the people
at the Library of Congress
putting on the event.  I know
the great work that goes into
putting on an event like  like
this. like this.
Thank you
for the work that you do.  I
think it's time for this to
happen and it's great to see the
Library of Congress take a
leadership role.  Today I'm
going to speak about --
speak about three conditions of
possibility to frame the way I
look at the data collection of
conversation.  Agency,
empowerment and ethics, but
first I want to start with a
story.  Early last week I exited
the library at UC santa Barbara
and put on my sunglasses and
made my way across campus.  It
was a typical day there, like
every day, 72 degrees, sunny, no
humidity, and I hope that
doesn't make you hate me.  The
quarter is just starting.
Students are out and about
running their way.  You can say
it's a time of uncertainty and
you can also say it's a time of
possibility.  I took a deep
breath and I tried to clear my
bind.  Lots of things to compete
for attention and to be honest,
it's not clear what matters.
What really matters is that it
can be difficult to hold close
to your heart, the reason you do
the things that you do and what
you do them for.  One foot in
front of the other, I started to
gain a measure of clarity.
Bikes, long boards, bikes with
people carrying surf boards and
enterprising Pokemon go players,
I reached my destination and it
was taller and had a tower at
the university.  We had a lot of
those.  I entered an elevator
to go into the tower.  The red
digits clicked past.  The doors
opened.  And I stepped toward a
meeting with the director on
campus and I am sure that there
are folks in the respective
communities walking to very
similar meetings as I am speak.
It was one of the first
conversations with the pressure
of possibilities everywhere.
Our conversation had a familiar
course and despite a bit of
variation here and there, the
surface is
often the same.  For you what
do you do and why does it matter
to the people?  In these
conversations I often find
myself in what is a humanity
curator, what is a librarian
for.  As the conversation
progressed, there was a lot of
academic hand gesturing around
the table.  We are pretty good
at that in university land and
after theafter the initialafter
the initial introductions I have
transition
ed to open the data topics when
the director interrupted me and
took a measured breath and
looked me squarely in the eyes
and asked yes, but Thomas,
what are the stakes?  It's an
important think to thing on.
Right.  What are the stakes?
Why
are all of us here in this
room?  I am sure that many of
our institutions have
collections that are not too
similar to me.  In this case,
it's the collection of themes.
We could relatively easily make
available the catalog data
describing those collections in
the way that the British library
has here.
Similarly, many of us probably
have works of art in our
collection.  Maybe not all of us
have Van Gough but surely we
have works of art and could
release individual measurements
of pixel value measuring things
like brightness and hue and
saturation, we can make that
available.
Some of us may even have things
in our collection that could be
used to try to make some sense
of the Paris attacks that
occurred earlier this year.  And
some of
us have released data related
to those attacks.  I think it
was more than 10 million tweets
captured in
the days following.  It brings
us back to the original
question.
What are the stakes?  Why
are we doing this?  For me I
learn to identify the mistakes
for  architecture.
architecture.  Like architects
we
are builders and we build
infrastructure and collections
and support the formation of
communities through these
efforts and the collection of
data conversations is an
extension of the commitments and
though it's important -- so it
is important to emphasize the
efforts that the conversation is
not about data for data's sake
or computation or computation's
sake.  Rather the work is
intended to build upon our
commitment and support nothing
nothing less than nothing less
than the ability that life
is
worth living.  This is not a
new role for us.  We have not
been without imperfection in
this role as has been indicated
by some of the presenters today.
Collection of data provides an
opportunity to continue
to learn to do better.
Condition of possibility.  For
me, the agency empowerment and
ethics and in my perspective,
the first condition in the
collections of data
conversations centered on
agency, to see collections as
data.  Is to step towards claim
agency and to extend individual
capacity to act.  I acknowledge
the chance of initial alien
AsianAsian.
The book of following image.
In the face of the familiar the
data may seem as a cold path to
discovery.  And yet data is
vibrant with possibility.  And
they are the product of human
design.  And world view.  And
reclimation of agency is
recognizing and interpreting the
data.  By figuring collections
of data we seek to make the
facets known to the community.
There is a path towards data and
I will talk about one.  Depends
on the notion of accordance.
It's a problematic approach
where I ask seemingly obvious
questions, what it does to
resolve a question.  To consider
the additional function it
aboards with data.  Something
that comprise the numerical
distance that speaks to each
other across great distances.
As this path is reversed I think
it's really helpful to think on
Martin Muhler's reminder that
every surrogate has its own
query potential and for some
exceeds that as the original.
As a physical object the
newspaper readily affords
certain types of functions.  You
can pick it up.
You can fold it.  You can unfold
it.  You can orient yourself to
a relatively significant amount
of hetero
genius conduct.  Once you
digitize it, it becomes
familiar.  Data being leveraged
to enhanced the ability to
enchance upon it at microscopic
level.  Paradigm that extends
familiar application for working
with the object, the ability to
browse, ability to search and
to read.
While the platform is there,
committed with API and get bulk
access to the data.
These preparations have since
supported a number of projects
that explore the collection.
This was covered a bit earlier
and I'm going to talk about it
in more detail.  And funded by
the NEH context.  It was one
project, I think it won.  And
identify machine learning over
166 thousand quotations and
verbal illusions from the bibles
across 700 million pages of the
historical newspaper and 56
billion words not only
identified the fa
phenomenon he was speaking but
also structuring the data so
they indicate how often it
intended to occur together.
This act shed the more complex
view on use of the bible to
support the formation of our
varied imagined communities over
time.  Of course, our
collection are not limited to
surrogates to physical objects.
Increasingly we collect
so-called born digital data and
web archive collections, and
throughout the world.
Institutions large and small.  A
key component of the
orientation with respect to the
collection is learning how to
recognize what the nature is for
supporting exploration of
questions and will continue the
case that we will have users
that want to interact with the
archives as the user may have
interacted with them them at the
time them at the time of the
formation in a web browser and
mobile device and so forth and
if we feel back the layer for
under lining visible structures,
it becomes
possible to ask the questions.
Consider the works on Canadian
interest parties.  In the
groups has drawn connections to
the cross cross Canadian parties
and special interest websites.
data and multi dimensional view
in the activity that may not be
apparent or intelligible without
the awareness of the
possibility, sitting below the
surface of the the push forwards
reaching past and the
collections of data conversation
is all about.  The better we
serve our community's ability to
peel back the layer of covering
seemingly mundane interactions
of everyday life in order to
encover the ability to
act.
Empowerment.  In order to do the
work that lies ahead we need to
be empowered to think
differently.  When I say we I'm
referring to the builders at the
inheritage institutions large
and small.  When I say we must
have the power, I refer to the
contents and the extent of
moving towards the
actualization.  I will speak now
to the respect of libraries in
particular since that is the
community that I am most
familiar with.  University
collections with impartial aims,
services with the universal
scope.  In this manner,
libraries are figured like
transaction groups and black
box.  But seriously, down with
the black box.  Libraries are
people.  Individual hands, hopes
and dreams build the
collections we use.  Let's
acknowledge that, celebrate it
and give credit where credit is
due.
Collections of data providing
opportunity.  Who designed the
schema.  Who did the
transcription?  Who decided why
the acquisition should be made
and for whom?  Why did a
normalization occur?  This is
about recognizing the labor and
the value of librarian
contribution crafting the
materials which with a wide
array of communities gain a
sense in the world.  It is also
did the design decision under
lining these collections in
order to give them their fullest
integrity so they can actually
be used to substantiate claims
based on them.  There are many
collections that the data
project can go.  In almost any
direction we will bump into
pre-existing normal for going
about this work and undoubted by
be expectations in terms of
scaleability.  Here are the
chickens if anyone was following
on Twitter.  I apologize that
the expectations
were erased.
But the scaleability question.
That is framing.  To be honesty
am a little bit tired of
scaleability.  It's like the
chicken or the egg debate where
someone says the chicken sprung
and a head and won't consider
the egg.  It's parallel.  And it
needs to happen that way in
order to push the conversation
forward in the space.  Side bar,
I want to thank Katie and
Trevor Munoz who in their piece,
they introduced me, so I am
just going to quote here on the
next show slides because she
really captures this notion of
scaleability that I am trying to
get at.  Highly recommend they
are piece as well.  So when
small projects become big
without changing the nature of
the project we call that
designed futuristic
scaleability.  Scaleability is
possible only at project
elements that do not form
transformative relationships
that might change the project.
But transformative relationships
are the relations for
diversity.
Tying it all together, from what
I would consider a classic
piece although it's probably
only four or five years old to
talk about what Beth gave in the
library, writing on digital
library work and speaking on it.
If you want unusual results
you can't expect this to come
from playing by the usual rules.
A couple of issues typically
arise as librarians have
commitment to save space.
The new ground is broken but the
potential of the work is
committed by outset and has the
scaleability paradigm.
Scaleability cannot be the soul
precondition of possibility in
the collections of data space.
In order for diverse solutions
to occur we must learn to
embrace experimentation, that
accommodates and even embraces
the value of failure as equally
as success.  Some may say that
the ability to engage in this
span of
outcome constitutes the luxury
and I would say to look at
liberal arts colleges by the
research university peers
throughout the countries.  They
are doing the most interesting
work throughout the space and
vastly limited resources xar
comparatively.  As previously
mentioned it is often the case
that there is expectation and
little is done administratively
to free up time and contribute
to new projects. I find more
often than not that personal
interests or excitement of what
you might call the preconditions
of empowerment not the barrier
collection of data work but
simply a question of time and
resolution can be traced to miss
match between goals and
reality.
Simply put, let's free people up
to empower themselves in their
work whether that's collection
of data work or another new
initiative.  In my work, they
are enthusiastic and public
about their experience.
Actually have a menu on their
website.  And they are currently
experiments listed there.  They
are all disabled.  Does this
mean they failed?  Can we
consider the possibility that
they may have been meant to
fail?  fail?  They may actually
be a
good thing, these failures.
failures.  Asfailures.  As we
move out of the experimental
menu of the experimental menu,
we have the collection by color,
by
concordance.  Why not?  I bet
the features started with the
mind of someone who had the
power to explore, started.  And
in this way we would miss one of
the experiments in in action
and what we are seeing is a
really novel solution to
addressing a particularly
challenging program, essentially
they
are trying to deal with
differing scales between an
object in a collection and how
to challenge thumb nails that
convey things to the user.  If
you took a distance from the
chair maybe 5 feet and a stencil
from 8 inches above, how do you
create an equivalent thumbnail.
One of the things that they
did in the lab and wrote a
python script to generate
shanon's values for each image
to inch which part of the image
would actually be cropped so
they can convey the most
information. The British library
labs have been doing fantastic
work in the space for years now.
Lauren McGregar and
James Bakerr.  I feel like they
have been eating everyone's
lunch a little bit, especially
in the national library space.
But yeah, they're an
enterprising group and engage in
the scholarship of the
institution and work towards
releasing a whole different type
of collection of data.  You may
have heard of the pioneering
work extracting millions of
images from historical text and
make them under a license.
Subsequently, they have
encouraged the number of
competitions working with the
collection and data.  These
efforts are not purely about
simplicity but provide the way
that we compare access to
collections and have concrete
reciprocal benefits. In this
case, Mario's experimentation
with machine learning and semi
automated classification has
meta data for the flicker
release and subseting for
really, you know, interesting
features and all of a sudden
becomes possible for collection
by portrait.  It's kind of cool.
I'm not sure what the
application would be but it's a
cool function.  There are a
number of libraries in north
America that have been working
in the space as well.  I am
formerly at Michigan state
university.  For those who are
not big fans of college football
that is the green helmet up
there on the left.  While our
collections across the board
here differed in scope, we all
shared in common a desire to
explore and release our
collections of data in order to
encourage traditional types of
use.  The process in my case was
fairly straightforward.
Identifying existing digital
collections and evaluate the
possibilities in the data, are
they unstructured?  Are they
structured?  What is the quality
of MPR?  Has it been
transcribed?  The representative
is the data given to its
relationship of the fatality of
the collection.  The next step
was to create derivatives and
out with the thumb nails and in
with the PDFs and the plain text
derivatives and wrap all of the
above with the documentation
for boarding computational use.
Subsequently this data was used
for digital humanities and
became a text set in a text
analysis program and sought
after for
a computational analysis in
American cooking.
If we not treated this
collection of data and not
treated it as such, it's not
likely that it would have seen
these types of views.  Work of
this kind only becomes possible
when individual people are still
empowered
to pursue their passion, the
cost of that self-actualization
is time and the confidence to
perceive projects whether they
succeed or fail.
Really, should be a goal.
That said, embracing failure
doesn't mean doing our work
without intention to ethics.  We
must commit the
transparency, inclusivey and
respect for what lies ahead.  A
number of things are raised in
the space.  Some things are new
and others are familiar and
possibly more complex in the
light of the medium. The first
issue relates to transparency in
the process of collection
building.  How is the data
processed?  What was left in?
What was left out?
Why?  The representative of the
data.  What bias of the
organization does the data
request.  And I think for a
number of reasons the
data-driven journalism has some
qualities that we can learn from
as we consider these questions.
feed supplemented an article
shown here with a blog post that
links the date methods and
analysis and code to produce the
work.  We see the level of
transparency is quite granular
and they go down and links to
the python notebook that that
has that has the
code, and the generated data to
support
that particular claim.
As I cast my eye over this
approach, I wonder what it can
teach us in libraries for data.
Will our users expect similar
levels of transparency and
computational processes and what
we consider access to.  They
may.  Transparency in the same
may actually
be a precondition use.  As
collections of data are
developed we cannot lose sight
of interest beyond north
American borders and must have
an inclusive vision, global
outlook of humanities reminds
us, there is a wider world to
engage with and can think deeply
about how we invest.  Part of
that consideration is
linguistics.  Part of that
consideration speaks to
questioning, assumptions of
normal access to computational
infrastructure.  To the model
for computing, we can develop a
model for collection and data
conversations that is more
expansive than it would be
otherwise.  Across the board we
require acts of bravery large
and small to make our
collections as open as possible.
A few things make the light of
curiosity die. More like quickly
when they give you the
accessibility.  This is
something that I have witnessed
myself from primary school
teachers when I worked at the
communication outreach at the
Library of Congress to
researchers interested in large
scale text analysis in the large
scale university that is I
worked at and I would argue that
this is a shining light in this
space, I am very grateful for
it.  More collections equal more
access which in turn equals
more inclusive range of use.
Now this is important.
Collections of data represent
lived experience.  And we should
respect that.  Traces of human
activity are not butterflied to
be collected catalogs and
finished in 21st century
cabinets of curiosity.
Documenting the now focuses on
capturing the form of data, the
tweaks.  While the technical
development is impressive, is
also presents an approach that
models how we might engage in
collection of data activity that
is predicated on sustained
attempts to ground the act of
collection in community needs.
Documenting the now approach is
the work in a number of
different ways and I
am particularly intrueinged by
Bergis Jules'
thoughts of what lies ahead
when it refers to data producers
and data collectors.  I hope we
see more of this in the space.
A contract after all is about
the terms of the agreement.
It's about mutual respect.  In
her interview with the LA review
of books, Jessica Marie Johnson
hits upon one of the key
sailings of our collections,
their inclusivity and
representativeness, and she like
many others thought necessity
by the meaning of fragment in
holdings to testify for
practices of systemic biases and
did nothing less
than the historic.  Sometimes
it's the says that the history
is buried underneath the har
monized approach to collection.
and searches different in the
historical records.  In the case
of the real face of white
Australia, Tim Shera leveraged
the detection script to
automatically have faces in the
documents and place them front
and center to give people
privacy.  In doing so, Shera
utilized the data-oriented
approach in stories that might
have otherwise been told.  As we
transition our historical
sources to meet the collection
of data mark, we
must be conflicted for the
English language that is
predominant in the legacy
history.  This is born from the
micro development legacy
policies and subsequently many
digital projects have worked
from the data sources which has
projects reenforcing a less
clearistic view of the world.
Presently we have opportunity to
create opportunities of data to
better support the community
that craft narratives of a
greater version of realities.
Jarred Drake reminds us we are
all complicit in the creation of
collection and reenforce the
equity.  In order to improve we
must face that reality.  Really
look at it.  And aim to do
better. As I have mentioned
throughout this talk,
collections of data provides an
opportunity to be better.  There
is some initial efforts seeking
to improve our work in this
space.  The digital library
federation cultural assessment
group is one promising.  It's
fairly on but geared towards
identifying and questioning what
is under lining the collection
and digital development.  You
may have noticed throughout that
talk that I didn't talk much
about infrastructure with any
degree of specificity.  Or
really anything particularly
technical in nature.  It wasn't
my goal to do so.  That said, I
wish it went without saying but
I feel I need to say it any way,
any infrastructure we develop
to push the collections of data
conversation forward
conversation forward must take
place in
an environment that recognizes
and works against historic and
contemporary hostility towards
women, people of color and other
under represented groups.  And
it comes full circle.  There is
an incredible amount of
opportunity that lies ahead.  If
we stay true supporting the
agency as we seek to make
meaning for the data.  If we
empower ourself to be desired by
our own experiment of data, and
if we are guided by an ethics
that focuses on transparenc
transparency, inclusivity and
respect, I trulily believe that
we are heading in a promising
direction.  A direction whose
past starts the core to nothing
less than supporting life that
is worth living.  Thank you.
[Applause]
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Thank you so much
Thomas.  As many of our speakers
generously said they were
honored to be here on stage at
the Library of Congress, but
truly it is our honor to have
them here and my honor to share
the stage with the inspiring and
unbelievable folks.  Thank you
so much for sharing your time
and expertise with us.  So many
of you in the room are also
working on really interesting
projects.  I know the GW book
from the social speed manager
here and the web archiving books
including our own here at the
Library of Congress, we would
really love if you can join us
at the hawk and dove right after
this to continue the
conversation.  We will be
meeting upstairs, a couple of us
will walk over to follow us if
you are not sure where that is.
Video will be posted shortly.
If you registered for the event
you should get an e-mail about
that.  And lastly I just want to
give a big thank you to
everyone who helped make this
possible today and especially
our speakers, the office of
equal opportunity and NAIO
management for supporting us,
the staff at Np
go  NGI and Abbey and the
engineering folks that are here
for the special events and those
of you that read the drafts for
our slides and friends and
colleagues who are available to
run errands during the day.
Thank you so much.  Thank you
all for coming.  Please keep in
touch.  [Applause].